hey there buddy I'm just going we're just
waiting and getting started here pretty soon
there's going to be a lot of visual stuff
today but if you want if you want to just
listen go for it we are
on to extend these days I go on stage and
Discord and I do too much at the same time
so I'll be starting here in about another 3
minutes maybe 5 minutes
I wish there was a way to send audio and
video to just go to the same time
great we can have a great weekend I was just
really busy as usual
all right
get her going to that my mom's got my
smoothies almost gone
is are we going to do we're going to be
and you doing kind of a speedrun I'm going
to do this probably several times because I
want to get really good at it going to be
installing kubernetes from absolute scratch
and probably hit a number of Kinks along the
way
and we now have a entirely provisioned
environment virtual environment to do this
with one vagrant command we built that big
red boat that vagrant file last week man
that included setting up nfs4 storage class
all of which went right
can you go for me be able to monitor the
underlying volume of a PVC so I can see when
is running out of space
all right
so here I am talking into mute again sorry
about that thank you for the reminder so I'm
down to nothing if there's like a noise you
please let me know we can be going through
this pretty quickly I'm going to be
answering questions except when I'm going to
be trying to focus on installing communities
as fast as possible I will be rubber ducky
in talking about through what I'm doing but
the goal here is for me to remember as much
as possible I'm only referring to documents
that are on communities that I owe and then
get home communities project which by the
way reminds me why you need somewhere to go
if you want to get good at this stuff if you
could have to see me until the activities
project
actually let's try this my wife is also
going to be
vacuuming unfortunately nothing I can do
about that so kubernetes
pandemic
the cube ATM application where is Covidien
what is it injury
it is an argument again how's it going
so when you go under two minutes let's do
this g h repo cologne
ronettis / Cube ATM
and we're going to see into Cube ATM and
this is the source code
of could get a comedian Tortura news today
give me a damn fool was built to provide
best practices and Fastpass for critical
base cluster is it supposed to quote a
Kelsey Hightower hard way which means
involving any of your information your own
certificates in anything and installing a
specific executables which is no longer a
thing for the most telling signs of how
outdated that tutorial is Kelsey Hightower
that the hard way is that did it installs
keep Roxie which is now included as a as a
dam and said within the kuebler so it's very
outdated nobody should be doing it if a
phone is actually this is her to get a
minimum viable secure coaster and running as
soon as a friendly way give ATM is a way to
do this give me a new scope with local found
on system
and it carries a plan is intended to be
composed of a building block however the
tools if you install a certificate
certificate will be managed by the ATM
upgrade that you do every time you upgrade
it will get new certs an update for you so
you have to worry about the certs Etc, and
Kim and let's in it and Bubba on sale cuz
you can go into
the source code forlook for comedian
I want where is it where was it looking at I
can't find it now
what to do if I think this just might be
hey Tammy that's why I don't have it
documentation is Socrates cranking requested
on my way to be falling all these stocks
with me
all the stuff is included this is all
communities documentation it's a lot
freezing
but I was looking for the source code and I
can't find it now exclusive all the labs in
left shoulder
no I deleted a move. Cuz yesterday cuz all
they're all the lads into a single a
directory and that's I'm going to recommend
other people do going forward to having him
spread out all over creation and get him as
a total mess and it's completely
unsearchable so I'm putting them all in one
yeah I mean is that about that so
I know where you're going to put it
give me the kind made
Billy Craig get
extreme what's the route the route Kinder
Cobra car or back and then go broken in
and I think they renamed it
where they put I know I found this somewhere
and I can't find it again
there's this the source code for curium has
the phases in it
I want to say that's probably not The Source
cover. And I know that sounds weird but
and I also goes down goals if you just
versus it would be kinder
Canon 70-200 by kind kind of share the same
qualities that I find this interesting
this is this is toilet why haven't even seen
this before that's interesting
I didn't think you even was an operator
I don't know if this is what we're even
looking at actually
I don't think it is actually I think this is
something else
where's the source code I can't find it now
oh there we go that's why I feel better I
don't feel so stupid so they can at it and
that's why I didn't have that repo I don't
have any code in it it's just for
aggravating issues the actual command is on
the community CMD okay that makes sense yeah
yeah it was literally the first line I was
like why don't I have the repo
cuz you don't need it is just documentation
right so let's go
+ 2 communities
it's okay and composes also included now
Mario yeah God I was cuz like was in the
brain
arioso this this is how you know what it
does I don't know I mean I don't remember
which one I looked at but
comedian that uses Cobra was just pain in my
ass but whenever
virgin blah blah blah blah Ukrainian command
and pre-flight concerts U2
Camilla Market in we did that one already we
need to go
Cindy faces yes there we go see the phases
there isthere is there's all the phases so
see the command that we wanted when we do
qbdm
in it which is the command that we run right
to keep it in and it is the command we're
going to be running and here's the source
code
so do they make note of that so that is
acumen in it again and
can you show me a sentence of a successful
look like chart because it is
go to Simplot and it options are in so
you cannot break down the source code and
follow along
new commanding it returns returns to give me
the command OK Google, command and it run
the command in order to see set of Human
Rights control plane
I think we have to go to the API actually
append face and it runner-up in Phase new
pre-flight phase new certs phase New Cube
config phase so each one of these phases is
an abstraction of how you used to have to
install communities by hand so if you want
to read what those faces are doing you can
go read the code there and you can see how
how all the phases go down
you can actually run a specific a security
and then we're going to get ahead of myself
so it's nice to have this code up to see
what's up
but you know and how much that that matters
to people
actually do you want to remember what that
is so I can make a note
how can a cat go
app see you Monday and It. Go
I'm not going to put a related section when
I'm tired of it
can be very enlightening read the source
can you read this source of the qbdm command
which was created specifically
to codify and standardizing codify
and codify the steps of creating
a kubernetes from scratch
insulation
can I have a reference to that
all the time so I want to make out a list
reset or things in the right place we're
going to make allowed to this and in case
you don't know I confirm I can combine
everything into a single Aviary bill so if
you want to follow all of the experimental
work Explorations and blowing things up you
can just go to my lab director so all of the
stuff I do indication why it's going to be
in the lab or is that anything that's
another project is a project you know I can
get them refunded
so we're to meet living in case I'm going to
your favorite local committee man
I don't even know if when you could call it
that
we can probably call it something else it
doesn't have to be vagrant local
I mean I guess it could be Hardway doctor
yeah it's a different one I'm not going to
talk about Alan
the Securities that are we using Docker
which is a fail he can't do it
I kind of want to change this
I don't want to call it all of that I want
to call it Q ATM or from scratch right
they just call it from Q ATM
Wesley College
give me a decent DVD and let's do that it
they aren't you oh yeah absolutely we're
going to say going again right here so
is it from Peabody I'm going to write this
the zoo
install
it's all coronavirus setups communities from
Kam
no it's my my wife vacuum
it's all over it nope don't do that is so
they're going to configure for the vert new
Patek on to that
I'm going to write this I'm going to write
the steps as if someone else wants to do
this lab
yeah this way by the way I can also put on
my notes in here
temperature the next workstation better Mi
install virtualbox
install vagrant
are indebted to Lenox absolutely Lennox all
the way
I need to make a cloud image of
I don't know how to say this we need to do
stand up the
nfsc
fragrance
and if n f s test vagrants environments
so I'm going to watch in this
work is going on too so this stuff right
here is already done
so this is it that my modifying is little
bit
I was if I saw that this event has been
modified over the right so
where did I need to do any of this anymore
so this this actually is way overdue has a
really bad one
and this was actually doing external storage
attached you don't have to do that anymore
all of this stuff is like bad
so this is the part where I wanted Like
Larry my learning I don't want to have to
repeat myself
when I learn as I hate go to this thing and
get up to this one spot here and then we go
on from there
and this provision file swappa anomalous
suffocate we do need to do all of this stuff
we do need to do all this stuff so
so yeah
we're trying to decide if we should if we
should have asked if we should have the if
you should have the lab say hey go sit up
there, Nate is box wax on wax out or if we
should have
or if we should have it still
yeah this you don't need any of this stuff
anymore no you don't need this
continue run time there's a net for certain
that we already known that filters on
because we checked it
alright so you know what I'm just going to
copy it I mean copy it
but first learn of it.
Learn how to
set up 3 machine
NFS vagrant 3
3 v m s hey Grinch memes
with n f s animals
all right so we already did that I did that
and I separated at that learning it was a
separate task to we're going to build on top
of that right
this is two quarters 2 GB Ram 10 GB storage
name control control another one or two
I would imagine he thinks he's with Sandra
Kennedy's components in administrative
Cheetos image credit NFS volume create a
small NFS volume and out all your systems at
the same amount point
at the same at one location / s
set up SSH login to from control to node in
your regenerated certs I don't know if we
actually need to do this part this is just
an administrative thing I feel like that
could come later
I can say bonus
setup SSH logins ice cream now
no we're not going is icy at all here
nothing on the worker notes though
no
I think about that why would we not met him
on over for nodes
yeah but okay that means the storage class
setup on the control box is able to
communicate storage over the network
what you're implying is that the storage
class provider for an FS
takes care of the network mounting and I
don't need him out Amon then points which
and if that's true then yeah we don't need
to
that let me know and that would mean that
there's some sort of magical proxy and going
a lot goingboxing going a lot going on in
the NFL stores class provider
yeah I would be able to chat. We don't want
that
it is a curious company of traction with a
small and if it's volume
at the slashes Melt point
it should be able to be mounted from the
and their workers from the nodes
workers but don't Mount them
acores class provider will cover that
cover a remote access yeah
so you're saying that that that joke already
knows about mounting a defense school I
learned that something to learn today that's
why I'm doing this I want to understand how
that provision of storage and then if it
still works best with our which is pretty
basic requirement for a community's install
vagrant they're not a set of 3 mg with nfsnl
so if you don't know that you need to learn
how to do that we do spend a lot of time
already knew that I haven't done so much I'm
going to just put me on the riverbank and
fall over
I don't know what I put my post position
here PostScript I remove post
vagrants when I can't so we're finally in
the right places to Mike's in here
and let's do
this provision file takes care of the other
stuff that we need to do we actually know a
lot of time doing this we were able to get
container ID working without Docker real sex
in the road project but we're not going to
talk about that right now
yeah we we've had extensive conversations
about rook and and and staff and all that
and and we're doing that but you've still
got to know how to use NFL
nfsi directory external provider versus a
savannah Fest mount
what it what is this
what is it is infested electric drum
provisioner
there's a dark servers are not a word that
uses your existing already could be going to
fist over I was just personal information or
giving a person a ways away we still have to
join our things and get it up get the system
right
this is fantastic though let's definitely
add this to the list of things
that's what this is all about all these
notes
I need to make sure it's standard though
and if anything is like out not standard and
I don't I don't want to use it I want to use
it as much out of the box stuff that people
would expect to use as possible that would
include I don't want to disrupt her stuff
and things like that because I do want to
learn that stuff going forward but I'm
dealing with like older architectures that
how you know the things that I have to
support that's why I'm sticking with it is
Play No Limit Fest
I'm a crazy person volume we have to do it
manually
well what I want to know is
actually I need to look in our internal
structure for our internal system for our
storage class provider for NFS I need to go
look at my phone or anything
yeah wow
yeah
does surprise me at all how people can lose
their shirt on that shit
alright so
we already went through all this provision
we actually got a community's cluster ready
to run qbdm on it this part is already been
done so and I'm going to clean up this file
and improve it right now as a bunch of shit
we don't need in it and I'm going to talk
about what I mean by that so we already did
an NFS vagrant file and thanks for the help
from LBG we've got it so that it's really
fucking amazing very slight of hand and it
uses the modern experimental stuff
and in this is this is like way better than
than anything else will be with you I'm
actually going to copy this in type to send
again because it could for the sake of
learning so the new disc external just
provider does not need the name of the debts
you can do that if you want if you want to
have your disk file be local but you really
don't give a shit the big thing that I miss
and I lost a lot of time when was setting
these environment variables and I'm going to
put those right here
and so we're going to use virtualbox as a
provider of a very experimental
control node one in 02
and this is another thing it's another cool
trick from Ruby which gives you if you do
with index you get a number which we can use
to establish a IP addresses that are
inconsistent and that is something that I
spent a lot of time trying to learn
so we're going to we're going to leave that
in there
all right so so we have a config do you have
the name do the node
we're going to stick with Alma give me the
same hostname do the provider stuff
Orange Box we tried link loan at didn't work
last time
link cloning didn't work I wish it would
still problem without any to remove that
actually
so then we have is a memory
we need the specifications on the cube ATM
sites say you need to get at least two gigs
of RAM on the controller Jen's going to have
one
urgent matters including onl
but what I'm trying to figure out how to add
the batteries in the way that is consistent
with my environment so you know they're
probably better ways out there but I want to
be able to change the batteries
no I don't think Lincoln was ever working I
didn't throw an error though
I mean I don't know we can leave it it's not
hurting
maybe. Was going to bite me after feeling
I mean it's not it's not going to hurt so
that's just about it
Digimon Tri everybody think cloned keeps it
from pulling the bass down every time or
something like that
Vivi memory 2048 unless you're the control
I see now that memory we wanted to be 1024
this is for the averages
and see if you really want someone save you
we only want one see if you
what's the upper Vega file we talked about
this file is the new one I'm doing for
kubernetes this is my old nfs1 only
this is going to have different parameters I
thought about just copying over Direct
there is a lot of stuff that we don't need
in it that was based on original
configuration before I knew about the
experimental stuff like all this file exists
shit we don't need that I may be going here
pretty soon so see if he is memory
fuse memory okay
meet this is the oldest one this is the one
I had back for I knew anything about that
stuff the one on the bottom is a nice clean
happy one that you helped me make and so if
Nichols control I want to see if use this is
how you would normally do disc in the old
days when I can do that we're going to do
the newfangled way of doing disc which is a
lot easier
this is if you be even now recognize this
either if we switch to text or just like so
much easier it's so much easier
else here
yeah I think we can if you want to spend
some pods
yeah yeah why not
yeah I'm just going by the recommendations
from the side so
remember that we probably should have an
else in here because
I mean I can do I can have an overrated but
this is just as well so they don't have the
same memory we're going to give to see if
use to control otherwise we're going to give
one of you if we have control we're also
going to mount a disc
so no. Rihanna.
All right so there we go
and
then we need to do the Shelf we going to run
out of provisioner which is down here we
have that as well
and it doesn't have to go in here in this
could be and takeaways from retrieving your
dad
I mean we don't need any provision just get
off cuz this is just in case you want to
resize this which is the new thing I found
out did not know that before
so in a vision v a vision
traffic is so this is going to run the
provisioner to the network first though
we didn't hear but I don't know
actually kind of think we should do that
first saw you
you should see the network stuff before the
random permit last version of script
so are we going to run the provisions for it
but this doesn't it scp's the file over and
runs it on the system or SSH is on I don't
know how but it gets it effectively it gets
in on their runs it because you can put the
file in a in a separate syntax if you have
been in the networking thing however we did
spend quite a bit of time setting up
and I really love it so a couple of the
conclusions here vagrant does not
it gives by The Faults of bug open on it
this book here this thing here fixes the
fact that it doesn't assign individual Mac
address to the to the virtual machines they
all have the same one and that's annoying
and wrong and then confuse the shit out of
his money and I saw it and so we're going to
turn it over to make out of Mac address even
if it's not really needed because of the
nodding that happens by default everything
gets an address so they don't get the same
IP and say mac address by the Falls if you
don't change anything but if you put
yeah if we if we put
let me put this year
but that's all I can find in your face which
is not really needed as you said yeah
so yeah and we need the eye peas so this is
a trick I think that what you came up with
which uses Ruby's ability to assign so if
you in all the examples you'll see
you know the example just so you know that
being Network private Network like this
seemed like a why are you doing this can't
we just use the default Network and you
actually can you connect to station to that
do all kinds of things but if you want the
VM to be able to talk to each other you have
to do apparently according to me you just an
interface has added with know that being
that we're getting random acts yes he's
getting random at Candy's anytime you're
doing anything with more than one pm and you
wanted to talk to each other make sure you
have a no. Damn Network the end you'll never
have the problem if you don't and every
example they have it but I was like well do
I really need it and then I added and it
works you can listen to everything they just
can't talk to each other actually you know
you can ping each other you just can't talk
to each other by AP which is the whole point
so just add it and if more than one you
might as well do this method because then
you can actually give them consistent IP
numbers that you can in right in your
provisional because your provisional
diagnosis specific IP address in a provision
script and that that's cool
is that means you can script Network related
things like an FS Mouse and stuff and that's
what we did down here so
so there
yeah we were just being ourselves by oh my
God it's working again and then we just
figure out that way it's not going anywhere
that was the strangest debug session I've
had in a long time because I was not
expecting it to be painting itself because
it had the same address and it wasn't it
didn't but we looked at the route said
everything or like wait a second this isn't
riding anywhere it's just going to itself
that was that was some crazy crazy stuff
expert coz on cell
so there I think I think this is enough
actually now let's go ahead and get this
Invader up this I'm going to actually
it's always the case for Network
troubleshooting guess but I mean seriously
fighting the same Mac address come on that
that is not a normal troubleshooting
Discovery everything at the same time when
you know Mac addresses were soldered onto
the board and
no virtualization is like totally blown that
away and extreme amount of work to get this
to work this actually when you when you
finish running this you have a working
kubernetes but I might do it all from
scratch even though I have a script for it
so because
you know I'm going to put down here going to
put
you know what Let's do let's have to
provisioner scripts yeah let's break it up
let's have let's have one that says
base and then let's have
keabadian okay so that way we have two
Provisions right we have a base runner which
we can get rid of this one now think
so now we have a base base provisioner that
gets that gets you base and Fs communities
yeah
well that we have an offence already right
no we don't we don't have enough s I'm going
to open that up again god dammit
we don't have enough fast we didn't we
didn't do it we didn't add the provisioning
sections renfest I realize now
if this provision so yes I think you're
right there we go yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes
IC base manifest
and given him and we'll keep the Basin FS
off
I think it's a great idea and things have
been a little early because here's the thing
sometimes you want to bring up the
environment at a different level to practice
your skills like do you want to practice
doing infest by hand like you have the
solution right there a written information
file right that's how you do it but if you
want to practice it as an exercise you might
want to leave it off so yeah let's break
that up let's break that up right now so
what's the
I'm a copy this provision to base and Fs and
Canadian
I don't know we have been too but Iwe have
been too but I don't know if you needed
I mean I have a separate activity for
setting up NFS mounts
you know make this into mace
copy base into alright so
hanging files yeah I have if you want it if
you want the NFL have someone there it is
right here I have a working and if this was
entirely scripted Professor exp was welcome
welcome welcome let's see anybody who wants
to follow along all the stuff is in my lab
repo and it's under so the nfs1 is entirely
under and it has a Raider the NFS one is
entirely under and it will it will this is
finished we have this completely working and
we got that working because of what he's a
storage cost nothing but as you know we've
been talkin we might not need all that so
Lexie doing multiple levels here so we're
going to say so first of all of us get it to
work so just brings up it just brings up
let's try that I'm just like that and never
going to bring up the bass
and then we'll add layer on and if snrk so
with the with the community stuff we only
need two layer on the base to get has a kill
and everybody thank you Raiders I wish I
knew
I could probably go check my cervix be out
how's it going
yeah fantastic
time to go over to your site here I don't
have that thing that recommends people you
know but I'm sure they can click on your
name
so so what are we doing here we're going
everybody said you Humble Bundle didn't you
didn't say I was pretty
all right so we have so if we just rented a
car as is everything should work and we
should have our networking setup right I
think let's go check and make sure are we
looking at our provisioning that is all
right so I turned swap off just cuz there's
no real reason to we turned off the firewall
we disable the firewall for NFS that goes in
the Manifest stuff let me know if it's all
in a client so this stuff actually goes as
is
hell we can probably just
the swap off stuff needs to go in the cube
ATM that's a cube ATM requirement that is
not a requirement of other stuff
I mean we probably could put the container
engine stuff in it provisioning file make it
say
yeah I mean we could almost make this into
multiple files you know and if ask Integrity
run time
I kind of feel like we could do that ya SE
Lennox
I mean disabling iconx and just say when the
fire all that kind of stays in base all
right let's let's let's do this let's go
back to basis what needs to be in base okay
so we need we need I am update yeah we need
that right we don't need any fests this is
all specific
they don't need to sit by the tables rules
for that we don't need that disabling
selinux that that's kind of a base thing
that we're going to do it and probably don't
need to do that
let me try without it
let's try without it I think you can do
without it let's try that the firewall we
don't need to disable the firewall anymore
we know that
now and this is all the community stuff
which we definitely need
and this is his we can do the communities
installation so is this
and then we just have to give a damn server
and that's all I don't think there's much
stuff to go in base
I was afraid the colonel yeah I mean
I mean yeah that would be fun but I don't I
don't know what kind of raw night yeah
kernel upgrade Hi how are you
kernel upgrade hi there you know not not at
the moment thank you
power wheels for communities where do you
have that
yeah we'll definitely need final rules I
wonder if there's a fire will command for
kubernetes yet I assume no so
and for the colonel that in there to do
I would rather not turn it off as someone
asks if we can avoid it cuz that's obviously
nothing you would do in production right
I don't even know if you needed them update
why why do we have any update in there we
don't need it
when I doing an installation right
I am thinking that people are sick. I don't
want to fire yum update off and go through
all that shit every time
besides we have to add a config manager
before we leave update anyway
so you know what I mean I don't want to do
it twice it's a pain in the ass
cni for the firewall yeah that's true that's
true the point
alright so we got the colonel afraid Cube
ATM
swap is off and if us know we can put it
into something
Henry run time I kind of feel like a you
could be in its own
people would say that container D is not a
part of kubernetes so let's let's do that
let's copy Cube ATM to container you
I like breaking it down like this because I
strictly speaking they don't even list can
they can they can hear her engines on the
community's components webpage it's not a
part of the standard engine components it's
supposed to say prerequisite to kubernetes
it so and I'm putting it in Coop Cube ATM is
kind of
because out there so again this is this is
only necessary
because container team yes
swap is not a container anything container
tea is a thing
Amazon container negativity default
and then we execute that turn on Bering air
filter which is an air filter Bridge
since the smoothies versus crushing boots
yeah I feel like this is not part of
container do you
sissy tell from her sis vs. Coronavirus I
feel like I don't
I also don't think we need to turn off well
we could just turn off the firewall
and we can figure out how to configure the
phone
ain't this time we're getting ahead of
ourselves let's go back let's go back to
base there's nothing in base all right so
I don't think we need to disable sunix we
might want to come over here
black the bike everyday is I know I saw say
about you talk about the poor for her stuff
yeah. Yeah I think we need to dive into the
firewall stuff so let's that's I don't want
to disable the firewall I don't have changed
my mind on that I think disabling the
firewall is cheating you would never do that
at least I don't think you would
let me know if you're if you're on a trusted
Network internal Network I guess you could
no but we don't want to
but we don't want to do that because a lot
of people installing kubernetes in his
public facing right I don't want to do this
fix me I do fire all right
I want to do that alright so
so what what do we have here so do do do do
do do do for however
I do believe this is not an FS not an FS not
an FS
this is an FS not an FS
not and if that's not an FS not an FS no
communities
American face connect with private switch
a separate private network interface
connected to a private to switch interesting
when turn that off from keyboard off
computer 8 a.m. up all right I think we can
actually add r n f s provisioning
stuff here and we don't necessarily
so and I only get one line. What the hell
alright so we get a new firewall
I don't know if we need to do a fresh update
we shouldn't need that
I mean let's put a very uncommon it out we
don't need it I don't seem to be from an NFS
reload yum install NFS utils are busy mind
and we do that everywhere at this is there's
no and if it's over
yeah it's just an offense utils in terms of
packages
and those name is control then mounted
Indiana Pacer otherwise exported I think we
should keep all that we can decide if we
don't want to mount that or not right
I mean we can keep it for mounting it
I didn't install it on the North Coast it's
only on the control right here see
and we could we actually turn off the
workers you say hey I don't need to fucking
now this I don't care I kind of want to do
that just to check and see if this is
working you know and if somebody leave it
here, in and out
and I mean
not necessary for
storage class
my good for testing so if you want to make
sure everything works right you might still
want to mount it maybe we could do it by
hand but
yeah you know I'm saying, I'm saying trying
to find Milan
I want to see my end
I still think we have our PC buying on the
client's right otherwise it can't do any
fast and storage class and fail I'm guessing
I don't know how much it broke or is it how
much of the NFS client as they use on the
client on the name Point notes
I know not so it's something we forgot
I'm finally done with that other file okay
so again we're not using these files right
away
Avid it the reason we broke out this files
you want to be able to layer on the
different layers of configuration so we can
test things and Andre kind of go back to
that point in time kind of like you would do
if you were saving snapshots of remember
something outside
really okay there's there's not
there's just this one oh there it is
or that come from
yeah we are prpc by not everything that's
actually left over
I think that's left over in our in our in
our other one we had to fix that we got to
fix that
and if you have to see mines
enable rpcbind oh because it was a
combination right okay I get it I get it
yeah we combine the two files I screwed up
alright so
if you see my needs to be in everything
oh yeah that's too I saw an entertainment
Fan Fest installed
all right this is good it's nice and nice
and clean now that's what happens when you
combine config files so
a lot of fast got that
I think we are busy but I think it's his
fault with nfsu2 I think I believe it was it
was listed as an individual thing to install
it's not always thank you for that follow
so should we have since Sunday and I have to
see mine and then maybe the firewall rules
and then we have the we have the control
test so this is the only one that gets out
of a server in the export Beer Fest even
though we disabled mountain by the remote
clients in this river runs on everything so
that's why we have a check for the names
that's also why we added hostnames to leave
her file so we can do that kind of
conditional provisioning and keep it in a
single script you know this IP addresses
lockdown based on
the stuff that we did in bigger file has
been a considerable amount of time the other
day learning how to partition which is
unnecessary we debate about whether you
should even put a primary partition without
feeling the whole disk of the volume that
you never going to be purchasing any other
way we could have easily done this without
the one and an stb I just felt uncomfortable
doing that because I don't want to encourage
especially beginner is 2 to an hour format
and then too broad of ice is out of the bed
up for Tisha number at the end at 3 in
common and I didn't want to mess people up
with hey how are you
welcome so
welcome welcome so so we've got
got a lot of stuff going on here okay so I
feel like that is pretty solid
comedian stuff is all over the board but
we're going to have to come back that we're
going to do this by hand that's why we're
doing this in a way to capture what we do by
hand into our provisional script so that if
we are one of them, that line we can
actually use the same bigger file to
provision a full kubernetes cluster
including a full standing up of like the
swords class and get ready and all that he
wants everything we can actually do all of
that and the command line
as far as I know I do and it has to happen
after the other provisioning so and there's
some like delays is going to be interesting
to see how well we can we can actually go
that easily. It is definitely my Nexus
and so yeah let's go back in and try that
I see you're no JS app low so let's see
I think I think we're going to go I'm going
to cancel this one here again and again
we're going to run dread
this vagrant file here I didn't ever get
hers over here
here's the last Busan anything I'm doing
with regard to the booths will be written
there I'll ask your questions shall be
answered in my about Paige this is
this is Papa West right now but I'd
recommend doing Linux Mint if you can I'm
just kind of married to this one right now
I think you and I are going to kiss so
there's nothing in base right now so we can
do that
we could do NFS I really don't give a shit
about anifest right now cuz I want to get to
the qbdm installation so that's why I have
this in kind of a sectional way we probably
could do container team I I don't know
though I feel like
I feel like I need to go through the steps
of installing container to again even though
that is not technically a part of kubernetes
installing container d
it's is populist yep
and let's look at container date so
it is if you're an atom and yes it is
absolutely is but if it was on that test it
wouldn't be on the test and I figure there's
nothing about setting up container to your
doctor c e or anything like that they would
ever be on a kubernetes certification it's
definitely require knowledge for an
infrastructure engineer who hands it over to
the community's person but I'm in Instagram
yeah I'm over there but I don't do a lot
over there very much so so let's see here
I'm going to do
we don't need them update
we actually do need an update after
evacuation manager change so I can go ahead
and put that here
if it is Sunil Rana can cluster yeah I shall
try some Lenox jokes Lola
absolutely should we come install container
d
I can hear you can fig and he's a
configuration file and enable Community this
goes on everything we're going to do the
bridge stuff and Kennedy my probe to get
that going set for crisis me of mail this
six like container is and confirm for me LBG
this to me is is is
this is kubernetes only configuration right
here yeah I figure Kris a deal I agree do
you think I should be in community or
something you probably have it be its own
thing
I feel like this is kubernetes related
information right here
this is something I can use for a new
modules
but this isn't but this says we put this in
a container d.com so
and what do we do there do you think this is
needed for container D or do you think that
we should put it in Michigan
our son is he on our yeah yes
well that's that was the name that we chose
we can put any name there but I'm trying to
decide is whether this new mod Pro Bowl
relay and BR filter this is a part of
container t
but yeah yeah
but then but we're putting mod loads opening
module Lowe's inside of retainer d
you know I kind of feel like
I want to put them here
I don't know
at this moment overlay stuff
took these things these iptables rules are
not model ivr filter so let's just take this
out
but you have to do a system CDL reload you
think your new container D to the
coronavirus cough
yeah but this is what this is going in
modules load and this is going assistant
uchealth I'm saying
cell
and I only want to do one sister sissy to
system reset
I mean
yeah
yeah I figured this is
It's really till this these things are
prerequisites for container T they are kind
of like bass things that need to be at it I
would think
and multiple things have requirements on
them you know
I wonder if that stuff goes into base system
config I don't know
I mean they're they're not they're only need
it back already is out so I don't know I
kind of maybe breaking detainer tea and
system use a bad idea
maybe we should keep them together
call Monroe on ansible oh you do
turn off my LEDs yeah
yeah I don't know
installing, packages yeah I was going to put
that in like Bass
all your base
yeah I I think it does volume base
I don't like that it's container do you do
you know
because if we pull it out it's like it's
like if I go to read it it's like
it doesn't matter if I'm trying to use this
to like get a handle on what's required I'm
going to be confused
because I'm going to be like well you know
this is required for container to do, but
it's actually required for a lot of other
things right
I don't need that how's it going wow thank
you
you see them put them in a tomatoes and if
this is kefir yeah
kubernetes we're going to actually combine
all this
yeah I'm going to confirm you can find them
all
cacique manager
Zillow swap is it going to be saying
Integrity run time is it covered Eddie's
thing
say Mossy Lennox is not a pretty thing
disable the firewall is of Granny singing
this is going to be something and then do
that he's so I'm making a Command Decision
the things going so we're just going to do
I'm going to change the kids Gates
all right so Basin FS communities no
bass B base could be where we turn off SE
Linux and it could be where we afraid the
colonel
so I want to leave it because we might we
might need it
yeah I mean we haven't got that far but
this is kind of annoying me though because
it's going to do the full communion since no
I don't want that I just want to hear you
set up
that's the reason I broke it out I wanted to
go all the way up to the point where I have
to install Cube ATM and I mean
you know what I'm going back to my original
if I want to be part of Base I don't want to
separate it up because it's a kubernetes is
the thing that requires that configuration
so if I put it in base it's like you know I
don't I see sequentially it makes sense but
I'm learning why is it doesn't make sense to
separate that out because I don't know what
needs it and I mean it's like
and that's that's
it's the same thing we could he ready to
even though you know this stuff makes sense
Overland by filter yeah I'm going to do you
need a sissy ctla-4 this as well
after you do my provini Assisi jail right
now you don't ever mind that's this right so
this to me is kubernetes Ish stuff
disable firewall communities yes alright I
feel better now so
I mean is it really containery that needs
the overtime BR NFL. I think it is right
modules are still communities
I know it's not cuz I just added the modules
load to here
why does it say okay to Overlay a net filter
I know these applied a lot of things right
the specific okay I think I think I have
enough I think I can agree with something
here
let's we need the stuff in the module
diagram okay so we can say
I am getting on stupid here so
colonel dependencies
so we can upgrade the colonel and then we
can apply these new thing this is Colonel
related right
I am so sorry that God dammit
god dammit
yeah so what let's say
I don't know we can do modular we could say
what is our Auto it is anyway are they
are you saying I don't need to do that to
disable and see
let's see if it blows up and it's not needed
I'm a v if I don't even fuck with my curl
test if these are in fact
can I text with him oh keeping is going to
check for them in the mods
yeah that's what we had to Adams remember we
failed Okay so so that means it
three-point I remember I remember that
actually know we have that are so I kind of
feel like we need to have it I'm sorry to
say this but I really feel like we need to
have that in the communities thing because
otherwise it's fine right. That's how I know
it belongs in Basin and then the container
he needs it
but I feel like that's a community's thing
is anything really fine disabling swap that
security requirement you know I'm saying so
let's not continue run time
right
I feel better about this
now if we lived at off a little fell for his
from him
yeah so backstabbing file I do want to get
all the way to continue to run without your
knees
so this this should be enough to guarantee
on it and then we should do some Trio set up
right
is it isn't Chrissy Taylor greatest hits
that's in a container thing right no is that
you can hear anything I don't know I'm
pretty new to it I use this money last week
it's already alright so let's add a note
here to to do that let's say
disable firing communities
cuz if you want yeah
and there are two deer here for that alright
so
wait when we haven't seen each other still I
haven't got rid of that
I'm just saying like I see Lenox like twice
I think we are yes
oh nice thank you I'll go look at that when
we are. I don't know if I want to add it
right now cuz
kind of out of scope
yum install cubelets
hey there if it's
I'll put it here as a reference
all right so I feel good
but that so when you go all the way to
container if we get if we go all the way
into getting container you then we can
simulate I am now handing the system off to
you communities team I have done my job and
I like simulating that separation because
that's a very real world scenario we have an
infrastructure team that's exactly what they
do when they tell us how should we they ask
that we modify our images of a blow when you
when you put on then we can do our own thing
and then you will put your stuff on there
and then you know they had it off
so what's that wizard in your mind
I probably mine
I talked about a slack ding it hasn't been
one recently on my side
Community steam here great passing
credentials
right
it's too close it wasn't mine I was not mine
so
I'm hungry, you take a break alright let's
run this shit Joey
so whatwhat have we accomplished we have
moved
are working nfs3 VM cluster
into our community project Bob space and
we've broken out the base nfsu Cantera T
provisioning so that after this runs
we should have everything necessary to set
up a combination of army using comedian and
we've also broken out the stuff that I
already did already actually did all this
and
we got two commands custom running last week
it doing this what's wrong with your memory
oh yeah it is all right Mr o c d
and
yeah I wish I deliver this there is no I
need to get a good realtor on that has like
a language to ever built in I could be nice
alright so
to hear it where you going looking at right
now we're looking at our completed a torrent
file to a boy when you bringing me
kind of scary
I guess we're getting a free unboxing
session here
I'm strong nor do I
I'm going to get I'm going to get trolled on
stream here
and here I know
Vector 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2
yes it's the girl and the guy that's which
is not true at all you do is fill the number
ianieri before but
no they're not slippers are there plushies
but I I wanted the
golang marketing it says
and while ago for has a yes what is the
other one are you sad that I didn't have
something for you Doris
do you want the pink one cuz you're so pink
oh shit
Sam thinks she's just got more toys ripped
the fuck apart she is she's like looking at
me like you can let me read
like where's my where's my toy where's my
toy how come you get it too and I don't get
a toy
oh my God is a remarkably satisfying
also their little shirts come off
yeah they're little shirts come off you can
take their little shirts if you want to you
can you can take him home
I'm running out of room for my plushies
have to make it like an entire shelf just
for the fuzzies
I'm the cutest in the house yeah exactly
what's this one gopher plushie stuffed
animals
oh God don't follow honey can I hear meet
Mozzy he purrs
is it even say it says go for a plush
stuffed animals for ages 14 and up
includes pellets to make thepellets to make
the bottom-heavy okay okay hand wash only
thank you from the go Community made with
love by golang marketing LTD
manufactured in Shenzhen the Shenzhen
Ki Hong Shang toy manufacturing company has
made in Shenzhen
let's make a surprise or not creepy at all
all right
all right we got to go in the guy you're
awake near ma that you have to take a seat.
I'm working sort of I know it's hard to tell
by the playing with the plushies and I'm
doing
yes sir Eva you got Fireball I can't touch
that shit
because it will burn my bottom he got he got
some firewall tequila
but I probably could drink what is this oh
my God
out hey where do skizzers can I have the
schedule back please
my love look at this
show that is like the perfect hat it's not
too heavy
you're welcome don't call me honey
this this this is awesome this is this is a
cap this is a cap that was designed for the
military because it's like Ultra Ultra
lightweight and yet still the absorbs
sweatshirt
it's so cool
it's okay even has it has a place right here
so you can like attach things
has a place right here so you can attach
things
now we got is perfect it's not it's perfect
it's not too hot not too cold
hey my glasses
oh my god is perfect as perfect
I have like a I have a sticker that says
fuck you I should put that right here it's
people now
oh yes that is a median
oh they're both large has nice it's called a
rain just like for people who shoot and shit
which is not mean
it has a pocket in a kiwi then it look it's
got a pocket if it's got a pocket in the Hat
I love it
I love it I love it
hello velcro sticker things you can put like
what rank you are equal your sergeant badges
up there's mean
yeah I love that I'm going to go right there
apparently I was supposed to take a break
I promise we shall return to the building I
mean to the Rays Madness n e s
I said to clean up all this trash can put
this a black one is a black one yeah
black like your soul
we're going to name them I think they have
names already I think the Gopher ones have
names already I don't know
that's not going to work all right just more
stuff to make dust on my desk
I'm kind of hungry I won't lie so
imma take a 10-minute break and we can back
what time is it we can back what time is it
3:30 and 3:40
I'm going to run it go for a gofin
actually this is actually run this thing and
see if it works and will then take a nice
break either a celebratory or
you know I got Victorious Hail the
Conquering Heroes kind of thing or not
alright so vagrant statues
do we have any vagrants running no do we
have a global
we have any Global vagrants running new
wonderful wonderful that we can actually
take a break and you can like take bets to
see if it's going to work
ship it ship ship it
that would be a no God dammit
please fix the errors you dumb ass and come
back again later this is must be unique
NFL who oh you got a credit card
oh God you got a business credit card now
separate accounts as soon as she can Shuffle
the way all of her secret money
that she also runs our business with nothing
nothing
I thought I hear actually you have made a
lot of money for artists
that would be ideal it's generally the goal
and believe me it's hard
Pro tip make more money than you spend
Pro tip make more money than you spend now
we have something to click
how long are Clips by the way I like 5
Seconds right
latest Hispanic for buddy then Link phone
no I don't think it should be
I think I have a problem that's what I think
why is it this vb.com
yeah
I don't know everyone I don't know I do not
know it says
the following this names are defined
multiple times in this configuration for the
game control
I don't I mean I feel like it had to be in
the provider and did it not
let's try
I could have swore the distaff had to be
inside of the VB thing
Isaac associations yes
I will and we don't do a lot of
customizations we talked about that is
something I want to tell everybody who's
gonna be going to the beginner boost for a
2022 on the first fucking day we're going to
install Linux and start doing something
we are not going to talk about
talk about audited active cabinets and all
that stuff when I can do that I'm getting
rid of it all the time so you'll I mean
during am a kind of sessions like that you
can pick that up you can read about that you
can watch the videos about of the we're
going to jump right in and do the skill
stuff I still think learning to learn is the
primary school you need to learn but I would
rather we do it together and you just got to
pick it up by osmosis rather than sitting
there talking about it
yeah just like everything else I'm going to
be doing a lot of projects that are going to
teach us the things that we're going to be
doing instead of talking about doing the
things which you know everybody know 70% of
learning is from doing it so that's a big
big we'll have time to do a lot of talk and
I tend to talk a lot so
you're trying to be Chappell
yeah and it's that the stuff that's in it is
is going to change last night no kidding I
woke up and I was given a message from God
and God said God said Alex Robb
you need to start on the first day by
setting up a virtual machine in virtualbox
that would be a compliment if it was Terry
Davis Davis Vibes I'm probably not I'm
definitely unhinged I'm just letting you
know I'm definitely unhinged you're not as
unhinged as him but
definitely an unhinged category
I want to get my vacation April imagine
nearest well I'm hoping to make it worth
taking vacation for the reason is it goes
those three months is because those are the
exact 3 months that most people have school
off so that includes college and includes
you know high school and stuff like that the
beginner boost is designed to be not saying
that you're going but I've been counting
I've been counting the hours in the stuff we
have to cover and then like we've got to get
going right away we had to go in and do what
we need to see if you need to learn
virtualbox anyway I've decided to that
instead of Docker which is a change from
last year we still need to learn to give me
your regular doctor which is not going to
load it in the Boost and the reason I think
we need to learn to box in the boosted
because then you can walk around with all
your different Linux distros as fast as many
times as you want and that would be a kind
of a challenge for you to do that tried
installing on five different distros using
virtualbox and get really good sampling
different virtual box images so that you can
then make a decision about what you want to
put on your Hardware
when we start the infrastructure boost to
the infrastructure boost in Canada location
looking at the calendar
the the infrastructure engineering booze is
going to expect you to have you know to be
ready to run Linux on hardware and we have
18 weeks now because we combine with another
thing so we are going to cover now that I
have IRL streaming capability you know
through cameras are so we are going to be
it's always free yeah everything's always
free of course I really I really appreciate
it up sponsorships and the subs in putting
the word out there and stuff like that this
is the same stuff I was doing so I
personally I took a full-time job so that I
could financially support this effort and I
get a lot out of it personally I get it
money-wise not so much but I get a lot of
satisfaction out of doing it so when I can
stay with it I get really tired sometimes
cuz I'm old i b i I really do it
it is my goal is to provide some kickass
professional-grade
good learn code save the world people that
is the mantra
let me think that because we had this big I
bet this big fight with my agent and I don't
want to talk about it anywhere here I don't
want to talk about it here you just need to
know that I had this big massive drop
traumatic fight with Canadian because he
called me out on my own private stuff and
then proceeded to trash me everywhere and it
is
no he does not know no but we don't need to
compare look you can go on about his
business I just want to move on but I just
need to tell people if you want to help me
help counter the tide of hate against are
the Vicks rub
and and go out there and do something good
you know what the stuff is going to share it
pass it forward
yeah we have no time to talk about that yeah
internet cloud is bs anyway exactly if I
agree
I agree
so here we go. We've got we've got we're
almost ready I'm feeling very positive about
this I feel like this is actually going to
work
Cloud I'm worried about as it is Lola so
treating symlink
cute little things there believe me
it's fine it's it was not talked about it
since I committed I am an asshole I'm going
to right now I'm an ass-whole you know what
makes me an asshole
I'mma tell you what makes me nuts all I
require you to meet your own potential
I don't tear people down
I require you to meet your own potential and
that makes me push you and say shit that I
mean in good faith the cause has been
causing snowflakes to smelt to melt so when
I say stuff like look at the fucking about
page or somebody asked me what time it is
which I used to rip people a new one Annika
I can say right now I have gotten much
better at that
I want to say I personally got better that
how many times has somebody asked me what
time it was or what my time zone was and
it's right here
it's right there on the screen people would
ask me what time it was I've been called OZO
you are a pretentious ass will just like
everybody said that somebody come in for 2
seconds asked me what time it was and and
what I stream about I said if you read my
about page and they went now I got time for
that I don't want that while you may want to
do that and they are out so you're just an
asshole you could just tell me like no your
the asshole cuz you didn't read my about
Paige realize what time it is right now I'm
people ask me what time it is I said oh it's
right here just have a look here
you see how that's better than what I used
to say what I used to say
I'm going to give you a test I'm going to
give you 30 seconds to evaluate everything
that's on the screen and see if you can find
the time and Mike you're such a dick might
have to be such a dick
hopefully I have people tell me that they
like why are you such a dick like you just
tell me the time when to take me to two
seconds to tell me the time because I love
you that's why because I am preparing you to
not be a clueless moron who doesn't figure
out their own answer to their own questions
I don't want you to be the guy in the
cubicle or the girl in the cubicle who
knocks next door and says hey can you tell
me about it and then it said let me Google
that for you that's why I'm going to push
you and I'm going to be a dick I want to be
an asshole I'm going to require more of you
and but just know that I'm not I'm a like a
military person by do I'm not doing it
because I'm a man so I'm doing it for your
good
I think sometimes it goes up to one minute
what the bed that the lag oh that's true
yeah that possibly could
giving a bit but it still it doesn't you
know oh I see you for the kind like minutes
but you can always look at the screen right
you can say oh wow look at that we're at 400
PN like literally had exactly
credit is simplink
oh my God it actually finished let's let's
move on and stop talking you sound like this
easier with my job and you don't like him
either to write or
do you know the Google yeah if people you
say that to somebody and then some people
come back at you and they say you're such an
asshole and like why can't you just help me
I'm like the thing that bothers me about
that I have to I have to say my rent with my
nice fuzzy Gophers here go duck yourself my
favorite one go duck yourself when somebody
is an asshole
ask yourself who is the greater asshole
the person who barges into your space taking
your time which may be upwards of $100 an
hour
to answer a question that you could have
taken 2 seconds to Google on your own but
you were too fucking lazy to look it up
who's the greater asshole
the person who doesn't do the search and
comes in and then calls you an asshole for
not answering your question or the person
who does he even let the fucking finger to
do their own research
is it when when you have that reaction from
people like that suits you or me part of its
love and it's like hey we want to push you
to answer your questions become a better
person and the other part of it's like get
the fuck out of my face because you little
prick didn't even bother to do any of the
research on your own how dare you and that
comes off as an asshole are pedantic you
have you brace you're smarter than a minute
to come up with all kinds of reasons to make
you the enemy when in fact they were the one
who invaded your space wasted your time and
didn't even lift a finger to try to help
themselves and those people need to die
I don't mean literally die that way of
thinking needs to diet needs to cease to
exist
you know and I that's that if that makes me
an asshole fine I'm a fucking asshole I'm an
unhinged pretentious
asshole if if you're going to call me that
great
but don't waste my time don't waste my time
and I will guide your time is so very nice
actually is back in tucking time is valuable
all right give me a give me a plus use
camera flash shoes
you can just answer that question for me
it isn't so much I'm just doing that right
there are they did you just answer my
question will be done here we've been moving
on anything
you wouldn't learn anything you would have
went away and understand the next person
wasted their time and then they're like for
the next for the next person in the whole
entire time you're actually hurting yourself
Idaho time you're hurting yourself can I go
for free for me
and it sucks in all things worked well I'm
glad you mentioned that I have like bitten
my wife's head off when she walks in the
door in the middle of like some real
everybody knows I'm not a particular Dakota
Frankel tell you but I when I get really
really into some really hard shit with first
thing or something walks in and interrupt me
and I lose my train of thought people
understand and I T E especially if you're
over 50 maintaining your train of thought is
really critical this is why open floor plans
are moronic they're not scientific or
anything and IBM blocks everybody in their
own room with a big fucken picked or they
can lock why not so they can jack off in
there or something it's so that they can
actually get shit done and enter flowstate
Zone and have everybody the external and
then really really make huge breakthroughs
and they understand that and they always
have and it's one thing about IBM I really
admire
so young it doesn't work in your Castle is
your solution
Overstock welcome so
so yeah we're going to do
I think is working actually after all that
talking I had to rent had to do something
with all the time while my code was
compiling message open. Thanks for the
response thank you so much major elk they
get in sponsorship if you're out there still
a bucks a month that's very nice thank you
very much for that it is supposed to be
inside the Ice Cube
yeah right so let's go back let's see if we
have this all worked we should happen to
energy on if every one of these systems so
let's do that let's do vagrant
survey current status first well what have
you tried yeah
yeah oh God that's a great way to do it then
it's a great word
oh I got I got to put that that is such a
great idea
I love that term you know what are Willis
that is a phenomenal way to deal with people
like that that is not mean
you'll say what what what time is it what
what have you tried
well I haven't tried anything but that's
less of a sin that's that it's brilliant
that is really brilliant
here's a polite question 2
deal with people who would waste your time
with questions they could have answered on
their own
without sounding like an asshole
I love it
I love that I love that I am so happy you
said that I'm going to practice it but what
if you tried
would it would have you read so far
what if what if what if what if you check so
far I haven't checked everything I can't see
anything what do you mean I mean like we got
to get ready and then I'll get to the well
assistant you know I mean
it's from you oh sorry I'll beat you almost
gave me the wrong person credit
amazeum
I like that I like that so much as such a
great idea
it is a great idea I cuz I need help not
being an asshole I do
if I surround myself with my wife in the
plushies maybe people will think I'm an
ass-whole but I haven't asked so I'm still
in that so I just have plushies I'm an
ass-whole with plushies
and a great wife so
I mean if if there's any greater evidence
that I'm not a complete assholes my wife
because she wouldn't love me if I were
in in she knows I'm kind of sending for sure
for goddamn sure
and ask for Jerry computer help yeah it's a
great line help desk
what are you trying I said it like Nick
Burns your company's Computer Guy move
turn on master if I series
I need to like I need to like I used to make
like like an actual frame and then like I
have the plushies and Velcro on the frame
around my around my camera
I was just keep adding plushies like
you know I got to like this guy this guy or
does he doing I actually make me happy I am
not kidding when I touch the plushies do you
like Lord my blood pressure and God knows I
needed
nice plushies nice plushies it's like having
a pet that's hypoallergenic
which is what I needed my pets not
hypoallergenic I'm very allergenic my pain
is very allergenic
what are we doing okay they current control
they could control a new movie from John
Landis
oh that's right vagrants just control
I remember everybody to somebody who
actually sounds out as a sage
I just want you to like take him aside and
say
hey we've been friends for a long time right
I know we've been friends you are we're good
friends right so I just want to share
something with you my good friend
stop fucking pronouncing shush it says this
age
yeah you sure then yeah I just rush into the
coasteroh my God
have a good weekend yes is passing over yeah
why not why the fuck not
yes
well I'm on the thing I'm on the thing with
the thing do I have Greek osito no I don't
because I don't know karate system do I have
to care team
how would we even know that she's Shish
Shish
hell I don't know do we have nothing here
buck
fuck me running that's a good for Robin Hood
from the 1980s
fuck me cleared it fuck me cleared it
NFL Saturday hey Dre
license for me by saying Shish everytime you
say SSH
that's a very qualified stroller right there
that's a wife who knows how to troll
wait this is a the container that I owe is
not installed I guess it is
am I going to say it yum has way better
output it does yum is so much easier to read
look at how easy that is to read
you think as Baseline for Mike's house
machines
she feeling good I don't think Dad's to be
able to work anymore
shit we're going to start needing to do a
lot more of that second base myself I used
to run by Steel by Steel on it nobody here
remembers best deal anybody remember but
still
I don't know what the modern equivalent best
deal is
hurting your sisters is best deal Linux it's
a tool that uses the process of hardening a
Linux system of getting a choice with a
lockdown apparently it's still a thing how
old is this news
2007 so it's not that old oh break is coming
up
bushy South American do a do the competition
Judge Margaret yes it's happening big-time
well we definitely did my amount Source like
all our internal stuff to like a whole team
in Brazil when I was there
they fired like 12 people in there in like
18 from Brazil
I was like one of three Americans left on
the company and the team cuz I was a good
deal no protein protein protein don't get
greedy
take as much money as you're worth that's
fair
but keep yourself a good deal because when
they ask comes to chop based on money they
won't care about skills all they care about
is where can we save the most money when it
when it when the tax comes like way from on
high and it says we're having a downsizing
measure they don't look at a seniority and
they don't look at Merritt they look at
dollars and if you are making less than your
peer and you feel bad because you're making
less than your. Probably deserve more than
that you'll still have a job
1 developer as a senior oh God
that's insane yeah I know that's it's really
hard it's hard to compete
I think you'll keep your tools sharp people
11 Cota cell phone it looks like best deal
still a thing
it does
I wonder if
God dammit god dammit
SommeSomme I need to
can I can do that
is where I was just switching and trying to
break into a car now
if you have an oil gas oh yeah yeah I would
I would definitely do that cursed they sent
it first
maybe the shelter second of Santa's Baseline
Destiny you absolutely tack it gives you the
ability to control our own destiny
hands-down specifically server-side
Technologies like Cloud native oh my God you
can fucking write your ticket anywhere with
this stuff you really can curse Quest
first
we're on and and we haven't here to you on
here it which means there's a doctor thing
over here even though there's no darker
we will still continue with the doctor and I
feel very proud of that that's that's not an
easy task although the hardest part of that
is you still have to use the doctor the
doctor i c e repos but you don't you can
stop Integrity that I owe instead of doctors
to you because I know people that I work
with to get that to work and we did so that
makes me feel secure
which is bad I know but getting container D
is like it's like super cool in the cloud
native World getting off of Docker is your
container engine is like really hip right
now if you can do that you're like you're
like cool if you if you still using Docker
see if you'd like
oh my God how can we stop talking to this
guy
I know that's horrible to say Creo is even
more him absolutely if you can get a career
was fucking already at work because it's so
fucking buggy
what I understand back and stuff yeah well
learn the terminal and you'll be at already
ahead right
a shop in Odessa delivering them yes. A
comeback in NBA mobile workstation with my
nieces and that's phenomenal that's
phenomenal if you're doing that and you're
very close eye on your way when skills are
good to have you should still have web
skills I'm not saying don't I just don't
have to focus on them cuz everyone else
those particular thing you'll learn with
Leon places like him
as I said using your production since 1.16
seriously
Kre-O is certainly hip now I have now I have
darker Envy I have container Envy I've
container engine Envy no God damn you
you're going to make me do that aren't you
okay the goal of this particular thing is to
stimulate my work environment so
oh yeah what you do shit you know we can do
a veggie
just for fun cuz I know you're a sadist and
like to do this stuff for fun in my room
which one we can make a provisioning file
that uses Creo yeah we could make a good
day. That's that's provisioning file that's
it says you can tell her that we could do a
creole and then try to get the exact same
thing to work for 30 and then and then you
could really Bragg Dr Ste 103 container one
and a community one and we can do a creole
and you can stay so what's your internal I
don't know what you want to do them all I'll
try with all of them
I tried them all and in my environment I I
just I pull up my Xena doing I'm giving you
bragging rights I'm helping you get bragging
rights so that you can brag about it in a
job interview and also while you're drinking
beer with your buddies at the Lennox me to
or the communities conference I know how
long it's been since I've had my own car
and finally recovering from the divorce and
running my own company and if
my screen is the best thing about best the
best in terms of like compared best is a
best is a superlative inferring that it's
compared to something else it hanging out
isn't the best container orchestration
versus no matter something you have to like
follow that one up for me
do to do do I need a bigger question is why
I converted is right why do you can register
jobs
just go look at the research research to go
research with the average kubernetes
certified administrator makes compared to
the average typescript developer
go to that research and you'll see real fast
then goes then go search for like scarcity
and stuff like that who's posting the jobs
for infrastructure in devops engineers
yeah
as you speak if I don't find anything on
Pershing file directly can explain it not
even so which one Grill is c h i Dash
I think we're done here I think I think we
actually use qbdm I think we're probably
ready to use comedian
so I need to get there because I need to get
back to work here
and you are such a pretty high-end I'm not
I'm not as as fond of doing anything cloud
or anything Cloud infrastructure related is
like crazy ass money
it is I think I think the median salary for
an infrastructure engineer is 150k median
and it need median salary of a web or
typescript developer is about 90 K 1890 k
so and it is only takes another extra two
years or so to learn it
so you know
also I like it because it it would go in
pairs well with security and hacking and I
love to hack in my spare time
when it's one of my great loves is hacking
so I'm not very good at it haven't in a long
time but but I really love hacking and
operation stuff goes really well with
hacking
text but not so much actually that's not
true learning no JavaScript in and all of
that if you're going to be a pen tester and
attack websites which is has been, an attack
vector
is a personal server Farms Alabama that
serves this stuff is still needed is still
needed to know it's absolutely that's all I
absolutely need it I think it's just the
people are migrating over to virtualization
and now they're moving one step further to
containerization and and Yummy Nummies join
the club 12 2013 this stuff all came out as
I know I don't need it round my own servers
and I realized how badly we actually do what
you do what you do for your first record for
Saturday and sat in and given a decent like
oh my God it did all of that for free for me
it's so magical phone like I normally I
don't like magic you know but in this thing
Casey like no I want the magic
sad day for Knotts contract crazy money yeah
yeah 900 per day dude if if you especially
if you're our age and I'm this is an age of
something right so ages and works against
you and for you if you are an older veteran
engineer
you don't let the internet scare you if if
you're an older veteran Lennox engineer Unix
engineer and you layer on cloud skills in
addition to the Decades of experience you
have the people that are my age most of the
people that are my age are making well over
three hundred thousand and they're they're
doing it for her either independently
wealthy millionaires they're doing high and
Contracting their ciccio's their Chief
Architects and and they are making well over
3000 so you know it's it just depends I'm
not making it by the way I'm making a lot
more now than I was offered in writing
250,000 so it's by somebody that I knew more
than I did
good friend and I might who knows I mean I
might go back to that was the Consulting so
I could buy that was like flying around you
know Consulting with French makes and that
was specific I was like really into that I
was like oh my God I can actually be
replying in France every weekend and giving
a presentation that a runner cloud and say
yeah I didn't I didn't I turn it down turn
it down it was in the middle it was in the
middle of actually interviewed so there's a
quick story I actually interviewed with
their you know
sitio and and I there talking to you during
the interview process
the senior Executives that said hire this
guy in 02 the other guy
it was very nice and I would frequently that
she would actually bring her presentations
to me
because your kid was in my mentorship
community who's now in like a kick-ass
private school and she would bring her stuff
to me and I would run through it and I told
her you know what about get lab for CSE just
never heard of it before as if she would she
would bring me her presentations that she
would have me she would like he met them
just for fun and and then she would go
present to these big ass Juno sitio people
over in France French for French banks and
other places like that I don't think of an
issue dominated caught either
that's why I like I'm from
every country you down now but I had a fun
day my wife and I were drinking like wine
out in the garden talking about it and like
oh my God you know and
we were like really playing with it and I
undo the guy the guy told me that the reason
I know that I couldn't do it as a guy the
guy said to me he said
I just want you to know that
you know we don't we don't try to be the
Unicorn we we we try to understand what the
unicorns are doing and help other companies
reproduce with their doing
and it's one of the very first things you
said in the interview is the CTO for a
company that you would definitely know that
I don't think he might have just been one of
the senior Executives I don't know that I
feel like it was at 2. But I don't know that
and he made it very clear at the very
beginning of the interview that this job was
about reproducing its successful
architectures I know it wasn't a fan company
but was a company whose total profit and
value is way more than a thank people keep
saying thank up is I'm like you know unless
you talk about Apple which is like crazy
overvalued there are a lot of companies out
there that are equally as valuable as Google
and others in terms of like total so this is
a consulting firm
iMac I talked about who was
as soon as they said he returned to the huge
ecosystem around communities yeah it did it
really did some people say that's all that
they wanted out of it is they want to know
if they can get a great job
yeah so anyway he said he said that the goal
of this job
what do understand what the unicorns were
doing and helping companies reproduce that
they were doing
I remember telling my wife that is I don't I
don't want that I want to be the fucking
unicorn
I want to chase unicorns only being a
fucking unicorn and it's true it's true and
then and then I realized that if I was going
to do that I would have to hand down I
wasn't ready I was I had 50 people depended
on me for their mentoring and learning and I
was not ready to throw that away at the time
at the time there was no Kobe everything and
we had health insurance we didn't have
health insurance but we were there was no
threat to our apartment and then
how many things happened after that we got
we got kicked out of our apartment because
the guy undercover he wanted to sell it and
get the money out of it and he tells you if
you have it for five years he only gave us a
year that was the second time in a row
within three years of that happened to us by
the way now it's one of the main reasons I
took a corporate job is because because I
did I was sick and tired of the you know you
know relatively low paying corporate job
which is when I say relatively I mean
compared to when I probably could make that
making fun of fifty if that's what you're
wondering. Making that much but I said no I
said no and I it was nice to say know I'm
kind of glad I did it was the right thing to
do
but dumb
I'm by you know who knows we'll see we'll
see what happens I really really love the
company that I work for now that's it it's
it's it's very much a mom-and-pop company
it's a you know that they're doing great
things for the world is very unsexy but a
damned crazy crazy valuation and and money
and they're not afraid of technology and
they have one of the greatest machine
one of the greatest machine-learning groups
in the world and and I really love it I
really love it right now so I'm not in a
real you know pressing that in a real
pressing position did look elsewhere as long
as they let me you know exploring and share
and stuff like that if it becomes to self
stifling and then stops you from do that
then I'll just move I can go anywhere at
this point and I feel better I think you'd
asked me the same thing last year I did not
feel this way I was a little bit panicked
because I needed to get a job that was going
to pay the bills after the whole Cove in
apartment thing
custom set up a management tools change your
driver's job yeah Coronavirus
Carolina Fan company and white box image of
particular space yeah what sort of things to
do in communities enforcer jr. right now I
because I have a lot of coding experience
I've kind of I'm kind of gravitated toward
building communities in ministration tools
so I've been auditing all of our internal
communities apps you know I was put in
charge of like a setting up to for the Hub
and installing that
and so I tend to Ghana straddled the
developer thing I can say need it if he
needed application installed or they want to
explore creating some sort of system monitor
or something I sort of fit into that space
more more than others because I've got a lot
of coding experience for the persistent sore
things
was that for companies that obsolete shit
that was collapsing yeah that's that does
that stresses you out I know what that's
like I know that's like
yeah so that's why I kind of in a kubernetes
operations assistance tools developer and
get really really nice with my with my
that's what I made for IBM specific I even
wrote the network protocol for it
and if I had to get really really you know
to the point of what my real cortex
specialty is that's it it's writing software
and application specifically for
infrastructure Engineering in administration
I am not well we're just going through a
different way
beginning morning. He's damaging Regional
actually that's funny you say that because I
am preparing that guy right now so February
12th through April 30th every Saturday from
noon to 5 I'll be covering at what I think
you need to do to get into communities and
container is having just learned about the
two years ago I had never even seen a doctor
file a written one and now I feel like I can
have a handle on what you need to learn I'm
not I'm not a veteran like lvg but I but I'm
a new beginner which means I've done a lot
of research about what I think you should
learn because I've had to go through it
right and hopefully I'll be certified by
then by July I'm not I'm not really keen on
certification but I thought it would you
know it was worth it in this case
he presented everything our products at
Walmart they gave a Norman fence that's
already including armed guards everything
if I can enter wow it's amazing you just
would not know there's so many companies
that you would just not even believe have
the level of of effect of the promise that
they do and people who limit themselves to
think companies really doing themselves a
disservice there in the world that is
service
did you get it cut me like Exxon to pay half
a million you have 40 people salaries are
you
yeah and not good for tomorrow if it yeah I
cannot deal with answering for other people
it's just not in my personality it's not in
my personality I've tried so hard that I was
a cruise director you know I've been a
president of mission presidents assistant
you know I've done stuff where I wasn't
responsible for other people's performance I
fucking hate it I hate I've been told that I
should consider it by people when I stepped
out and ring training and I'll be home and
they said you you're pretty good at this you
should do I'm like no I don't ever want to
answer for another person's performance and
rest of my life ever
know your day all I know it can and that's
one of the reasons I want to go through this
again speaking of that
on that note letting me stand up I have to
sit up for a while I'm going to stand up for
5 minutes and I'm going to go come back when
we come back we're going to do our Canadian
installation
insulation and if everything goes well we
should have our keeping in insulation
finished and be able to create applications
within the next hour
yeah
it will back the couldn't what the reason
that you see me like even in an apartment
right now you know as we wait my wife does a
residency in Charlotte and then we are
considering moving into a nice Cottage I've
deliberately kept my needs very low because
I want to enjoy what I'm doing
you know sue me
he will say you should you make three times
that money becoming a consultant fly all
around and then responsible for other
people's appointments or anything I could
totally do that shit I know I could do it
but what I want to do it what would the
stress do to me you know what happened
opportunity to go camping that you know
but having like boots-on-the-ground
techskills
I get really uncomfortable when I don't have
boots on the ground techskills because that
is the one thing that ground you no matter
what if you have boots-on-the-ground
techskills other words you know how to shoot
you know how to make stuff you know how to
do is Miss Tracey not a code you can take
that anywhere
if you're a project manager or if you're a
middle manager particular your job is
largely based on seniority I know that's
changed somewhat but you might learn a thing
or two
is it believed involved me Community hours
ago God yeah I will never take a job that's
not remote isn't working remote for 25 years
why would I ever go into the office now
there's no reason
Mike quit before I do
oh thank you for signing up
all right so and thank God for LPG and
people like LBJ in our community they are
way Superior to me for this kind of things
definitely good luck on the interview for a
bit 5
yeah I am cuz I'm doing I'm doing a salad
that means I'm donelet me know I need to go
again
but it's also why I was not talking okay
let's do it ready to go is it legal to put a
mark in this actually
there starts of cube ATM
and it'll go pardon me
all right your second check an email here
shit when I do and you're going to hear
anybody say that right
I've lost my teeth see Alice's
start a timer what time is it I don't have a
timer but once we could we could start timer
turn down. Turn down and sell now we're not
installing a snap I refuse
so first things first this is recap where
are we what do we do when we going to do
next we have three three virtual machines
control only one provision for the standard
companies actually we haven't done that yet
yes no way to do that we actually
we know we didn't install anything we just
there let's do that will do this disgrace FX
install the communities components
and components and and game
so we need so I can put us and prepare for
configuration is sup
so
so what are going to do well this is the
part I have to come remind my cell phone if
you have to install communities rights oh
and by the way what are we reading this from
so if you if you want to read this from the
the guy that's probably important to go do
that let's go let's go to the installing
Cube ATM from the communities documentation
right and then we can do what he using qpdm
to create a cluster so we need to do the
same
so we need to install all the communities
components that's first and then we need to
in
and then we need to install kubernetes
Ephraim given a.m.
this is the main thing that you're here for
him so we need to do
create a small one if that's my amount and
we did that
and and so on
no I'm going to I'm going to guess right now
since I'm doing this kind of a test for
myself what I need to do next so I need to
install cute but we already so
the main components let me restate this
every time the main components of a
kubernetes node R1 some sort of container
engine right strictly speaking this external
to give attendees and not listed in the
credits components on the documentation site
but that's needed you can have that first it
to you have to have a keyboard installed and
cute little cute includes to keep Roxie You
Keep Nash proxy something that runs the dam
itself but it's an important component it s
phone even though it's built in the queue
video I mean to Cuba and then you need he
would itself which is also in key would it's
a little confusing on the
add banana dish into that you need two other
pieces of software you need to keep ATM and
take you back to the damn it said but it's
still an essential component is still within
an event independent as a component keep
Roxie is actually
associated with the cube light even though
it's Run is it a man's head from something
else right when I got that bear bones things
what do you have to install in order to make
a machine into a node you have to install
container engine you have to install Cube
ATM on each of them I used to think you
didn't have to do that that you just need to
keep it on the control plane you do not have
to have qbdm on the workers as well in order
to join us you have to have given him
everywhere and then you have to have CDL if
you want to be able to do testing and stuff
and I keep CDL is the a client for a
controller for talking to the community is
there anyway even though technically you
know you need that on there it is not
required required I don't think but it is a
thing to install and the Q but Mickey what
is the main thing that has to be installed
so there's going to be three packages were
going to install from the community site
security M cubed and and keeps eating them
so how do we do that when we have to go if
we go to the documentation we know they were
going to have to add o and Trinity says to
disable the swap so
yeah we got to disable swap so it's you that
we're going to do this with the control
plane first actually listen to all of them
shall we
yeah let's do that
so big rent control SSH control
and what are you doing we need to install
Millenia turn to swap off swap off there is
a to do is swap off command Sudoku
the swap have off dash
I'm trying to do this by to test my memory I
guess that's alright
hey how's it going
swampfox Bakersfield Oasis
Rock spaces Natural Area a
yeah it's enabled a rate is
what is it now Melissa Levin
figuring SSH into or like node one
R2
car accidents to miss you dash top
yes he swap is on what's another way to go
swap LS
free as well right memory box size
and that's a sticks that are installed at
school I think I knew that free girl free
yes I have swap and it's a swap is off
so swap off Ashley free
so again now we can also
that's we're doing this we can take note of
these things and go back and check them
need to come in at this time let's do that
let's do this one here
I got a cessation 02
CVS in dash after I say I like the
repetition that's helping me to remember
it's so free
free yeah it's ef-s tab where's the swap
swamp nun
and says if his mind contains the word Swap
come in and out
and the sexy try this line show me what it
does so
and actually run it
and you'll see that it works it's using
reacts matches to replacement dash I has any
place that it
and you'll see that FS tab Iowa swap is
coming out now
right so that's all that's doing see what I
should have anyway
yeah I guess I could
seriously dashes but I've been doing it for
decades so yeah
and so all we did is coming out this line
that turns it off
so yeah I'm doing all these steps by hand
just as just as kind of a
practical matter you don't want to mess up
FS have obviously
all right so what else you knew we needed to
see an iPod 7 out
we don't know that this stuff is essential
so I think we actually try to do without
know we I know we did we skip this and we
got burned by it so you can't skip this
and this required for this an iPod
networking except new pots can't talk to
each other if you don't do it you can get
you to bring the readies up with give me the
am enjoying everything but then the pots
can't talk to each other so subtly useless
and I actually did all that so I already hit
that problem I almost kind of want to bring
it up without it and then we can come back
and add it
later maybe let's try that just so you guys
can see so let's actually try to bring
kubernetes up without the scene iPod stuff
okay should be speaking I think this stuff
could probably come after your 21 days
installation what do you think we could try
it this right we're going to skip this part
right
yeah
I guess we do need overlay the netfilter
stuff we need that's for the senior high
yeah I know I look so so so I'm going to see
if I how much of Covidien I can do without
that and we'll come back and added if we can
so this stuff this is how you add
communities repo to yum
I think there's a better command for this
kind of thing
but this is straight out of the
documentation so there's no getting around
this when fortunately
so yeah we're going to have to have
this is when you would have to cut and paste
there's no memorizing it it's a tunnel file
looks like a community's name is communities
may crl name was you cuz you check repo
check gpg keys and exclude and the reason
they have the excludes is so that they
doesn't get out of me updated so it doesn't
get you out of sync with your base
communities and saw on the server what you
want be what you'd stop your stuff from
working so and this is not one that we can
easily do
I'm going to yank this and then I'm going to
run it remote
a vagrant is to Sage actually I think I can
do vagrant SUV
maygrant this is why I do my own buffering
by the way as CPA temp uses an independent
buffer that ended on div cuz sometimes I
like to use my buffers for other things
besides with Cindy I am cuz eunuchs and I
may want to copy this to
look up control Temple off attempt
I think I did it wrong is it file
deploys code in the Survivor to the
configure destination provision Vigor
machine
I need your new Vapor cuz I don't know I
thought I thought there was an SUV I guess
not
I think it's just file here's the sitch
config and put it in this is your big
yeah that's cool I didn't know that
I didn't know about that but add that to my
learning list
I am just curious to see if I can do it
there's another bigger, that doesn't require
then
use of vagrants
since I'm using SSH it's just easier
I guess that's good that mean I kind of
wanted anyway because that would the skills
I be putting into my brain will be what I
would do in real life right
I feel like I want to do that no matter what
it's always going to be the same IP address
right no because it had me to public aid
give me the public and private key vagrant
SSH config
is bugging
easiest way to copy a file
oh that's the one I saw that's why I thought
it existed I saw that the other day
can you file hell is awesome
could a strong community that vagrant that
reminds me it's not bigger than my in my my
file here
. Getting our I don't need this video in
there in 1 L
all right so so what we're going to do I
mean
I think I want to get used to the I know you
can push a single file but just don't file
but I mean I've seen him into it with
England
but I kind of want it I think I I think I
want to do this to say something
plus that also helps people understand how
did USA trade
I don't use a specific for anything so this
will be interesting
now because I look at here I'm going to
pause here this is this should be an example
of when VI kicks ass and eunuchs philosophy
because I should be able to do this I should
be able to go to SSH config and bang bang to
get the filter command and type vagrant SSH.
Config and have it put it in here
yep then we go so it just ran the whole
thing and right from the eye and it plug it
right into their that's because I use the
filter commands VI and that's how I'm
fucking plugin
so that's kind of cool now with that there I
should be able to SSH to control
and I haven't and I like an SUV and
everything that is really really cool
that didn't take me even a few seconds to do
it the fastest way to do this
to open up can I want
and use the filter command
to replace a line with the output of
vagrants could fig and then clean up the
comments
I could do to go see the devil him
you have to rekey yeah depending on
your changes to your configuration you might
have to
rerun this after running on vagrants of
or vision yep
alright so analog in there
I think it is raining very very two locks
yes waiting for Sean for employees code in
this environment to a configure destination
I think Bush washer put a follow-up there
has it gone run Riddim
and let's do that so
so now we can actually just mean a m u s e p
10 buff up their hair
it's true the matter is you don't even have
to be that we could just run it so give me
there it is right there's a buff I'll let me
know you really that we just left the
station I see that it's even better
so every does SSH the file cuz I mean look
what's in it
it gets it to the end of two communities
yep let's give it a shot we should be able
to just ssage that file
I don't know we're going to try
I think I'm going to dash it would work I
meant I mean
yeah it is that we copied over trying to
think of how we could get that all that such
a run
I tried something
yeah it's a single command so
I don't know yeah we just going to do that I
would never can it like that though you bad
person how dare you can't like that you know
better than that I know you do
drunk Mash yeah
there we go I need that worked
so so
if that works then the stuff should be at
the bottom of this
no I should be at the bottom of this
imma try to be right at 2 I do remember
this PA
as early as yep there it is so thank you man
worked
it's actually going to that command hell you
do it like this if you're safe or before i n
control node one no to this is just fun to
do as a stage control temp done and that
will do it for every single system just to
check it though
to check it though going to do an echo on
the command instead of the actual command
alright so
I see that and that should put it in all
three yet leaving out
yeah yeah I guess you could even do that
yeah I take her soon
yeah I know that's why I was upset so I was
afraid of it's only a single command so I
think we can do
and an assassin station control and yet I'd
see what was it revealed e
God damn it I can't remember
temp off
Emory post that damn I got to get I got to
remember this shit and see him repos
kubernetes styrofoam
there we go all right so they all have it if
I really wanted to I could do the same
command to take at it right I could just
as a sage cat this
and no show us all the app so they're all
there
you got SSH is your best friend in this kind
of thing is like really nice right
I don't mean that. I guess there's there's
our notes we did all that work remotely so
we don't even really need to be logged in
it's nice being logged in Powershell no
I don't use pssh what what is pssh
perilous is 4 G oh I've heard about this
I've heard that this I never have looked
into it no
yeah it does the same command a lot across
multiple things that people can do this they
do this wooden and T-Maxx to there's a way
to open up key marks windows on all three
systems that everything you type goes into
all the systems and I haven't figured how to
do that either that's one of the cool too
much things I've never learned
you can open a like how's it going so you
going to have you can open up a 2X window
like this and every single winner will get
the same keystrokes
and I don't know how to do it
I kind of want to know though I saw somebody
doing that when they were doing committee
set up actually so I'm going to take a
rabbit hole
Yeah it's cool so how how can I
simultaneously time
into is it control V
that may be a faster way to find it
Crystal Pace buffers whenever it's a
specific command
tracking laritate through pain suspense like
this loud blancpain it's kind of like you
know how you can you can turn your cursor on
for multiple men have multiple characters in
v-bucks I mean it and it's kind of like that
yeah is that it you found it
synchronize pains on is it really that easy
is it that easy oh my God you guys are the
best y'all are the best
oh that is so cool is that create sync
synchronize team Ox pains
on clear history yeah well
so what we got here we've got
conference link address again these notes
are all available for anybody else he wants
to come fall along or you just joining
this disease has herforecast for here yeah
this this needs to be I got permanent
addition to my team which file
I saw a kubernetes admin doing it they had
like their nose and everything
anything that was cool as it they could they
could copy back and forth while they had
like three workers typing the same joint
command at the same time
yeah it was super cool and I was like woah
and probably are from yeah I mean it's it
sounds a little too good to be true
what I think it's worth looking at you know
so Serie set set synchronize pains on right
I don't think I saw that I took over my my
see my Creator it actually makes two pains
every time so that its base is it out
probably two months it's just supposed to
fucking amazing people complain and people
fight out their best when a manager like
okay that's nice
it's just so crazy awesome Panera Bread
her any email patterns on a field yeah
that's right it's so
set w you guys being stabbed on
I didn't say it that's all we need helmet at
completion that's not that bad
that is not that bad with have completion
yeah that is fucking awesome oh I can't even
raining over here my blancpain
it was just great cuz it could I get scared
out of medically what oh oh my God that is
got to be one of my I got to make a video
about that I can make it for you just that
one thing
all right so so what are you doing here so
cat
temp buff I'm just testing it look there's
no such thing on the file
clear all three of them LS free
oh my God it goes so well with the vagrant
work we've been doing cuz the vagrant
usually brings like one two or three of
machines up you know
that is so awesome oh I got why is anybody
using anything besides he likes I mean
really
oh my God that's so cool I can think of so
many things I can do that
bike run teenagers and all three windows at
the same time with different color
God are in dash r f yeah so
Mmm Mmm Mmm Mmm Mmm Mmm Mmm Ella CPU oh God
how do you just get the kind of CPUs we did
this once and I can't hear what it was
LS CPU h
how do I just get the one
hey looking for it said that she'll be here
in both of them on all of them
is it an RC View
nrz few nope
and which one is I want if I want a quick
one that can you just do that
how do you save your info and that's just
all the stuff we were just doing though
right which one do we want
we want Sheba Coors right so
actually scrap cores out of this
there you go there you go
a a i l s u b l s if you have to dig through
itand I'm trying to figure out a way to not
to do that
oh God Hennessey architecture information
there's an argument for that just gives you
the number and I don't know what it is I can
remember I guess where there is there's one
online offline extended help
let's just make a list of arguments is equal
sign blank are examples of equal CPU or
extended see if you know
and Spencer in Henryville formation space if
you
Nash is it in Prague
oh that's my new favorite that's what I want
number of rocks
now Manning. Use in frock
when you 2
number of processors only
is it threads
what would I want to say here Coors
how can we know that hair yeah mine says 8 I
have a course
right actually no I have 4 CPU for quarters
in 8 whatever
with the other names
see what I'm doing I'm doing some today's
Administration stuff
so is there a number of course
processing units processing units available
going to process
what's the number online processors I like
that
shows the number of
wish maybe that's the number of cores
Camp Rock but and Truck Yeah
save some groups as pretty much it
yep and Crockett today I learn and practice
a thing
and now we can do it on all the machines at
the same time
oh my god there will be this will be known
as as the therapy the time before I learned
about multi-pane synchronization and the day
after the time after it'll it'll be a moment
in time
that is so cool I ate a gusher
Pro tips tips teemix when X
I don't know develops its kind of democracy
tennis should I keep
haha
all right now. Onward and upward all right
so we got our products that we've got our
Roxette we've got our communities thing set
up
keyboard shortcut for it yes we do yeah I
don't I don't know if I need one
is that is my own thing
set my own Knowledge Management tool it's
not nearly finished but it it works
yeah it just sent a tweet out to and it did
that by the way so
get cough but in Brookshire is a siskonpeti
I did not know this did not know this y'all
are real smart
this is I mean this is why I do this I get
to hear this cool thank you I just alright
what's that well let's do this let's do
yum that's why I update because everything
is got to be updated cuz we just had a
kubernetes right
so we're going to add that in all three
systems at the same time
I got count number processes only
as long as it has is his confia going to go
and
this is so much fun this is why I became an
admin
I mean this is the kind of thing if I had to
do it like one of the other I've been
waiting forever right I have to log in and
everything is just had like three open
it's like it's like a race who's going to
win do you think the dual core is going to
win
is it to frock is a Tupac control going to
win and work against the workers or is it
worker they are in that final stretch and
knowed one is catching up on no to a new
yeah I went and then we can actually wait we
can have top in another window
what is stop Thursday sub
a stop is going at it it's a hundred percent
see if you do as a nation
God damn look at all those things my fan is
on it's okay just came up
do do do yeah
a lot of I owe ya hear that
I mean this isn't a really heavy machine so
this is doing pretty damn well for giving
hell you know
it's definitely taxing the the system you
know
because
it's all on the same machine it's all in the
same order when we're getting we're getting
a chance to see what I do hate each other
that was pretty close another done I'll
leave that up just was there
it is still good over here to LA why does
it doesn't get to install that shit so young
that's why install cubelet
Cube CDL and Cube ATM all at one time
ready let the race begin oh shit
oh you know why
we have to we have to we have to force the
cave people out there right now or asking
why did you exclude the thing that you're
just about to add
and the reason we're doing that is because
we never ever ever 1 a.m. update to update
those packages because they will put them
out of sync with the server and really fuck
is up that's why they're in the exclude list
so in order to do that you have to use an
extra command with with yum because of
warnings and it'll tell you if if you get
more than two levels out of
two levels out of date out of sync all of
the components will stop working your keeps
each other because they can't it says nope
I'm sorry you're too far away from the
version and it will separate you two you
never want some dinner and me to ask them if
they batshit but then you don't want to eat
with an update or something so you have them
to exclude least that's not particularly
obvious so it's worth missing because I know
that there is way to do this
I know that there is there is a way there is
disabled excludes for
kubernetes the curb as you're the silly
young thing that I'm not particularly
acquainted with so I'm going to put that on
there
add
Patty up doing you want to eat you had this
this line right here yeah but disable
exclusive kubernetes and your Junior had one
who doesn't know any better is going to not
nagging like I can't I have to be excluded
can you tell me how to do not exclude it and
if we need to save up because X and Y this
saves you from from them so let's try that
I can raise is already up and running
we still want it on even after its up and
running because if you
you always you wanted I think I think you
want to always explicitly
upgrade that stuff right so
when I understand now we need to enable
Kiewit which is on all of them is another
thing I didn't understand and can raise when
I started I just came today
so what I want to say here
it was not intuitive to me when some people
use the term control playing at work and I
was just like that I was like what are you
talking about are they computer is it so I'm
going to restate this for myself and others
a kubernetes node is a machine that is
running the cubits
that's the simple definition in the cupid
includes Senior Care proxy something.
That's a simple answer there
here's another thing it's not completely
into it which seems obvious to a lot of
communities people probably they control
plane itself if we're supposed to control
plane a control plane is a kubernetes node
that is also running the components of the
control plane namely at CD controller and
all that then Master Control kind of things
right
and that's what makes the control plane
here's here's here's the thing is not
completely obvious to beginners like me the
control plane is a node
you might not use it very much but it in
every other way is to know. And that's good
because when you want to go test everything
in the first place you should test to see if
everything is working is on that system
because that system you can test whether it
has no keep CDL and everything working
because itself itself in itself is a note so
step one get your machine set-up provisioned
it should be multiple those yes we're not
going to get into Aha and all that stuff you
should be multiple nose bit each each node
is a redundant copy of control and it done
actually confused at the shit out of people
because they control the control plane
control plane is a role for a node
control plane is a roll
of a node and and it is Patrick roces
absolutely right you should never just have
one known you control playing that stupid
ride you should have 3-g have 3-g 4-H a
minimum of three for a chain be here we're
doing testing and stuff right but if you're
doing is the minimum you want is 3 in in a
in a perfect world all three of them should
be a different availability Zone which means
you know there's some sort of physical
separation between them will not tolerate
lower than 5 millisecond latency point 10 at
the maximum I we read about this recently
and we actually at work here I will share
there was an open shift deployment they
tried to put one of their availability
whether a chain control play notes in in the
cloud and then leave the rest on friend and
then it was well over 10
at 10 ms latency it was well over 10 ms
latency and it destroy the whole cluster so
you can't do that then I have the numbers
written down somewhere but the optimal
latency is point is the think point to Ms or
to Ms yeah yeah so it's it's just really
sensitive I am I get exact numbers for you
if you're going to quote me on that
I have it in my thing I hope I have it no
sorry guys
I don't know if I wrote it down at god
dammit god dammit
it is so mad at myself I didn't write that
down
I ain't going to be so mad I don't remember
where I put it
oh there we go are distributed consensus
algorithm and CD limitations that's the one
so yours is at
and it said CD that has a limitation it's
the primary is a primary limiter which is
you know the main piece of candy I bet you
that's why I didn't get it
so
industry consensus on where the missing you
nominations based on wraps
oh man I have a good boy I took my took care
I took it today at 10 ms
yeah I'm about cluster size excetera yeah it
does for absolutely does. She can raise
architecture kind of been working entire
state flower blossom at needs to be composed
of several clusters Francis ever done two
planets are having this is it's like super
sensitive and this is why multi cluster is a
thing and if 95 were here they would confirm
this
they would confirm this yeah 980 Dino's for
cluster relay
yeah well I've heard six is it is one of the
good ways to go
yeah 5 minutes anything Google but you can't
we didn't we didn't we didn't and that's
where this lesson came from
that's what this lesson came from that you
just
and I never absolutely yes it has to be not
number that's that's that's if you don't
know anything about consensus on where
things and I didn't to keep a quorum you
have to have an odd number of a long time we
had to I was actually involved in the
project to add an extra one we had to wait
to for like 2 years of friends even here
because I had no idea what I needed to and I
didn't either until I found out I'm sorry I
was reading that so that's the thing I mean
it's not your typical kind of administrative
knowledge you have to know about raft right
it's not admit to being expected you a lot
more than I used to you know they have to
know a lot a lot of extra stuff that they
did have to do before that's why they don't
call me I'm in Seymour
keep cglre client to client see if you I
said request control plane
exercise especially close to order yet he
will get Workers just run different
committees conical yes yes it's just it's
all good good restating of the of how that
works cuz I'm going to have that I was so
afraid I'd lost that note
got any that's why I have is a McKesson
because I cannot remember that shit and I
had to be able to put up fast and I did that
search I get him and boom I had it within 30
seconds if you don't have some sort of like
a search engine driven retrievable second
brain I feel sorry for you because I would
go crazy without mine now hundreds of
workers to his nose running and overloads
yes yeah
I know it's not it is not it is not not even
with 107 yeah and they say You're supposed
to get the 5000 those I don't know if
anybody's ever at the time so let's do the
next thing we we got to
we got our stuff on here how
how did you know that because they because
it offsets the traffic right because it
distributed you have your because how do you
do you're just you're just riveted to load
balancer in inbound to your API do you
Dennis round-robin Forest you can you talk
to us about that
Percival I just wondering if you could tell
us about I was wondering if you if you knew
because that's that's what that's that's why
right
I see your load balancing your API Inc in
Cumming API request across multiple I'm
assuming you're not just putting at CD on 96
outside of the outside of keeping it inside
cuz you can do that you can do that you have
to maintain it to be independently you can
set up and maintain a CD independently from
kubernetes but I don't recommend in
dedicating Point Mississippi
and that one that's it yeah
is that part of kubernetes this something
you built in him
that's just a machine load balancer probably
right yeah but you have an inbound load
balancer free community pericos okay that
makes sense
ain't ya
it feels right by Rancher interesting did
not know that they did that I'll have to go
look at that
yeah it is. Because all everything has to be
STD in fact I was saying that the biggest
one of the biggest pain points in kubernetes
deployment is all the extra pressure on
these controllers are putting on a CD
because he has to have all of that data
controllers or or or STD intensive and
before moving off helmet other stuff like
that for installation and they're building
control that controls are putting pressure
on at CD player of the whole infrastructure
and it stops working
I got a commercial just happened at Sandy
control do you have them all separate wow
I mean did you did you security Eminem's
daughter did you suffer is Unisom all and
Sibley
you probably did the whole long long way
thing
you got it it sounds like it didn't used to
be the end of it convenient to solve them
never sent the first time I read about you
ATM and thanks for the father is still need
all their components give you a story of
course.
Yeah I mean I've noticed is that when I run
into people if it is just an anecdotal thing
so I've noticed it when I run into people
who have
set up their communities clusters more than
2 years ago
that they tends to not use Q ATM
and don't buy Rancher we Define what does a
running which notes
I found that the reason I'm asking the
question right now is
I mean when your a beginner and you go to
read the stuff like your ATM you're like oh
you can use this really awesome new tool to
get create is up and running really fast and
quick in your life but you just got you know
you just read all about mini Cube and kind
and how that's the fastest way to get a
cluster up if you're a beginner in you're
looking to study right and then you read
about this this awesome amazing fast
lightweight Cube ATM wait a second give me a
damn is supposed to be provisioning on Prime
clusters from the scratch it just helps to
bootstrap at that way and then you come and
then you finally realize that if you may DM
came along and it in the time at your way I
realize this was looking at Kelsey Hightower
thing I was like what the fuck is this it's
very attitude it wouldn't do it but Kelsey
Hightower the hard way doesn't use Q medium
it installs every fucking thing
independently with no Cube ATM all of the
individual pieces every single thing at CD
they did buy an Aries instead of running a
damn in the Notre Dame in for a cute Fox for
example you install binary on the nodes you
download the Go by and it when I saw that I
was like oh my god there was a world before
Cube ATM
and what I talk to people like forced to
hear you know any thanks forhey thanks for
that
every fucking thing is I agree with that I
agree with that but I feel like doing Cube
ATM and as I said reading through the source
code of this of the phases of installation
of cubed including making a is it the hard
way has you provision all your certificates
in the create down by yourself which I saw
and learn how to do but I mean it does shit
that is just like very tedious and painful
and so you know
I don't divorce and comedian was not there
from the start though you're saying look you
can either buy some Kelsey where we replace
that CD with console and was amazing really
yeah and what are you just you just you just
took it in and you say hey these pieces are
all hot swappable basically you just put
another thing in him do it yeah and I'm not
against that I just
and somebody's trying to help people get get
online quickly for so I think you may DM is
like the perfect you like this is too hot
and this is too cold and Cube ATM is just
right for taking me for for those who are
studying or Baskerville way back before me
when you have
and I don't remember any of that I'm so I'm
coming the reason I'm going so verbose Lee
into all this shit is because if you're a
beginner to kubernetes
all the documentation has a particular
tainted flavor based on his history and it
can be very confusing if you're coming at
the documentation for the first time because
you don't know the history of where
coronavirus came from all you know is you
want to do something besides minikube now
and you don't want to do you know Google
cloud or whatever so you want to start
playing with it and yeah it was before Arbok
really
so even the c k references cubania mug
why I think it's supposed to know and for
those who are like really like a hundred
eggs kubernetes admins who built their own
infrastructure from scratch every component
from scratch by the way there's downsides to
that the only time we ever had a full 24
hour outage in our communities close to her
was because our search expired because we
did STD as an independent entity from Q ATM
and Canadian would have saved us from that
because every time you upgrade with Q ATM
and you have that CD built-in is not just
you baby I'm but anytime you have that CD
this built-in it will automatically
reprovision you're still gets an update him
on every single communities upgrade if you
don't do that and I'm signing this as one
example of why
I'm I think if I were asked as a contractor
to help somebody set up their communities
closer I would stick with you ATM
because because it covers so many of the
things that are that are so I say somebody's
got gobs of money they want to throw at you
and they say hey come set up or internal
carre's cluster we have this minimal amount
of this mineral cost to requirements always
search T & S RV GPS and I think so I don't
know
I don't remember but if the point of trying
to make here is you have a if you're a
contractor you've been contracted to set up
your dates for yourself or for others if
answer question do you suggest they use the
cloud was just probably what you're going to
suggest the most people just like you said
yes to most people that they look weird for
us instead of teaching them how to do you
know do you know rest API development
you wouldn't do that to most customers right
if you have a customer comes to you right if
a customer comes in and say I want to raise
closer is a hey go what what do you want to
do with it while I want to do X and Y and I
think I'm doing they say I want a high
performance Machinery cluster and I paid
gobs of money for all these gpus that we
have on Prime and I want to run the cluster
on friend what's the answer
the answer is obviously you're building it
on Prime cluster obviously but then the next
question is how do you build out that on
friend cluster
you know I did not yet how do you build out
that I'm from cluster do you do the simple
way and use Cube ATM and just you just trust
that you've ATM administrators everybody's
been in there or do you go there since you
know if you go the extra mile and you like
in provisioned into play all of it
individual components of it and maybe evil
tweak it in like swap out and you know it's
a TV for console or some shit like that they
provide your own anger is your day going to
be doing metal lb and things like that for
these are all the batteries that have to be
added
the added are you pay for openshift and I
got to tell you that's what they going to do
do I like that fuck know that is exactly
what they're going to do
that's what they're doing though that's what
they're doing they're paying 40.
Ida teams are already using for bruising
General and he got to maintain a long-term
absolutely I couldn't tell ya what what are
most companies going to do especially the
companies that are already buying shit from
Red Hat and already on their subscription
service for their for their package updates
and everything and I know all about that cuz
I was IBM free night. That's what we're
going to do the on doing that shit they are
they're going to go run at
I don't I'm not saying I like it
but that is the easiest most reliable way to
go and and they can pay red heifer support
no
so that's why they don't really learn things
they only know they only know the open
Chick-fil-A yeah
and the Run vmz Qbert
did you see cute kid native got serverless K
native is coming back like a native made
another I read that in the news today
yeah I could buy on Prime Ivan Biser yeah
yeah
I am so skeptical of converts I am totally
skeptical of it
noocube number three now and yeah is that
nuts not middle of me is it
which one is that I haven't heard of that
one yet I've been saying Koreans are metals
going to be coming for a long time
yeah yep and that's it this is like the
sitter or stuff to write you guys about tell
us right
same thing they're doing they're doing bare
metal committed in prison as well you just
can't get into it you can't get into the
hood it's completely lockdown
try to mix water with the well I don't know
I don't know it's going to be interesting
okay ways I am just right okay so what what
started us on this is huge awesome tangent
that only Enterprise you kind of people are
really probably going to care about I don't
care I'm an enterprising person doing an
Enterprise a job right now
so my question is
well I thought we answered already it's
openshift
now you're going to get a number of people
they're going to say okay so let's pretend
that they don't go right out route what
would be the next best answer
keabadian right at least Cube ATM is
not going to overly tax the kubernetes
skills of your infrastructure team
you think they were going to Rancher haha
Jenna link
yeah the link to that to the Rancho stuff
thing
well I know her enviable oh my God
no I was looking specifically for the link
for their for their for their Arcane project
products
all right so so where does that leave us
right
so I guess I'm speaking to the obvious you
want to learn how to do this stuff
he is Addison communication, yes the side
that's how I remember I actually started two
years ago two years ago I started down that
urinates passes and you've no need to pick
it up and and I provisionally back minis
with Rancher and it was awesome ohmygod is
so cool you you put you take your USB stick
and you put your foot in front of public key
on the stick and you can provision of the
hardware straight up into Rancher it just
just boot right into the cluster is so cool
I guess this side path he wasn't asking a
question is to ATM the way to go for
hobbyists or or is there is there something
more palatable in we're going to
we're going to throw out the chips I'm not
going to do open shift I mean I've already
bought into red hat is the Adeno sent to us
Elmo whatever as the base of us because it's
the most likely to encounter my the reason I
get it I said I want to get you a job wanted
to do skills are going to be relevant what
are the most if you're in a build a cluster
at home what cluster is going to give you
the most relevant sign okay 3s yeah I think
you be able to set up single or clusters
under the only beings
are they are they are they provision with
vagrant like I've been doing doctor room
I mean imagine it would have to do that so
you know what you raise a good point that I
still think you baby I miss very viable
particularly for those who want to develop
system software for kubernetes
because it's better than many Cube you can't
write a storage class driver
using mini Cube you have to use a full
kubernetes environment through one and
keeping him as a fast way to get you that so
thank you for saying so that that validates
my decision to continue down the path
security and learning how to provision with
Kik Cube am because
because if you just look at Enterprise
deployments there's not enough justification
for that
you know if you're just looking at hey I
want to maintain and and and work with
Enterprise to Plymouth then you probably
should learn open shift or you probably
shouldn't Rancher the chances of you walking
in the door for some in a middle of a
company that wants to communities and them
not picking Cloud open shift and say they
really want to be out of the box kind of
like ours like that Machinery they have
customization want to do then you're going
to be using to medium or you're going to be
you're going to be building your own stuff
and then you going to get burned by certs
expiring like we did
so yeah I just drank your video and I said
to myself interesting
ansible yeah well yeah I mean I'm going to
revisit the ansible thing
this or things that I'm doing with a
provision extra extra remote volumes I don't
know that I maybe there's a hook to do it
but it's definitely a bending ansible
password it's designed to do right as well
as not designed for provisioning bm's I mean
as his core golemancer people are doing it
but I haven't played around with that you
have yet to the reason I'm asking all these
questions is because I am learning animals
helping other people learn and I want to
make sure that the stuff was learning is
relevant excetera in an and that's that's
the reasons we went to to making over knows
our communities virtual machines into red
hat because the chances of you running into
a kubernetes know that out in the wild and
Enterprise in particular that's not read had
a pretty low you might find some of my stuff
out there but
so and just for the other beginners out
there what does it mean for you the beginner
boost is going to cover were going to use
Adobe intuitive and canonical at whatever as
your first Lennox and then I'm going to do
we're going to do red hat when we come in
for structure engineering as our base
install because those are the two primary
distributions primary eye most popular just
as we can fight over what your favorite just
do all day that's fine that's when you said
you know what's a box you can try them all
out and send it when you want you can make
your own decisions but but when it comes to
skills that apply across the board haven't
you knowing apt and an napt package manager
system and knowing young and you know RPM
base system that covers probably ninety
percent of what you encounter in the
infrastructure space and is it in out there
a provisioning Wikipedia am definitely make
sense
that version of Ring of migration so painful
yeah that that's funny that's so funny you
say that because that's like Siri we have to
go through that one at one of the reasons
I'm doing this I'm kind of going to be no
spoiler alert right what are the reasons I'm
doing all of this is because we have to
prepare for a 12 to upgrade and I want to go
through the 12 to upgrade without Andy being
anywhere near the real McCluster I want to
know what the steps are for the upgrade and
I want to be able to do that in a real
environment you know a true environment not
environment not a Mini Cooper something so
the reason to do this VM stuff that I'm
doing is many many many reasons this you
know how do you install it first of all
understand what has to be done what to see
and I but beyond that it's like it is
probably take me to 119 yeah that is
customary Developers
yes there is there is really miss my wife
just came to me and gave me the it's dinner
time. So I'm going to step away from it
there's many other great streamers right now
if you want to if you want to choose this
time to go do that I'm not going to be
closing this trained most of this for the
sake of practicality people want to keep
talking here we go play around with multiple
muscle pain stuff it's like really fun to go
to that when I was a good one would you stop
over here
now or something else when I come back
though and I want to stay awake because I
really really really need to get this is so
so I can start to do my software testing and
I want to start making calls the rest API so
I'm going to try really hard to stay awake
and work on it so I should be back within 10
20 30 minutes unless something strange
happens
so I'm going to say back in 20 and will do
that see you in a bit
all right let's go back and do some more
stuff
what are we doing here Mom
what kind of keyboard install and use the
song go ahead and try to do I join Kelly
I think we need for the fire alarm but I do
think we need to turn the fire off I don't
think the fire was going to be able to talk
is there any way Cuban ATM and its
oh I didn't all three and we don't want that
that's bad bad wrong bad Rob
I just dropped my thing set time you
synchronize pains false damn it
Ariel
I only made an able to find I bet if I do
remember where to find out though stim Ctrl
yeah thank you sza Ctrl
find Aldi status I got in the wrong order
it is running now we're going to just bring
that off
already know that so we tried the house and
we could all try I'll try but you're not
sure about
I was going to need to see and I not working
this week
last time we did this I mean if you don't
turn it all the way off gate if you do kind
and it made a few qbdm in it
so you never replied all right so the reason
is doing this is because
it wants
I will need to be turned off with since your
ports are open to your cluster not function
correctly
I don't remember how to open forces far all
day and Human Services on labeled
oh and we didn't talk to you about service
on yeah that's actually we should have been
last time in the last step
yes you don't hear how it turns out you so
let's do that
and Restless to cubelet C
Sim Ctrl enable Dash dress now it's activate
to start keeping it
there we go status
activating it still says activating
when I activate Ed a week is this
statues Cube Outlet
uh-oh why isn't it on that's a good
why does it say activating instead of off
how to make an egg to make it to the final
we make it starts cuz I can figure we did
this
as a repo
oh no no no no no no no. I remember the
instructions they said it will come up but
it won't actually do anything cuz it can't
talk yeah I remember now I remember you said
you were sexy in the docks so
set time you synchronize panes off
all right we're going to try to keep medium
here and it's going to croak because of the
firewall
I mean it'll work you just won't you just
won't do anything with me to talk to him and
this problem for him
oh here we go there's the checks for IV
tables
if Thou shalt have the checks for a tables
or you cannot work
so this stuff is required
is this other stuff I don't know let's just
try this stuff right here shall we I'm going
to yank this out using my my handy-dandy
yanker
so that I can do this
can you make a pain bigger why
these bigger I can
but it would make his letter C small for you
to read I'm going to do this way to say
yeah with wise
I know I don't know which one this one I
already know what that is this is zoom which
is using
if this is there any ivy table setting
yeah that's the same thing that we know
about from before so I'm going to be adding
those two lines type of cables
when I can ignore pre-flight we're going to
turn it on I said let's do that let's say
Shi
tempeh
let me go so that set the IP table stuff to
every system
that is also already in Artemis Fowl
Kate's since that we didn't do them on
overlea thing
I don't know if it needs to come and get her
or not that's what I'm trying to test
I don't know about this so
so you do systemctl and all
yeah yeah that's the dark I've been reading
before
yeah that's a good one but that one in the
in the read me
does do cgl
I don't actually know it's it's ETL system
what is c c c c l
if your girlfriend RZR 170
that must be the man probably start like we
have to do stuff to do
Mom shit that's cool alright let's try or
nothing now
I need to find a hockey for that you're
right
all right we're going to do Q ATM in it
are felt content tables does not exist
I don't know why that's a problem
Roxas net bridge bridge enough calling
potatoes
interesting it looks directly for the file
that's named that
Roxas net bridge bridge and have coffee
tables or stuff not on that's why I'm
yep so that means this does have to actually
happen
so
run that buffer all right my problem is you
are my problem now
I need a key for this
are there right now I did it by system to
jail yeah
I didn't I didn't system an assistant to
tell system
but I didn't I didn't do the mods the first
message that again
so I think the mud probably going to create
a creative thinking I don't know if I know
yeah
I think it did I think there's some files
that got created by whether or not that was
enough without having to rewrite the other
thing I don't know we're going to try that
out right now
so let's try that let's do
we're going to simplify to check I'm
guessing problem I know we didn't thatthat
was enough
so if I can get that module thing can go in
a separate time
it was like no I don't want to talk about
oh I put the mods in my probes I found
everything I do I didn't I put it on this
one
arguing and everything I don't know if we do
yeah I know. I've been funny
yes
so there's are are joining thing
and I've been feeling this one's going to
fail mostly because
because of the firewall
and see how it's to be the first time ever
and ever do systemctl cloudy
stop firewall D or disabled now
that's amazing that it is work out of that
V with the vehicles 5 order yeah
she's going to fantasize about those New
Jersey and I remember that one
that is doing it is the 10. Network to your
ass is not using the IP numbers do you think
that's weird
I kind of wanted to use the IP numbers like
the non 10:10. So I wanted to use the yeah
we need to do the network thing where we
tell it what never to use yeah
so I think we need to you haven't used it
the right now work
yes now we actually need cement network
configuration we absolutely do we need it
before we need to do that there's an extra
command line that tells you the c i t c h e
r for the Pod thing on that right and I
don't remember I'm going to go get up so
there's
yeah there's a yeah if you're a Survivor
ties well I didn't know about that one
what's what's on a server advertise address
well that will that will all this year as
yours get picked up from that automatically
for the for the pazzi annihilator remember
we're supposed to do in it and then dash
dash whatever
and it's there's a network thing as related
to that is like something cidr that never
said you are when that be the same I mean I
got to read about this this option I got to
read about this option
Chi-Chi Madman Dashie age
turn on network configuration out it's not
it's different that's just for the pods to
see my right alright I got you
alrighty
I want to read about that though
humanium and then Dash age
I need to read all of this but edit
PreFlight certs
yeah Pi Network CPR
eventually we probably still need to do that
though I would think that that would still
be needed and it certainly not going to hurt
right I think it's probably good is it true
or false it's good
it's good practice to just at your apartment
at work cidr anyway it's not going to hurt
and I going to hurt anything right I think I
need to memorize that as a thing you should
just do we should do tonight or what
any teas that ain't Calicut a serving okay
interesting
what I'm thinking about is I need
I was at the the default
yeah but how about know the default what
number the funk is a VIP server advertise
address
I am implying it from it
I guess I'm Burns Buy in Pines Road
I think we would have to specify right
I get a strong impression that I need to put
this no matter what just to make myself feel
safe
92. 168. 0 0 what is 16
Ciara
I got it I can't tell her I'm a hard time
finding a p I should run Docs
if your server advertise address
is it a store advertised a dress code is
that probably should be changed if you're
going to do a load balancer as well right
I'm thinking that you would probably want to
change that
generic ranges once the positive Falls son's
head over services or staff also has 80
if that's the case then you wouldn't need
this if it's just using the default
this is like
is there one for services to is there like a
Services Network cidr
I bet there is
service DNS to mainstream God is so much
stuff
I think it would help me out with an
outright I would like to see that written
somewhere
but then you know your overriding the fault
if there's oil changes which is probably a
good thing
okay I did Pastor advertise a drawstring the
IP address the
API server will advertise its listening on
if not set the default network interface
will be used and that's the not an interface
that we don't want
alright so
hey I'm going to take file
I can hate medium box but
shit I did not know this this phenomenal
I would much rather do that than fuck around
with this
this is super cool
have you been for service dragonface repatha
created a vowel
Osaka and turn run
that's what I run but not know that I didn't
pass extensions Silver City I said it does
have a service cidr
oh hey look it's 10. Now and it's not it's
not what I do anymore
I'm at the doctor wrong hey how's it going
H-E-B in gang
yeah I kind of think that we should get in
the habit of making it a big wild.
Can you run dry run and get the output and
yellow okay
I think it did you said no no you did it you
did sorry I thought I had when I turn my
head so I saw a different one night to
address range
alright so
so that's good I mean I can potentially see
that being on a vacation that's what is the
default Network range for services in
kubernetes what is the default Network range
for pods in the Pod in the center policy and
I you know when I do 168
Zapata Network cidr
yeah I think I said that I have everything
and services Through The Eyes of a Range
Rover
customer service radar
there's no strange that's good that we need
to know that how did you get that
did you get if you drive around this and
have it dumped out all that stuff
picture of Samara source Minnesota viciously
fast really
is there another strange Rocky IP addresses
yes
is it going to service address change this
at this range must not be within a network
range
and must not be used anywhere else for the
purpose we'll use the racing at 2
years of trial and error no but I'm trying
to say is like
I'm thinking
they should have been some of the commands I
have dry runs you can do right and it will
just dump it for you
yeah I'm thinking know though
how can I create a kubernetes
give ATM
I mean obviously you can just have a temple
right so I think this is would be more in
the money for me to remind remember
so that's why I'm asking
I am I think having you know if I would help
me remember better so security
if you're going to call the QT mccaig wow
well there you go you go bowling down
and he keeps it in his face
is it red in the commune join there you go
there is one and go get one from existing
closer
yeah so it makes me want to do mini tube
kind custard we have a kind cluster
and if we can get one this way kind of
cluster
I got my computer going to be yelling at me
kind create cluster
it was just a fault hyppo sister that let's
go grab that that
accurate a fig
I'm doing for the command line
there's no Community running and get the
config yeah
can you give me the information does it
don't take any then
I can't get
can a DM config Ashen hair system
I talked about 2 cm
there it is oh yeah MO
Hair We Go there we go we can rip out all
the shit we don't want
Precision Window Rock I mean this is just
Google Now directory it secret is pki
I I did this is this is great I want to see
how close is configured
Naruto go alright so
so so so play should have been an investment
I have it right I actually could
now he's a host or not mounting on the host
so yeah
yeah I'm going to come back to this one
later after I know what I'm doing
so
ascp
what how much of this do we actually change
authorization mode no darmok runs like a pig
oh you found something like that
oh my god well that's much easier that's way
easier thank you
I think I was looking for
is so acute c t l You Mad Men
config print doop doop
difference prince in it
defaults oopsy
join the falls and Intimates UK version gay
version
Sandy River soaking show messages you to
sign the association
look like I N Point advertised address 1234
really
why couldn't you like I said I've
thank you it's just the terminology monks
but thank you for saying so
and I'll look crazy socket. My God this is
all fucked up
we don't have dr. shim
this is great I love this because this helps
me know all the things I need to change I
remember we passed that last time too and it
would have worked if we had to change it
cuz there's no doctor soon
I remember we changed we built an entire
different Cube ATM thing so did you get an
STD
what are the TD kind of close to
configuration wages is 7 thing unless the
same thing
oh
it kind of seems like it
I mean okay the reason I like this is cuz
this gives me straight up an example of what
to expect right
so here's your internet configuration see
this is the different object it says nothing
about you except I was expecting
this is not communicative at me I need to
read more
this is exactly very sure and yes it is and
I was just reading about right so
cluster config
why does it have a time out for control
plane interesting and why is that why is
that a subtype of API server
seems odd to me I've never seen if you do if
your server is not a p i e p i e server got
it got it got just moved it around instead
of being in the normal order
you know I just got kind of threw me so
Yvonne Zima yeah I mean that's where all the
schemes are yeah I remember that thank you
for that yeah
can I still get directory a cluster name
caretti's DNS no DNS to do my TV
is your pulse rate as soon as Bates is going
to Duke or DNS by default which it did last
time when I did Grey's version
never getting a DNS to main cluster local
a service some that others are some that
were looking for him and it is because it's
this is not the
I got the Pod addressing
yeah
I mean I don't needed to deal went to delve
into this I'm just I find it very
interesting so let's do the other one let's
do
join default have a feeling to join the
Foster going to have the machine I don't
work right
join llamo
causes of cluster which makes sense there is
no cluster config
yes it does
yeah we need to we need to fix that
I guess it wouldn't hurt you to sign away
yeah but that's a bad thing we don't want I
do not want to overlapping At Work's biggest
thing for most working issues is a pain in
the ass in
communities I'm out with strap tank of
Eurasian doctors why does it keep saying
I thought install integrity was going to fix
all that
activate in The Fall Guys yes at parts we
need to know
there's no darker skin
is it just depends on how it's supposed to
be wanted me you know
yeah I feel like when you're running it yeah
well
what's the cidr to jump past
I have to put the first numbers in there
right
I don't know I have to change the cidr value
and get rid of the first ones
cuz it's all a bit white stuff I'd have to
figure that out. I don't spend time do it if
I if I want to split
if I want to split the same 24/7 mask mint
Summit mask
sort something out there ask what's the
subnet mask I just
is this so much fucking Something cover for
people and I know about it but it's like I
can't imagine trying to teach all this
you've got to know now working you can't
step into this world until you know not
working like you know what a subnet mask is
and all that stuff it's you can't you just
can't do it and so that's why the
infrastructure stuff comes first
I mean I can't fix it now
what did you what did you find his new books
on t w o r r e 24 God
more fucking read the doc's I just want this
for the whole thing and I look their
configuration I was tempted to write a book
on read the docs and I looked at their setup
and I was like fuck no
very scary this is approach
I know why people do it cuz it's nice and
easy to just works but
yeah
do do do do do do do
thank you for that all right all right
it is at 17 and then I would stand with that
makes sense yeah obviously
what's that
I need to write this down though because
yeah I need a ride. I don't want to lose it
that goes in my my property down here a
calico
yeah
I know nothing about this and I think
they're going to think we probably could
I am sure we can figure it out we could
probably write it probably script and catch
the output and then you said up what's up
with those
you know if we just if we just at the end of
his joints for those other things we could
actually reuse the links
but yeah I'm smoking so I'm constructing my
thing here to ATM
advertise API server
I cannot write
when to do on 68.2 too and that's specific
in our configuration
and we can do pod Network cidr
and we already know what that is right we
don't need to add that and I think we need
to add any of my just want to know what the
default are
I don't I don't want to do that I don't want
to confuse the issue this is only doing this
is because we have a specific IP that we've
used in them is not the default IP so that's
we need this because of agren because of
ignorant that's the primary purpose with so
advertise up in here Canadian
Annette and
keabadian completion Bash
if you ask me why I use mash as I have it
backwards into tonight
if you're a server I could figure that one
out but thank you
Pacific Union I'm doing it in but I'm also
reading a bunch of stuff
did the car lot of people keep medium is the
hard way
we just talked about how the tone of the
documentation can be very confusing to
beginners because when you when you come out
at you think the easy way is use me to give
her trying to get started or just a cloud
and they say no and then there's this other
way if you want to do a real unfriend thing
you just keep comedian to do it the easy way
and it's not easy but it's easier than doing
each individual thing like what she was
talking about and like Kelsey talk about in
his guitar. Which is extremely dated by the
way they install Q proxy binary instead of
using Q proxy as a demon set which is
evidence enough for me to never use it so
hey sister Dan + Shay Wikipedia Mama Texas
we had a pretty big debate with myself
anyway about
about the value of cube ATM
and I think that the core value of Q ATM is
bringing up. And I mean full systems for
evaluation and testing and potentially even
direction to Enterprise
we had some some some conversation since
you're here I'll go ahead and put it out
there it
it handles PreFlight checks a lot
I wish I could lick it in all your product
or service traffic you know she has good
news and she was talking about they don't do
that they built the whole thing from scratch
they use Rancher and
and it's production quality so I mentioned
one simple question
if your ass is a contractor employer as a c
t o
you you're tasked with install kubernetes
for us right and they say we have our own
Hardware we got our own machine learning
things we want to do it here and then I'm
probably pretty decided we were about to
Hardware put covid-19 down there and
when asked to do that for a moment I paused
at the answer the strategy being used to be
damned to do that because I know of at least
three other Enterprises clean my current
Enterprise that did not do that
and they have all reached the
you know disadvantages of that and you know
we were cuz she was down for today because
certs expired and they did at CD outside of
UVM
and so I'm trying to establish with the
Enterprise and you know what the interest
industry Enterprise best practice for 4
standing up a kubernetes cluster is if
number one you don't go with it with
openshift wish everybody agreed to be the
first pick for most people unfortunately at
to the first pick in probably a cloud to
solution of some kind of people in the chat
say we were stupid for even exploring the
possibility of running on front communities
and I was like you to understand the
requirements are they don't they don't
they're living in a lonely world in
that's that's not the world for many people
the ticket of those people doing Machinery
so open should just going to be the answer
for everybody cloud is not going to be the
answer for everybody hey how's it going
stranger us to the next question is Rancho
Rio Rancho Saturn key on Prime solution blah
blah blah and so that left me wondering
legitimately is tube ATM just
basically kind of me to keep on steroids for
developers to get a sense of how to develop
something or for people to develop storage
class providers in a way that is real if you
know you can't do that I'm going to give up
that easily but can we build storage cross
providers and code them and test them in a
real companies environment without the cloud
with out over to follow up just for
developers and assistant system that moves
like me to beat the shit out of something in
a controlled environment
or is it more than qbdm actually be used in
production in a can you stand up a
coronavirus cluster in production that has
you know Den hundred twenty-two hundred
thousand notes and expected to perform and
be able to add extra things in the answer to
that I believe is yes
in our particular case we just recently
added another control plane and we used to
be DM for that but then we had to tweak it
because we'd already built this external at
CD dependency and so we had to come back and
fix that particular part after we use at the
base of a ATM
there's a quote in a blog on keeping your
purpose
resigning all of our cluster that are fully
compliant
it's been under active development since
is it a fact if you were a school for Dakota
pastors and I've read all that stuff
so it's so this is this there's no official
document to this effect when I'm trying to
get his a sense of where all these other
people coming from her doing their own
careers clusters
add my best because you said it's been
around since 2016 2017 right so if you
medium has been the go-to thing and then
we'll come as close to her as more compliant
yeah but I mean every time I hear people
talk about full compliance they say many
Cubans fully compliant they say kind is
fully compliant I'm like okay fine it's
fully compliant but when I speak that for an
Enterprise as hell no and it keeps ATM is
regularly being picked by people in a
production Enterprise in Ojai performance
environments
or is there some magic shows are coming from
a place of my desire to be able to provide
Consulting feedback to people asking
question like what's the best way you know
there's so many different ways to start a
kubernetes in your environment first
question is do you even need covered and
he's been after that you have a certified
you have a certified to raise District
I know there's Voice or if I can race
sisters are you going to run your Enterprise
Machinery cluster on Mini Cube fuk no so
they're fully certified as opposed to what
was the other term
boots see I'm reading from the docs
viable clusters it doesn't say
production-grade coasters
I mean lvg says it's a default to bootstrap
production clusters and I tend to agree that
guy went into this activity with that
assumption
the tops is ready I remember reading that
Google give me six when they become his
mistress typically need to be strong minimum
viable clusters that are fully compliant
with certified Community guidelines has been
reactive elements a $6
or the title of the article production-ready
Cara, Taqueria and who wrote this
look for consents have to go private. He was
the tool that enables Christmas tree because
we strapped
ia Security on the foundation I agree I'm
I'm glad this is true
are you a Russian letters okay so far I
don't know what are KDs
at least one I don't know I don't know what
that is I'm at the look that up
that's okay I control plane so I'll come and
then you act
what what I'm about to say and this is
something very yeah we got a lot of people
talking about the option right
right now I don't even come over Noah
companies they come over just
oh shit wait a second did you just say that
red hat openshift is not a certified
ronettis provider
cuz that's what I thought it sound like you
just said if that's true omigod am I going
to use that
oh okay pretty sure she say
and I can be there in just over
well yeah I mean that goes nothing
I mean they're trying to get locked in on
that I imagine they've done optimizations
internally for their particular destroys
their lately on PodOmatic thing like that
you may need a minute and she set up snot
running
and identified her.
Ever use a Mini Cooper macaronis if you
actually are you running keeping him inside
me to keep you in
did not know that
your sister I didn't realize it was already
keeping him in their sleep reproduction most
companies force you to their distro yes
what security is offer most accurate is
offering your Cloud give me the image of go
to for creating what causes a low level
at a low level interesting Rita's in a
highly customized communities
Beamer really did not know that it doesn't
cut it for you need to customize can raise
cluster Taylor to your Hardware security
policy excetera
what this one
is a Samara special stamp on bare metal
machines anyone to quickly create create
sculptures that are secure and in
conformance the best practices but also I
can pick him up
yeah that would be us give me a G
you can point that out
yeah alright well they have it as being a
stickler on this particular point because I
wanted I want to you know I need I need you
show me the money kind of thing I
money kind of thing I eat when I'm going to
have a conversation with somebody about why
I made a decision to do something I want to
know why and I it's kind of this noon OCT I
wish nature of my brain to think about these
questions like if someone comes to me and
have no idea what to do
yeah I went I have no idea what to do and
and they say why you can't go wrong with
Cube ATM we need it on Prime cluster we're
going to do a ton of custom configuration we
might even write her own you know extensions
plugins controllers excetera which all of
which could be done with no cameras but
anyway let's say they want to actually
provide their own storage class I mean
there's one right so that are working for a
company that the storage pods company and
you want to run a community's cluster in
order to test you know OptimEyes in that
storage class for Cooper Nettie's as a
fucking no-brainer that's definitely keep a
damn and that's the kind of thing I want to
do I want to write eventually I know the
long way from it but eventually I want to
write software and go for kubernetes for
Hardware providers and vendors and other
people like that and import their job at
your back in to go or something like that
that's what I want to do in and there's no
doubt that many cubes are where to go for
them
knowing that many Cube already uses to ATM
even more justification and I'm going to say
something so controversial anybody who is
not using Cube ATM
I would say that you are the outlier and
frankly I think you have some technical debt
I said that there now yell at me yell at me
for saying that
if you if you're running a community's close
to her and you are not running
from something has been built like a medium
having had it been around for so long you
have to have like a really significant
reason to do that and if you don't
somebody said that it makes it hard to
upgrade well how was it less hard to upgrade
all of your individual pieces especially
when you're searching on their own you know
expiration track
she never yes I remember this is true I'm
pretty sure it 25 knows that person
personally
based on the track record of name dropping
so
it's okay baby I'm sorry Jessica celenza
continue be committed
I'm going to say it again if you're not
using yeah I had a feeling
if you're not using yeah Tony Tony fuzz
a pretty well connected with his put it out
I can't say who will you probably know who
Tony for his just from another way we're not
going to talk Sunday but nobody talks to me
for
nobody knocks 95 you know Tony from but but
tell me photos everybody
at that level so so yeah
I'm going to say something and I know it's
controversial
let me say it again because I believe it now
I've done enough research in a preliminary
research I will need to change my opinion if
I can do information but as of this moment
if you are running a kubernetes cluster this
not been administered and installed using Q
ATM you have technical debt
and probably unnecessarily so
yeah I know that you know kubernetes is not
perfect and it's got bugs out there and you
got to do your own thing sometimes you get
around the bug I mean that's already been a
thing right but the chances are if you're if
you're unless you're you're using a managed
communities
are you talking about like a cloud provider
something like Rancher or opinion
actually if you are home crafting you're
keeping it is Custer and installing all the
pieces like you would if you were to go
through Kelsey Hightower so you know from
scratch money and you think you're cooler
because you did it that way I'm going to go
so far as to say you are a bad person
because you just you just added a ton of
fucking complexity and independent upgrade
tracks that have to be maintained outside of
the supported nothing which is supported by
the foundation
and yeah your service man were to
guessTopsail
anaconda versus last year lyrics to the
Federal
ask me where Enterprise when did this happen
are you okay baby sounds
where is a place that I would work it so the
place that I would definitely work I want to
work some places writing software for
keeping ID so that's that's the thing I want
to do
Iris registry see there you go if you need
any other for the harbor is a thing to learn
we're going to learn how to write next I
can't I got to go I got to hurry cuz I got
shit to do all right so I am going to make a
conclusion here
what is Upstream kunai's Isabella point of
what this word nice
yeah how's that for controversial God knows
I'm kind of a big apology and there is like
I apologize for my opinions and if there
might be a penny is in here and my opinions
I don't represent a little bit because
because it's it's it's definitely necessary
to write like that given the number of
contacts Downey Phi has with significant
people in the air Bruno Indiana like the
desire to not take too many breaks him he'll
make too many like boiling water and that's
what I meant
I like your music Amy on you suck you
shouldn't be doing that stop doing it
everyone's like
yeah vedette
no Cube ATM? You're probably doing it wrong
I'm going to be my own. It's true
how many times have I have it in my notes
that I don't believe anymore I'm glad you
put that tell me what I need to put mine
it's like I'm going to do that
I went to right now while I'm thinking of it
I knew it because Isis as ever
and I went off on people and as is available
so they're pretty much a topic like running
about with me public Republic first such as
soon as the spelling right ready. There were
six and realization that was wrong because
it was meant to be an organic place to jump
thoughts not a fan of complication please
please consult with me on any specific topic
before
I'm going to put it in the morning here
yeah yeah I know I mean I said I don't care
about
he really sad it was a good independent
project oh God
bye no you don't do parodies
now when I say that when I'm not trying to
be too argumentative they're fighting here
but I imagine that there are a ton of
companies that into play Cuban Eddie's
is it at the play Cooper Nettie's well
before cuckoo baby in was reliable and I
can't judge them I mean they have to keep
track of it trying to redeploy your entire
kubernetes cluster is massive techno dad
it does make me curious to know what comes
next though and I haven't even hit that yet
I'm just a noob I haven't even hit what
happens when you have to upgrade you know
12000 High Performance Machine learning
nodes and you want to go back to using a
cube ATM install the only way to do that is
to drain all the nodes and reset them with a
brand new cluster or the upgrade of a
cluster in this slowly migrated nose up
which allows you to do you can like take a
certain number of nose off and and dedicate
them to a new cluster and then get everybody
to move over to the new cluster but that's a
massive massive effort
yeah I mean so I could see them not wanting
to pay for that now
is thinking of your own web so intense but
isn't that kind of interlocking yeah
I'll let you know something more people
about this or stuff yeah
yeah nnnnn you know if you're if you're the
one left holding the bag vendor lock-in and
using qadim could be considered a form of
vendor lock-in right so I want if I don't
want to just give it to him cuz it sucks it
does the same thing over here not very well
and mother what and you be in trouble
you know exactly what it is
to the latest flavor of the week yes
well that's not that's that's just a whole
tackle that problem you know I mean that
applies to everything I'm texting on the
tagged in a technical round. Right there's
just people
but it's doable
do do do do
alright so
if strong opinions are welcome here as usual
I had to repeat that again was here and I
want to run up a large Enterprise all the
time and that's why I had to ask question
and it API server advertise
what is it sir
API advertise server API API server
advertise server
that seems like a bad name Joyce
it's so easy yes yeah
it's a dress advertise address so I wrote it
I'm the one who fuk up okay here we go
address
I feel much better the world is my reality
is saying no
all right so 192.168. 2.83 to
search available it's not empty that's
because we already did it
yes OS right I can do it from here right
I for I forgot about reset I got it I got to
get used to this
and at the firewalls are still stopped us
from working but let's just say it was get
the IP right first and then we'll do the
next thing
and I'm saying no I'm saying it so we need
to join here for soon
here's the thing where I can do this again
you said w
can you join discovered token hash
get to the 5 it's typing it in this one too
I don't know how to work I didn't shed as
she'd work it should be able to join itself
and shouldn't be in there
and should not be in here it should be fine
but it's funny I mean
Stephanie oh wait baby to change it change
the IP number that's nice
I'm jealous. That's probably cuz you can't
talk to the network oh
it's I didn't either firewall up do we turn
it off
show me I didn't turn it off tell me I
didn't turn it off
do we do we turn off I don't think we turn
the fire off are we did
we did we did cell
but that's pretty cool I mean it it works I
got to knownow they can't talk to each other
cuz it have a network
nope I will show that I will demonstrate
this presently
so so now what well let's try some things
first of all cubes ETL
went to your ex were right ask for it this
is something new Cube config
Eagles Etsy kubernetes
admin now there is no admin on the other one
so they're going to fail
off the firewall Mendoza cousin trouble
you're as soon as the other connect think
about nuts
text logs right to health checks yeah yeah
I'm not too familiar with that stuff
let's make a note to turn the power off on
everything
at we obviously need it
disable firewall on everything
I have teddy bear this whole system
paintings and give me in trouble
it is going to give me trouble codes in a
pain and just call today
yeah I think here
and they don't know about like me like I
don't know what this is super dangerous but
fun but I want to just show with it so it
doesn't work right
keep CDL can nodes
so hey look we have nose and they are doing
their thing alright so
yep they did as far as and Calico and all
that and you will see that they are not
there
get Hans
and there we go so we have the accordion s
pods which are needed to ease need to talk
to
in points
actually scored in his faults are running on
invoice I think they're cute system there in
the juices and mrs. I think they're damaged
fence that run I think that's I think they
are
I'm pretty sure they're damn assistant run
at 14 pod I mean 14 node over known yeah so
let's get
I need to turn this off when I break
something
stress pains it's a fine with your ugly
sweater felt so
so that means it's not an it's not a it's
not a Davidson
Gibson she'll get appointment
that shade appointment find get Dash
qct L contacts
set second text
Dash namespace Hue system
how config I can my commands are getting
rusty god dammit
it ain't my music current images of stashed
current
I used to remember this shit is like one of
my favorite commands
I feel so embarrassed I can't remember it
it's can fix it contacting space current
no it's set namespace
and then it's his face something along those
lines
isn't contacts containment
I mean this is stuff I have to
I don't want it again thing I don't like
doing that I want to do it this way so there
I actually don't think it's a command
that's the problem yeah okay I did it right
eye current
s n
and I fucking righted yay
that I do not I do not fucking thing filed
very often I probably need to start I do not
know much about the about the Aqib config
file format I haven't spent a lot of time in
there I've just been you know using the
stuff
get say config
there you go anything about five names yeah
yep
department has said yeah but David said that
extra think of the name to
yeah I could have swore they do
I know it's right let's do kjq proxy that is
named except for sure god dammit
fuck
get Damon said
keep on saying I guess I'll run
that makes sense because it's a replica said
in so I can be tricky tray renewed you don't
even a damn if they all got one guaranteed
right at that makes sense yeah the only
reason I said pods have that is because they
can get reap any time there are super
ephemeral and the button the other Damon
said stuff they possess to write and it's
like actually no Staples hits
I think save us is going to have replicas as
well write anything that can ever happen
this has it has the actual name on it that's
something I kind of picked up along the way
but but can be a pain in the ass to look
into pods directly which normally probably
shouldn't do it
anyway so yeah what are we doing what I say
something17 x 23 is it really that's even
better
so that's what I'm going to share until you
to be with me tonight that is super cool
that I got to get into stable says I really
do I can't wait to get into them they they
can do so many cool things
I think Stay full sets are going to be one
of the best
tools for kubernetes administrators to use
because by creating a statefulset you can
cash your own shit
and keep track of stuff in the Clusters
basically you can add ad hoc observability
scripts and shit to a stateful set
and yeah and then
and then you can put that send that off to
where we want to and you have guarantee
persistence
I like him a lot I like him a lot in effect
when I first learned about BBC I was like
this is useless to me and then I thought
about Staples that sounds like what it's
guaranteed always get the same storage
holyshit why wasn't that include in the
rainforest I don't know why people are not
using Staples this for everything
I forgot to get ready before starting next
body up
it gets really valuable I really do think
it's awesome and right so
yep it's okay get Akshay
where you got everything here so here mostly
I want to see what they are
I can't get pod there cuz right there when
it is
so this is a pod
I was given a zap and I can be an ass wenis
77 scorpion this is just a service it's not
it's not a and it is not a pronoun again
thing
it's to keep Roxie that's doing and it's
doing the DNS riding when they do dinner so
I can swing by originally understood it to
work and then I kind of I kind of I kind of
Switched after that kind of changed
does a chi chi like wait what is there any
recording in this instance on every pod on
every and that didn't make any of your node
they don't write
there's no there's no accordion s instance
running within a node in order to in order
to handle the genius queries that then the
proxies brokering them all up to some
Central
SubCentral DNS
it ain't safe assets yet so
Cornelius Cornelius in case you're wondering
Cornelius was not
apart of kubernetes it was not a standard
part of communities has been kind of brought
in you can replace it with another piece and
CD and core DNS have been so melded with the
ATM deployment that they have become so does
synonymous with communities because they're
just there
and obviously can replace it with something
else you do with anything I can read his
butt but you kind of have to know it's a
part of it it's it's frustrating because
there's there's communities and then there's
all the shit that communities uses by
default and you have to come and assess how
you know permanent is this thing is just a
thing that's going to be around for a while
or is it just temporary or is it built into
the standard and bottle that says it's
really hard that's what the whole Landscapes
about so
so yeah so this
I'm on it says the replica said so that
means that there are two Cordina servers
running inside of the entire fucking cluster
and they have to talk to the pods and right
now they can't talk to the paws that's why
we looked at them they are
they arethey are not ready because there's
no networking
are cluster is configured everything it just
doesn't have any a king so none of our pods
can talk to each other and including the DNS
pods so there's things out there doing DNS
queries and stuff and they will fail because
I have no way to talk to the Dana spots
it doesn't definitely ready yet
the note the Buns on the note or not oh no
they're not ready
and I think they're not ready because they
don't have this you know I installed how's
it going
yeah I know I'm just I already did this once
and I'm doing it again because I really want
to see the state of a cluster that's broken
back of this ability how's it going that's
cool
I hope you can help you achieve your goals
dinner should be ready minnows are not ready
because of some other reason right I think
it's because there's no networking honestly
I do not know wait we had him join they join
to find so I don't know
oh wait wait wait
yeah I don't know
any Calico I think it needs Calico because
it knows you're not ready because they don't
turn on the network
right the reason that everything is so
unhappy it because there's no network
anywaywell G mastrov
how do I add a network are you telling me
kubernetes comes is so batteries not
included it doesn't even come with a fucking
network-layer and the answer is yes there is
no network layer by default
no. This is not like Docker kubernetes uses
docker Ishq containers
the committee's is for orchestrating
containers
and doing things with them at a scale at
large hail and very complicated or something
cuz that's what if if you don't know
anything about this whole topic and you just
want to get into it from the get-go I will
be beginning on February 12th to do a
containers in kubernetes beginner boost
and I'm going to be recapping
I need to be re camping
everything I learned about containers and
Kira days I am absolutely had to get her on
this front but that I will be recapping
everything I've learned about container
Securities in in the six weeks we have next
week are you still have a lot more time for
it
so if that we're going to go through why
didn't why if she's containers were they for
I should warn you though that this content
assumes that you've you've been through the
beginner boost and that you know a single
again amount about infrastructure
engineering as well we're going to doing
things that you may not understand if you
don't know of a corn is and stuff like that
and that stuff is covered elsewhere and
that's because we need to get back on
schedule so the annual cycle
I don't think I'm going to get her any more
reports not ready unless there's a working
at work yes so this is where we start
everybody starts at Ground Zero I make no
assumptions whatsoever other than that you
can use a computer basically and then we do
infrastructure engineering boost and then
containers communities and that is going to
be your annual cycle going forward unless I
make a change which I always do but that is
that is the anticipated schedule cuz I want
to sleep in
on the weekends
I just realized my license is going to need
some more importantly I want to stay up late
hi are you doing things to do in tools to do
well that's what the boosters for
yeah I was just driving home so
before I do this let me know I'm at this
place
if you want to know what to get started go
install virtualbox and then install Linux
play around with that that's your homework
all right give her a boost so there's my
recommendation how to get started keep in
mind that my stuff is for significant jobs
in the back and called native the security
space and not so much in the web development
space developers I tease him all the time
but I was 14 years I was Nikes with Messer
and
my stuff is primarily related to security,
native Enterprise infrastructure operations
Administration you know the stuff that makes
double the money of web developers usually
and is also a fundamental part of the back
end part of a full stack engineer I have to
say that every time I push the Boost
it is likely to still keep any reset doesn't
keep going to be tonight it was a clean
install them
I've been in my said I had to rudinos after
joining me but forgot to clean
I thought he it doesn't remove my default.
The clothes I had that exact problem I had
that exact problem I did it I had it I think
I install Calico and then I did a reset and
it still said they were ready and it was
fucked up and I still had to redo it because
it showed ready even though it wasn't ready
because that stuff left in that Dottie I had
that exact thing happened last week so
yeah this is this is going from
all right so what do we got
Etsy
we did a reset but we do have calicos told
so that's the next thing we have to do
do we have to use the mind probe on the
Netflix like we did right we didn't get away
from the
Armin X reloaded one and stuck with it after
reset it could have been
yeah I know the reason to do this was a
virtual machine right now and you didn't.
You no longer exist
Emma love it more proviene these days
because of all the flexibility gives you
comedian started that oh yeah yeah we need
to Falco
she said she'll yeah
let's do it now
Calico doesn't need to be installed
everywhere because it's Securities
appointment
text Lee Davidson
is it a C or D as in David said crd can be a
whole bunch of things right
and I'm going to find out holyshit
Transylvania key
kjet Dashay all more and we'll look at all
the Calico stuff it just got out of bed so
calicos a table set
Calico notice the name is at Dario that's
interesting though why is it have names
after it
iPod it must be also pod yeah the controller
that's it okay that makes sense as a
controller that's a pod and there's a pod
right there at it looks like it's in a
container though
that might go away I think this is a this is
just ridiculous ation
yeah if it's a damn it said that's going to
go away right after it is so this is a nib
container
isn't it pod but yet another thing to
explain to people
yeah it's a saying Calico node is
initializing and to do that is running a pod
right now these will go away the next time
you run it
yeah this is really good info
A123
running communities Damon sets cluster IP
keep system
keep system service
1096 West because Services Route 296 I have
that memorized now thank God
pods contain in a container I think that's
what I said
any containers in separate pots
how many containers are inside of the Pod
right sandwich finalized containers right
I remember now yep okay yeah running
I apparently there's a pot that goes with it
I wasn't expecting that
is it California to pod in addition to the
damage said it seems odd to me
oh I don't know I don't know how good it out
I was deployed this stuff if you're new to
communities that we have think this was the
first thing we have to go through is what
are all the resources
it's big is a big deal ignore cremated
instead
I will deposit created by the demon said
oh that's right every Damon said his
replicas come on Rob yeah that's right I'm
sorry yes I forgot
all right it's it's more than just a replica
said right duh
yeah
yes they're credit of course they are I got
confused
what else is new
yeah that the whole replication thing is it
is is easy to get wrong position of coconut
on the notes
firewall or something we didn't reset
anything over there so I also didn't do it
be our Network bridges on everything I don't
think I did that on everything I had Mike my
best is probably iptables stuff is not on
everything right I think I want to read some
of that stuff on the controller
there's no network configured again
yeah yeah yeah I am with you on that I think
it's probably right
I don't even know how to check that though
we're going to have to
yeah I was fix it I'm trying to fix it now
we have our laws are off iptables rules are
on their participation table things
does got loaded and everything and the
module with the Montrose stuff might not be
there
the Orlando and then Brer netfilter how do
you know let's go check
is Ellis Marcella thing answer
the NFL is there chose the wrong and network
interface to talk to the other notes
what describe yes at
logs Calico node
hey how's it going welcome
yep I'm already in keep system but it's also
that's something I actually know how to do
if so identify reconciliation lives over in
blah
I did before it did it in front of solution
lips
is this is this control oh it is a control
oh it's one of these is busted let's go look
at one of these hey there
well where are these Bots coming from
are these Bots is our Bots are they not
I did not make these Bots to do this what
the hell people
oh my God how am I going to stop this as you
can see in this
oh how do I report this I'm getting flooded
with new follows
I'm getting totally falling within the falls
and I did not have anything to do with this
I didn't do this
oh shit what do I do here do I report this
oh my God someone clip it all right
I'm going to cut this I have nothing to do
with this I have no idea what's going on how
am I supposed to report all of them I can't
go in a report everyone I just got I'm
getting followed by tons of people all at
once and I have nothing to do with it
fuck someone set the bond at me someone
either likes me or doesn't like me I don't
know what
I know I didn't get ready for anything I
mean I appreciate the fall of it they're all
fake
but I don't like having fake followers cuz
then people give me shit I had I had a
follower
I have a follower from somebody else why is
my prevent those attacks I have no idea what
that is
I have fallen far he's just happy to see me
hearing thanks for the follow for the next
few hours I know
I might just have to turn it off I don't
know how to even turn it off
oh God here we go we know you watch child
pronography
it's not my Ivy please don't go look at the
IP iTunes pornography
I did have sex with my wife this morning
though it was awesome
she just got done with the real guy she's
like to give me the look
I know too much information oh shit I don't
know what to do with this guy's
I'm sorry I just had to make a joke the bad
joke
I just have to feel Kentucky I don't want to
look at it. Please look at the IP
this is the thing we're supposed to turn off
being able to push it into the spam you know
unless they do a thing
yeah
don't post the clip and just go to I don't
know how to save this save us from this
I don't know
should I just stop streaming and that would
they would win if we did that
b
disable phone applications yeah that's the
first thing to do are you at right now
it is if I wanted to spend my time doing
this instead of helping people in
communities cuz cuz apparently people don't
want me to do that
no they don't want me to be successful and
help people they want they want to rip his
down
yeah I don't know 50th birthday
stopping stream unless you're uncomfortable
afraid something bad is going to happen on
the stream and I don't want it to get banned
cuz people have been banned for having shit
happened on their stream that's not not
within their control
and that's all hey look I got a whole 105
followers today
fuck I don't know how to report this let me
try to or just let me try to turn off my
alert box is getting turned off filter
events
test for excessive follow Shelly hey look I
just followed myself
all right I promise to stop
unlimited alert moderation delay unless if
your navel all alerts need to be approved
manually
if I see that
sensory cinnamon sensors are recent events
for streamer unless I clicked on if
moderator proves it is uncensor for streamer
I didn't do it disabled
learn moderation to alert delay
I do I turn off I'm trying reset stream
label session automatically
maybe stressful energy extraction and carry
on as you were otherwise I do need to turn
off all the follows though
and I mean
you know what that's probably a way to do it
well that would be way too easy
oh my God that's like the easiest of all now
I still saying it can you hear it
mute it on the mixer
you can't because it's just stuff out but I
don't mean to do that I have to turn the
sound off completely
you can't hear it now right you can just
hear me but no sound
recent stream labels alert Perry
bad words that so when I didn't push them
settings you can't hear right now right
yeah it's been a slow music and only try
something else
unlimited alert moderation delay this
applies to all ours and enable all ours need
to be approved manually
save setting I'm going to try something that
should have stopped it
apparently not
no that's supposed to make it so that all
alerts are enabled to be for a manually it
doesn't work
is there all recent events forestry mower
unless clicked on
it doesn't give you the false thing cuz it
doesn't give you any sound
if I hear it still
I mean yeah let's just take it off of it
I mean this is this is by far the easiest
way to keep track of this with the sound
annoyance for y'all
and I mean but
as he hears me I'll do mine if
follows itsy
oh wait you can turn them all off disabled
wait wait wait
I think they've already been queued
yeah
here's the thing it doesn't matter if I save
the setting because they've already
they've already been sent
so they're already cute up like I disable
them something just so you know going
forward in the future
thanks for the follow us
so what what happened was
I mean I I click disable follow alerts and
it still doing it
because they've already been sent
and I don't know so it actually doesn't even
work to turn it off through streamlabs
because
and they've already been cute everything
cute up so
yep they're doing nothing we can do there I
just need to know that streamlabs is useless
in this regard you can't help me fix
anything
there at best I can do is just turn off the
notification
and
I don't even know how to block that this
email snow yeah
we don't punish users her victims about
attacks reporting a handful of accounts
you have estimated okay I'll have to give
that a try
yeah it's like I hate that that takes time
to do that it's like takes so much time to
do that shit
it's like you know
and I'll go back and do that I'll do it when
it's like a waste of time I want to finish
our stuff we almost got it done all right so
whatever
yeah
oh shit that's why it happened oh my God
I just got done is anonymous
it's just that I think that I think I see
what happened
yeah yeah I think I think I saw happen
so so the cyber security people chess
so so a cyber-security person posted me
and it went to a hacker crew
and the hacker crew thought it would be fun
to lunch about it me
to give you some extra followers which exit
warms my heart
because I know why they were doing it but
they I don't appreciate
I think now I know as it's starting to come
clear I think I know what happened here I
think I know what happened to her
somebody thought they were doing me a favor
by giving you a ton of extra followers
because somebody on one of the cybersecurity
that that post that tweet just went out 35
minutes ago
so which I really appreciate so whoever's
watching this right now I want you to know
that I appreciate the efforts
but please don't send Bots follow Bots at me
I know you're trying to help me and you want
to change the world and that's awesome and
you got the skills and everything but but if
you're watching right now
please just know that this is you know it
was other ways to get the word out
get the word out right I'm starting to put
two and two together I see what's happened
so somebody tweeted me to cybersecurity
listen to hackers you know saying hey I'm a
nice guy go follow me read me and that's
really great I really appreciate that and
then and then then some well-meaning hacker
went out there and thought they'd send fall
about after me
just kind of of L going to a backward
compliment but but I I don't I would rather
not have that the reason I don't want that
just so I can explain it because then I get
people in here from other channels and they
will say things like
all we know you just set up another Follow
by to file yourself you didn't really earn
all those followers nobody really gives a
shit about you I've had people come in here
and say that before and I don't want to give
him any any any I don't want to give him
anything to go on you had a mean
how to get to Twitch
they just they know a month which they just
ate some it says my name in there which
Linksys to my Twitch account since so
somebody saw as a twitch streamer that came
out in
ioki it's it's awesome I appreciate the help
and and everything and but I didn't I don't
want to sound ungrateful I just I would just
rather not have to justify my existence and
followers to somebody else later is going to
come see you and go I bet you're a hacker I
bet half of those are follower Bots and I'm
going to be like no they're not but every
time we get an instant like that it just
adds fire to their argument that people
don't really give a shit about a picture of
Stevie they were just they're just a bunch
of Autobots and and then that's not until
today
I do believe I got hit with a follow but
once but once it was previously and I think
it was another two after I got posted to
Defcon and some some well-meaning people out
over there I think about my way and I you
know I like thank you for the your misguided
attempt to get people to watch the back to
the community stuff so
back to the committee's the first used to
create the fall asleep stop by the following
announcement. So I think we can probably
turn the music back on
I want that too many have something like 30
or 40 or something 1020 I don't know
I don't I don't know if I have to report it
but probably should report it but I'm really
conflicted now because I really feel
strongly that the people who sent the ball
out my way were friends of the station of
the stream and they were trying to do the
right thing and I don't feel I'm really
conflicted about reporting them because it's
like yes I want them to go clean them up but
I also I mean it's like I don't know I'm
saying
hello it to tell you the truth I did say hey
go to go we know you got child born here so
maybe it was somebody is trying to throw me
in the it wasn't it wasn't really a
complimentary thing I don't know what it is
the standard think you should probably be to
take 20 minutes out of my day and go report
in five or six of those accounts and then
just move on and not even over think it and
just go from that go from that way from
scratch by the hell not
you got a good I think I need to report it
yeah
I think which I think is what she needs to
do it I have had my my followers go down by
$700 for four or something like that and
like overnight with a 4570 Dennis to range
of Boston and hit us and stuff yeah I'm
going to report it I'm not going to let it
go but but I think that counts that I'll
report to the ones that actually posted to
the chat about child porn
those are the ones I'm going to definitely
report
I'm going to do that want to take a moment
to do that if you guys want to go watch
something else I understand
so I can do this is by cooking on
and and I got going to report them
Contra 4 for my hair I think you could
report missing yes
in a month span was just thinking about
accounts nextwhat's next
next at the fast way to do it
watch and see
okay
give me a second we just you guys wanted to
do something else while I'm doing this so I
don't care that I'm going to there's one two
three four of them that I'm going to report
and that should be fine
and I don't have a moderator cuz I'm poor
spambot account
pray Corky son
uneven unique
sure I think that was it
I do like that it called out the first time
chats from viewers because then I was able
to find it you know
Eternal Ray Rayden Eternal raid and how are
you there's actually somebody legit who
followed in their
and then yeah so yeah
we are good to go let's let's go forward
here
this is got my reports and we can move
forward all right that's kind of like you
know the cost of doing service that's why I
appreciate the the sponsorships including
from major elcon get him who is now getting
sponsor for 8 bucks a month I appreciate
that a lot and I just noticed out of my
email again I wanted to say that again if
anybody wants to help you know offset the
cost of fighting against by my free time
alright so let's do this
what are you doing we don't do we get our
stuff work
I think we're doing I'm at work. We are
taking our notes let's do it again all again
we have we have errors on the notes so us
describe those notes
Kim Long and let's go see what's up
what what do you mean
oh and we go yeah
crashing back off that's interesting
long as it likes only for nodes
your delete
who didn't to delete the door that pod
Minnesota's runningMinnesota is running its
Network later I should really get
appointment
right
well wait what why is this one running no
one isn't
what's it doing on the news oh
freon I think it doesn't know it existed to
get registered
I want to just do it on an appointment way I
am system in a man.
I thought it was already
they were in the right place
so how are we going to do where to go ahead
and
it is it is it doesn't make sense to me
different different different
was Cornelius is that it is not in the
system
it's like your system that's very odd
yeah we did that I think it doesn't know
about it it's like as if something or
networking is not working
yeah
no no no no there's no DS anywhere near this
app what's the air
oh there's never there is no error
there's no locks and something until you
can't I can't get logs this can't I can't
see it so
so I can do the running one and then crashed
upon it it can't it can't see it
long is on that server cannot find request
resource
pod / log calculator so
I thought logs were only for nodes no
they're not nevermind
just another Chris resource different find
really weird
I feel like it's the network problem cuz it
can't tell that it's even there
I think we did
yeah that would be my guess too I don't
think we did
you're going to shoot me I don't think we
did we talked about it we talked about doing
it and I was like all over the place
I don't know it's dead why we need to the IP
stuff
that could be
I mean I can remember things
inactive dead Jesus is able
I want to I'm thinking it might be something
you might be the node then some of that we
have to go back because it could have been
that we did it out of order like I didn't do
the remember we skip this so we skip the
section right here right
and then we came back and I was like one of
his work and I do that again that order has
two matters we did this first and then we
came back and we turned firewall off and we
had a number of other things we did this
other stuff after the fact and I think I
think that might be the problem
I I think that might be I know we didn't
want with your mom I was on there and that's
all there
so yeah and it's a small thing we do that
yeah I could reset the the cute little bit
here until happens to just try that anybody
disagree
yeah I see the fun
like a fun can we always wanted at
where are the laws written
on the nodes are not written of our lock
right isn't there the lungs are generated
from something can we can can we do it at
Kristi's yeah what's that I see I don't know
I knew there was something that I didn't
know about crazy so we don't have to stay
down here or we do now
you'll never know
orvar lock containers yeah
shit which is the one we're using right now
each all the same Calico node
yeah let's do oh God
Calico system how are you are you actually
Lucas
there we go interconnecting today to store
trying to get
why is it trying to go to 10. Oh that's the
service
that means it's not getting routed right
yeah
that means our Bridge Network stuff is
probably failed
I probably yeah I can't touch this can't
touch this
I'm guessing that means that are all of the
cheese guy tables riding stuff it didn't
take Jenna mean
yeah
that's it
I'm going to set the info don't even if I
referred your name to to your name to
starting newest version blah chicken
greatest or hit are connected to data store
retry error gets 443
dial and got a timeout so
it could not reach this and we couldn't take
it either
not to me that means that there is a Creo
stuff didn't get pushed out
now I thought you could do I thought you
could do the Calico stuff ahead of time I
didn't think you had to have that after the
fact you know what I mean
I didn't think you had to have the Calico
stuff before you to the other installs right
but apparently you do
so
hello he doesn't work with service a piece
right
it has to be routed in the in the proxy or
something
I think I think what's happening is to keep
rocks is not working because the chemical
damage that didn't work
well we know that because the Calico Damon
said it didn't work. So somehow the cow
could imitate wasn't able to push down right
I mean this is good I like I like that this
is painful because this is good debugging
so I obviously can't talk to
I know what the IP rules are I want to say
that
okay the net filters in
and did the IP study the Feast of TCP table
stuff gets saved member that so
that was supposed to be
mr. Frankie right we did that that's all I
know is this can make it in right
is this making it and is it the right number
have a for the said container do you but I
feel like that's okay that stuff is in there
we just checked it and made it in so
did I not restart systemctl on all the
systems maybe that was it
I mean I'm pretty sure we changed the values
their yeah
it did take did it take cctl
I thought Susie Ellis was out of there we go
applying
nfsi Be Tails
wait what it didn't like the radius one are
there it is
oh
wait a second it's not a high enough number
you seeing this
I didn't happen before though that presents
a call if you can lose one
count all the Sable IPv6
cuz all the sale if you sexy we haven't
disable selinux
we didn't do that that's another thing we
didn't do
I think I need to do it I think every single
thing needs to be done
I think is I'm going to say it sassy Lenox I
bet that's it I mean it I don't see how it
would
after five sister to tell
at me when we have to
oh it's gone already that's good right
oh I thought that we had to cursive Echo
turn on name so same time out
that's the only way I could think of it we
didn't do other than that we did stuff out
of order you know
I do I think we did it out of work I think
that's a problem so so yeah
I think they tell that we have the UNC or
something if you have been seeing her do not
how is telnet still in still in your that's
like you're stupid
nope that would be no
I think we already have we just use it if
all calico last time
the problem here is we did all the steps or
just did them out of order
yeah I think that's how we found the problem
last time this is how we found the problem
last time I remember
is getting routed right
Juju did you do it's a very well I kind of
want to start over and find it
because I feel like I feel like we know what
this is I think they're just it's like
something that we dropped in the cracks I
dropped in the cracks
I want to think that I want to say that some
of the configuration steps failed because we
didn't have the networking working at first
but I thought you could do less than we did
it we got
probably not get to the state again what do
you mean in order to be able to check it
like this
it's a weird State don't you think
where do you find the debugging but I don't
think we're going to get I don't think we're
going to get do you think we can get this
far so I know we can get this far again if
that's
yeah order troubleshoot it right I see
you're saying yeah so use the opportunity to
like look for the problem
yeah I mean that's that's diable
there's something going on with networking
I mean the only thing I know of this related
to Internet working at all is
this stuff
my TPMS repair all day
I mean we had this this is different to
write to advertise the API so I wonder if
it's still try and use the defaults in that
stuff and that spring up the routing
I thought we were supposed to get that out
of there
I mean it looks fine to me
Le Creuset ship yes
and then go sit and then it goes to sub
and then it goes to a zoo going and it's
going to 172 Network
why is it going to the 172 Network
this is an external address yeah
this should not be there yeah
it's like it's pulling
there isn't one either is RS
I'll let you know what they say that to do
that too that was this was the
so it's trying to do not
and since we don't have Nat because we
didn't label it on the other interface
that's weird okay that's
then okay yeah then added the natted version
was working before I only had 10 dots before
we didn't answer and I P's this time is the
first time we had our own IP I bet you
that's it
I bet you that's it I bet I bet you
we need to expressly say we want and adding
on the other router on the other network
yeah I bet I bet that's it
I don't know where ever try on this is it
why is it easy to pee
has been a long time since I've done that is
Emily there it's Emily listening
yeah
that's right ain't that that stuff my riding
in listening so
I mean we could probably prove it by looking
your logs on the server
how can you look in the server logs I'm
going to look enter the API server logs
and I don't know how to look at those weird
look at that
what's restaurants in Albuquerque
keep Roxy notes
for some restart I would not have known to
do that that's a great idea though
is that a ccic tail thing
or I can I get with you I just have to
export Q config equals and securities detail
well yeah cuz if you can't talk to her right
now that was just reading that was just
remove it from here
alright let's try that advance
okay so this one is working only because
it's running on this system right oh I see
they're saying maybe because we did all the
restarts and everything that is still stuck
in a crashing but then we need to be okay
I see I see
foxy Melissa tripods firstit's going to go
back in the car it's going to go back into
it
you want you want to reset the proxies as
well huh okay I mean I seem fine
but it's only the proxy is not happy I want
to see what happens when the sun resorts
and same problem same old problem
I mean 222
well would you look at that there any just
not ready now
so
search did not find request sister source
I don't know we had a crash you back off
and now we don't even scratch the thing for
a second there
mostly because it wasn't ready say are you
saying it's going to go into Crossley
because it's not ready yet for sure about
time all right that was okay I think it's
the same as just yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah alright so that's a mess to
miss misleading
I am restoring the proxies and seems like a
practice or whatever is responsible for the
network interaction is not working why can't
we just redo the the name is set for the
whole thing
can we just do that it's like not a cool
thing to do but
are you rolling restart
I do that because you we will restart it and
it keep going to just kill the replicas okay
I mean it seems like doing the damage that
by itself would be would be prudent
sounds like the same and said maybe we could
add it back
the Red Leaf anymore refreshes everything
but yeah
if we didn't do them instead it will not
refresh obviously we have to make our own
damn and set
empathetic the deposit refresh if we just
keep it inside okay I see what you're trying
to do I think I do anyway
so it's raining men that just came right up
and create again but it's usually deposit
you have to think this pain seems like they
came right up they just pop right up so
and then there's a crash that back off is
snuck in after that because it's not running
yeah there's something going on with a
networking
I don't expect expect this is going to work
but
we did not have this from lesson though that
is for sure it's other related to this to
the IPS that we set up where we did
something in the wrong order
transfer Summit it was working that's how it
was working I swear to God
because it was holding the Connection open
I'm pretty sure it was working
makes me want to get an m on their or Nancy
or something 00 the first one out the second
oh right right okay so you're saying yeah
I just want to say so this is a success in
my opinion
take me to just have a connection then we
didn't even connect at all right so
why why did Senate 96
that's the service
this is going to work astray
that's a crazy person right guy 37643 Wright
why are we going are we going to record
today if you're a server to make sure that
it's getting a routing properly to the main
server and then go to the other stuff
what am I no dice is a 4 / 3
Paradise
maybe if your Serene be restarted
I mean it's possible no it wouldn't be
because because if your servers working
because of the know this running on the
system is fine
I mean the accordionist fathers on their the
Calico pot
wow that's so shiny and wonderful
it doesn't look original it's so good it
looks like it was like Factory done you know
what I mean it's like
it is a compliment but I I can't see it cuz
I have any light
they don't have any light thank you
is so pretty is very pretty
you don't know where you're going oops
I know they're like they're what are they
doors what's the art
I want to see squash but it's got this like
metallic stuff in it it's going to call she
just making like little things cuz she
doesn't have a car she could or Studio
a super pretty though at this point I kind
of want to just reset it
he'll reboot situation I need the debugging
here is useful but
I got a douche it
I think
went from the let's go back to the airlock
the airlines are saying
quasius Satan's watercolors
I mean I I don't see
I mean I just don't see an easy resolution
for this one and me where it is kind of fun
to figure it out but
turning onto with Virgin blah
well now it says it has access
when you get the same air I think you might
be right I think the problem went away
so basically the SAT for community service
not working
you know what I mean I think I think having
those Nat addresses in there is a bad thing
that really makes me want to get like figure
out how to make a vagrant situation where we
don't have Nat and we just put Bridgeton
there and maybe it would leave off that
extra that extra interface then at the
default
the default not interface we didn't have
this problem before I when we use the
regular eye peas and wheat the eyepiece
change
it was a different problem you know so the
external works
and that's the one that we specified it to
you is right that means that something in
the router is not connecting to it okay if
active router
this is so we can't we can't get our Calico
to just to report back
it's not it's not been able to talk over the
network to the API
and we turn to firewalls off on everything
am I maybe we proved it because we talk
directly to
to the the advertise API server address
every but we cannot talk to that one that's
the actual service but this is the API
wait but we don't we need to see an idea be
able to talk to it
I think it's supposed to be one right
that's one right
so I want to hear
we can talk to me if you had of the pods are
supposed to be able to bypass the API or are
they not
I have nothing to it a Calico lookups cuz
that's I mean how to reboot a node
yeah I guess they're those are going to be
fine right fuck I forgot they were virtual
so we're not going to lose everything
yeah I'll try to reboot
yeah I think that's I keep forgetting is a
virtual machines I've been doing so much
stuff with containers and feels the same
lately left here that I keep forgetting that
we have
NFL that we had State and reboot something
it says that we should do not like a long
time ago I mean that would have been is
there an l
can't connect to a community center
smsi cats around it's almost like it's like
a chicken in the egg thing so Calico is used
for pod for pain networking right and
benefit if but if the other it but if it
doesn't get setup correctly then it can't
talk to itself and it's kind of like a
chicken in the egg
make his Calico supposed to be handling the
routing to the 10. Network right
or is that there's a just4paws it's not for
services
does it doesn't the cousin Calico take care
of all of the Pod networking including
communication to Services between pods and
services right
so it's a cni it's like for the whole
fucking thing right or is it just pots
really is it just pods looking cakes for of
the service routing overcrowding from the
pods I went down with that you need to see
and I do right
let me know I think it would fall within
that scope that's interesting
then I'm learning a shit ton about
kubernetes though I'll tell you that I tell
you that
I don't know about y'all but I am
but there is serious a special in this
regard
well that doesn't mean to keep rocks in the
afternoon about 2:10. 96 services
the ceiling of the way it would know about
it right as it have internal knowledge of it
and keeping text it doesn't have anything to
do with this and I
keep Roxie cell okay yeah
yeah okay say I'm trying to identify what
does what like where the rules are if if you
broke it wasn't working none of the cube CDL
stuff would work after our initial install
without Calico nothing there would be no way
to communicate because you keep Roxie
couldn't couldn't check on anything it
couldn't even go down and check out the so
so okay that's super cool to know so the
Baseline the Baseline Cubit to control plane
networking is covered by Q proxy
Pata Pata give CDL connect directly to the
API so right
yeah but but yes okay yes keep ccl4 sure is
an API thing but it's reporting on status
that's being generated by talking to the Q
blood when it says it's not ready
I don't think that means it's never
communicated with it or does it
I wish you would know about it we haven't
even know about if it hadn't communicated
some point so
what I'm trying to say is I think that
there's networking that's happening between
keep Roxy in the control plane that's
independent of the networking that's
happening between the pods
I'm sorry dear ho we're doing it's pretty
it's pretty low-level Community stuff
check note to now
oh my God that I don't know how it's running
again ask you the same thing
I think it's weird is it the one that's on
the system works
yeah well this was the 124 this is and this
is we're pretty sure this is the one that's
on the host
we did that we're just checking logs you
can't run logs on it that's how we know it's
fucked up
you can't you have to go into the system to
get the logs as we were just doing cell
no is he can't talk.
So and then and then we went down here and
went straight to the logs
nice
describe doesn't give us a neither the best
we can figure out as it can't the way we
were determined this is when we looked at
the log
which is now going my answer is gone on your
mind and I still have it thank God
arioso we went straight to the log and that
locks is it can't talk
no I says I don't know what you're talkin
about
well I didn't work
I know you don't need seen I'm working
that's why that's why we do Keep Rocks to
get you that stuff right I mean that's what
we figured but
we don't have any communication whatsoever
so
and checking database store I'm trying to
get to the one that's
there you go this is the are we got
yeah it it can't talk to the tenant 96
services
and we look at iptables and and we looked on
the firewall
as should be
inactive firewall we were thinking it could
have been for forwarding wasn't said and we
looked at all of that
like I think I have that cell
before it's at we tell that it to the 192
thing and got a connection with telling her
to 1096 and don't get anyting
so
we tell them to the external API interface
and it works fine if we telling that to the
internal interface it doesn't work I thought
you can you answer this question is routing
to the services covered by proxy or does
that require a cni to be installed
I would think it would work without that
okay well I mean the only thing that's
different between this and what we did last
time
IP for in the colonel yet
did the only thing that's different between
this and what we did last time is in this
one we have specified the IP addresses and
we we had to do something different we had
to do this the first time I've ever had to
do this
right we didn't need to do that last time we
going to do that but that's because we have
specific IP addresses that's the first thing
and the second thing
is we sorted itself out of order and so it's
possible that we missed something but it
it's consistent across both servers
no we were on the verge no I don't think so
when delivered I want to say we got this
work without livered no we didn't
situated we definitely were because we had
it yeah we did it right
you're absolutely right
no no we weren't we were on virtualbox we
got it working over some box
yeah I did I shipped that over
Spotify communication alcoholism
so so we've got I mean to go back to the
controller
yeah so we have that this is working because
it's it's that's a note on control plane and
used to or not
that's all
and we can't get logs from thrown away but
we wanted to see if there was if there's
anything we can learn in the process here
yeah I was super surprised just working met
services in there but for some reason
doesn't work yeah
no we haven't looked in the sea and I can
forgive yours
but that is potipot stuff right
I wants you doing
is this not working because if I deposit
stuff not working
yeah just going to say
the end
the end it's like it's like the weight of
the pain the pain wrong
that's fine we're just we're just playing
around the bunch of ideas here
I'm about ready to start it over because
Reasons I'm just you know
d i p 792 addresses him
wait well that's interesting now eth1
so this is different from before we have
that we have the NAT at 1 and then I kind of
feel like we should take it off
and we take it off though and then are they
going to say don't work anymore
which we do need to work maybe we should
disable this interface completely
every time yeah
yep and we got it we got it working before
they can use it again
secretary start
Q controller manager yep that was started
I think the issue is because of you th-02
can you make a minute if you have cirrhosis
I think we already did that
I agree I think we did started with that did
I use yeah
pretty sure we did that
that's how we started for sure we did the
API server thing I put in my notes
yeah that that is something that's different
no we did not do that before
now I did the to the 2.2 which is you know
but I get that wrong if I got that wrong we
would have any we would have any
communication all right
yeah when I supposed to do that too so
it says they might have gotten that number
wrong we've been screwed
so that I so that's the command I asked you
at 3 and 3/4
they should be three and four to go check
huh yep
ipps
they're using ebf back in and old and to all
the colonel has fell so far is it going to
send the order
the weirdest stuff from kind of willy-nilly
I think that might be it and the addition of
a specific IP network for the API that is
that is it I feel like something is hitting
the default router in Fountain failing
that's what I feel like is happening I don't
know how but I feel like something is going
to to this defaults interface and is not
observing this new thing
I feel like that's I think that's what's
happening but that's really a sweet hard to
nail down
so
we restarted the network and stuff
yeah
how to configure which works a Cisco it did
that's why I'm saying so
yeah I feel like we need to go back through
the steps and follow them in order according
to the thing I did some things like mod Pro
man and adding you to be our net filter and
all that stuff after before we do the
California sell the book but after
after we do some of the other stuff
so I wonder if some of those other tools and
they were installed they didn't prepare him
properly because the other pieces weren't
there
if it's causing issue 3 and he was taking
every time
yeah we're going to eat we had to force the
eyepiece don't know if you saw that but we
had to force a piece
we have the first step yes
the thing okay so here's what we need to
identify the
one of the Calico nose is working all right
and it's working because it doesn't have any
network problems
I think it's oozing host and working too and
I feel like that is what's hurting it is
using the default HughesNet working or just
the 10. Whatever not address and so he can't
resolve and then it can't figure doing the
rest can finish doing the rest that's what I
think's happening but I I don't know that
and that's why this one works
all the interface is really how's it going
interesting I think we should focus on his
why does the local one work and this one not
work so I'm going to read the logs
and I believe it's because I'm not working
that's the only explanation
want me to make sense because his errors
were like I can't see it
Verizon data plans using auto-text ipv4
addresses I interface and blah
using Auto detect that ipv4 addresses on the
interface ball
Auto detected V4 addresses
Auto detective before addresses
this is what's going wrong
it's it's not able to connect
I think he's trying to use host Network in
which is failing f
and I got out of patience I think we're
going to have to reset
what does Randy the reset any any other
ideas you want to run down and get a sense
of before we move on
I did not
I did not give it a pod Network cidr people
were saying I didn't need you guys to the
default
but maybe we do
I mean maybe we do that we we we
specifically talked about that and we were
like we don't need that because it'll use
the default which is the 10th of 1992 and it
seems to be using that when we went to the
chemical CDL no tags that's a thing oh my
God
on the Node
well well maybe Calvin again install
can you maybe save Everett
yeah Jessica Target right
Franklin songs in
hey Ian yes install
hey we're getting slammed again I hope not
sure that you got it yeah it is interesting
you should I agree
then this is why we're doing this right so
we can get this baptism by fire kind of
learning going on this is the kind of shit
that that you can make a class about this
Chanel it's like let's box up on the
different ways and see what we come up with
you know and there's no way to get that
experience other than on this
I feel like if I if you think if I halt you
think of a halter the agreement will keep
the state
let's do that let's halt it
how did you like it yeah this is a son
saying it's
do you think if I hold it if I hold him if I
shut him down or should I hold him
I think it's just make her down right they
are destroying our we don't do that
just don't want to do that
I don't even know what's possible here I
don't know Bakery upload down
do you want to suspend the machine or take
it all the way down changing cover
and saving it and I don't know where I put
it but I can I can get it to you somehow
I can be big right should we should try it
is spinning will use more space
that was after I said I don't care let's do
that I would rather you have like all the
stuff right so
it's what we have to do this first the first
things first let me that vagrant file
2 digest temp camp
bark vagrants we want to go work
Calico and
I mean we can just tired I just want a zip
it
yeah yeah
oh and all that actually but let's let's
let's let's save this stuff right so
how to find out if it's vagrant file
go to bed at 2 so
I don't have to work hard tomorrow I'm
probably not going to stream for the part of
the work work I have to do I have a ton of
stuff I'll get it done a lot faster for you
this is still relevant work I'm not saying
it's not but
I need I really need to get a crazed cluster
up and running tonight really important cuz
I got to be at singing this song
I did the game they came
all right so you should have a tag
there's there's the lab you and I'll try to
I don't even know where to put it where can
you store big ass files
I don't even know where to put big ass files
anywhere as I got a Dropbox or something
yes got to see the whole plushie
but I don't have enough room like precarious
as it is I mean
more Calico
I forgot how to do this refusing to write
arcade Fountain Central
s f
now I see if CVS has been long time to do
this pork Calico
Auntie Jeezy CV
njr ztf4 thank
compressed data 7K that's got to be a
problem right
I mean it's going to be a problem
I haven't been turbos in a long time xvf
shit
there's some anniversary box yeah
yeah I don't think anything in there useful
Butler machines about yourself
we have to Snapchat for the image right and
the Snapchat all three images ouch
yeah I don't know how valuable that is
well it is good news is that this crap is in
the docks or somewhere hey look Papa was
decided to fuck up my desktop again cuz Papa
was
and not so not happy with this latest
release of opposites such
I was going to run for manager I guess I
mean box whatever
I think I'm back now I don't need it and be
fine without it
now the continue run who me or they
I'm going to keep up with us because if my
games work that's the only reason I'm
keeping it I don't want to try
I think I'm going to keep using system 765
us that's going to be tough if you're going
to invest all that time in the rust desktop
environment I think that means yes
and saving them all that's cool I mean we
could export these
we can probably just take a snapshot for
nevertheless right and just for fun
predict another one
I think I'm going to say let's call it
calikim or calikim work okay okay
take Kaliko vark
calikim work alright so I don't know if I'm
going to delete those though
I don't know that's a good question
XSport is currently in safe state when time
will be lost if it's still running
I don't know man I feel like it's not
working discard Save State
guess we have to
insurance is going to save data for a used
power off the machine is that doing proper
shutdown
Carter
I wish I could be I would be cool if it kept
estate but it doesn't look like it's going
to I'm going to snapshot
alright so so there
the puppet video leftover it I kind of feel
like we need to remove them
there's a bike is not going to be happy with
me how to make a diamond necklace that if I
go in at a new one
I say I want a new one right
all right so you see save this date going to
go for it again
we know bring it all the way up that
container Tea Works we have not added the
steps for the community set up we do these
by hand so that we can observe them and
probably wants to do it in and just go for
it and disable firewall and then they
created this is the same thing that we had
running before
and and then we do these lists final steps
by hand so I kind of want to do that let's
go ahead and try it
I'm trying to find while off try it again
go for it lower
I'm going to enable that corny stuff is
going to take a while to run somebody who
had to run this and if this finishes in
their handiwork and it and it should work
and we can start debugging and and stuff and
if you got anything hoki in the middle and
in which it shouldn't be an issue because
this is very controlled statues I think we
have
stuff that Sarah's not going okay just do it
big current up
all right I'm going to do this summer to
take a break like watch it do its thing see
you at
all right let's look at this thing
are they going to call
antsy
I think it's because the pain Network
overlap with subnet and will you call it
what you doing about it
yeah let's fix that
I kind of feel like we should fix it right
away well know we should
we did it fix it so if this happened again
that would confirm it right
all right so we're on
he'll we should so
wait.
What are the fact that we put that in on our
way
I didn't have to do it
there's some other or some other distinction
has it but how do we how do we pass how do
we pass the slash 17 cidr
yeah you see I mean
I think that's not that's not the
remember they wanted to talk about the that
I do that I was at. I thought I was / 17
yeah the planet were so I think we should
probably still do theshe probably still do
the p a n a c h
yeah let's do that I'm going to hide out
here
yeah and it was what was it we did
yeah that 7 yeah you know what I'm going to
force myself to write every time
yeah and could we do that. I was 17
09 2. 168
128 yeah now we have it at 2
why what would this is my default
I always thought you said it was nowhere
except for some of that 24 it's why I took
them all it took me an age when they okay
yeah I see what's up
16 ^ okay alright then so we always took a
seven piece of that we have to drop that off
now got it okay so that means we're
I mean God we could do anything right I kind
of like the 128 one because then we put them
all
and I hate that what you hate that one I
guess we could do one of it as far as that
Network already taken a half and make sense
2.0 / 17
it doesn't seem right though
I'm trying to think about the Midfield so it
would be
eight so you said the default the default is
16 right
yeah I was going to say yeah so that's the
default
and that that overlaps because 16 says that
these two can be used for ever and we've
taken up. To minimally so we just split this
network
and we're trying to make it higher than that
I need to see the ones I need to see the son
of mask is so hard of me for me to visualize
I always need to see it
so that would be but what I'm wondering is
why we're not doing
to him I'm wondering why we're not doing 16
because that would be too limiting the
number of pods this is 16 and a half
this is what in half
oh that's why I want 2800 I get you
yeah I I get one as soon though
it's because it's because the bit is up as
up on here that doesn't match gets up higher
on the side and so it actually has a lot
higher value that's why yeah
Ore City 851 right yep and
oh that's right I said that message the ones
are on the lower end right Damascus the ones
and zeros are the other pieces that's what's
up right here right
I need it
a tune mean
yeah I really want to go through that when
we do the networking stuff I need to go
through all of the subnet calculations again
and hash out some of that mess and cutting
chopping subnets out I need to build that we
need to do it all the time I haven't done it
in years haven't done that in 20 years
at least at least when you're not used to it
all the time and now because I had to do it
I haven't had to do it in in any capacity it
what other is a network it guy for my own
shop or for
but I might be really need you I didn't even
want to see how you are as I thought he said
it was your only what the fuck is that so
it's like a southern mess with Slash
whatever number after I like oh that's what
they call it okay
all right so thankfully we we we don't have
to redo any of our
code I mean are they going to run up is is
is good so that we can do this
and we should be able to do this from all
three systems
I start again so no one is to save snow to
SSH control
clear what are you doing installations or
anything cuz we did all that already so we
see the cube ATM over here
Q ATM no serious you dash
I need to make a quickie fan I'm so weird
your Cube ATM
and it's and I try to remember this from
scratch
an API server
set broadcast Dash address server something
advertise advertise address
mine too
168. One know that you got to that is
the IP address of of control and then
going to say in the pa the pod
Network right CDI Stadium
and and that is 192.168
. 12080 or whatever / 17
that allows it there and let me know out
over that
I want should be off so I don't really need
to check that but it should be off
you take a minute seems happy so far view my
checks
asking for images of the internet's I guess
it's fine
and
we are Keen to complain Aztec pods from
directory
and thenthat looks happy
alright so let's do a join from here
that we should be able to join without the
without the Calico stuff going way back we
have to because we're getting a bunch of
Calico seeing I probably have to have keep
Roxy running which is not I don't think it's
running right now
so we have to do this I think it's safe to
say
and put it on there
wait for AccuWeather from Taylor Swift that
looks healthy so far yep that works
that was happy let's go sell this one a
token
but this joint down here yeah
and I got to keep reminding myself the
reason we can do that is because you keep
proxy takes care of all the communication it
warm with you perhaps you would be no
communicating whatsoever with those notes
and so cute proxy manages all the network
communication
add some sort of like foundational level
that allows
I know a lot of cute of communities to
operate and we didn't have that you couldn't
use
you couldn't deploy Calico as whatever we're
doing we could do it if it wasn't already
some some some pain with urination
everything is already working and so why is
that important to me that's important
because there's multiple
you know networks involved in kubernetes and
getting my head around what is talking to
what in the promoters of a network
perspective is really great for visualizing
how coronavirus is is is doing its thing
internally
and and we were we're getting a bag of feel
like I'm getting a better handle on that so
we can have all this communication has all
taking place over the API server and it's
just all you know I makes Services work
that's it right it just makes Services work
and services are 10.98 stuff right and and
then and then pick up until this point until
we install Calico the only way anything
communication the cluster as far as I know
right now is 3 a p i e server by talking
initiating a connection to the external
192168. Yes 6443 thing or over the services
network is which is what keep Roxie runs
which is on 10.98 right I think and and
after that
you have when you put Calphalon it's like
that that's when you have to set up a
different network and that's what we do with
our patr Network CID CID R because that says
okay I'll go here you go here is your
network go use this so that additional
Network as is being used by just a pot just
deposit communicate between each other that
includes do you know us internal DNS within
the cluster is a replica set it's a pods
employment which means that is running as
upon which is a finite unit cube rocks is
used to be an owl coffee and Billy really
wow that's an interesting
yeah I mean this just really makes me want
to go look at it look internal you know
everything at some point but
I can't get pods
08 yeah not that we do all this so I'm
actually getting kind of good at this part
it was an actual proxy hence the name yeah
it's all I've been able to write PS Now is
it really
so so it's you know what that explains why
we had our problems on our internal Network
yeah yeah
I tell you what that's when we started
having all kinds of problems in our cluster
you know it's the statement that you just
said about cute proxy depending on the
underlying
yeah it's what I'm saying
if if they switched off at being an actual
proxy to starting to use the underlying
iptables
that's a fucking disaster if if you're a
structure team fux with iptables
because they can they can totally fucked up
your kubernetes cluster and not even know it
and I actually feel like that's exactly what
happened earlier in the year they like two
months of outages they were really really
hard to identify they were related to armpit
shoes
Custer Siva clusters yeah
haha that's super interesting pass
completion
bash completion 08 you see killed Mash no
ATM
what the hell explore Cube config
I'll know you would recompile all the rules
if you and cry oh my God
yeah I thought Colonel that's crazy
my phone was painful because he likes yes
ATL hip pain
best vacuum system
so there's a Cardenas it's pending cuz we
not Calico we can still talk to everything
though keep Roxy's up and CDs up
answer that because you are a Calico install
which is RC and I for the pods it's just so
the pods can communicate with each other
they can't currently
and went to pull right off the internet
without even checking it is a CVS so it's
relatively assured we're going to get the
right thing
this is straight from the community stocks
and
we should be seeing stuff happen here
we should see the pot initializing
and hopefully it will do the right thing
it's now running which is good yeah and and
after it runs
if it if it if it fails after here oh oh
it's working fix everything
huzzah 2% done thinking Ellet
is this going to be a flood of YouTube nope
no I don't do that you can watch my bought
on Twitch but at some point I'll come back
and redo this stuff
we have a running race cluster and all I had
to do was the join
two notes while you can yeah it's on Twitch
it's a look if you guys are afraid about us
recreating
is recreating the steps don't worry it's all
documented here and you know if you I'm
going to be making videos at some point this
is already on his that all right so this
Saturday we're going to kick off
the last remaining six weeks is going to be
very informal and we have normally will have
10 weeks to do the containers of grenades
boost but we're going to try it again
and yeah I mean you know imagine being able
to you know added a bunch of like a people
together right and just hear everything they
have to say I can't wait it rather than a
second brain it would be like it would
literally behind mines is like yours on the
notes of having and be able to just reading
a time if you did that to me is like the
perfect possible thing hey welcome
so
so when we got here we have a working
communities that actually works with zero
hitches
perfect I'm so proud of that can't get pods
it was loaded too easy
this is a little bit too easy I don't think
that's a great one
oh God yeah rain people on specialties
yeah oh yeah exactly we can make our own
thing
now it don't unfortunately lvg we can't say
definitively that it was a network overlap I
strongly believe it was it could also have
been I just did shit in the wrong order the
based on the fact that it was related to
networking
I strongly believe you were right and it was
the overlapping IP addresses because that
was the only thing that was the only thing
that was different from from the last time
we did this the only thing different is the
allocation of IP addresses and I I want to
believe that that was the problem
so note to self
you know Thou shalt not overlap your
Hardware machine IP addresses with your pod
container Network
bad things will happen
you know that's exactly what happened yes
yeah it says here we go we got
I mean we're up we're up I don't know what
to say right now it's times like breaking
shit right so
I mean he'll wear it like totally up I think
for even port forwarding
I think we might be port forwarding
can't get that say all so here's everything
in the cluster of God
all right so you're going to read that I'm
sorry because of the chat but here's
everything in the coaster
every single little thing why is calico no
doing it's a good thing again or those old
one
alright a scare me so we got we got in
Calico which provides our container network
interface that's the the pods can talk to
each other over the specified IP range which
by default as when I too. 168. 0. 0 / 16 I'm
I'm saying this to myself because I know you
know reflective learning hear the cubes
proxy which Brokers communication over
iptables between all of the machines on the
network which are that would be actually no
that's different than the machines
themselves so we just sshd in right when we
have to Stage those the machines are
connected via the 192. 168. Two. Two. Two.
Three. Two nights for theirs theirs is a
static IP said they were assigned
and they have up to 128 I am 2,000 machines
if you want to cuz we
she's we want to cuz we split and we split
the the one I don't want 68.0 Network men so
that's why I thought that's what we had to
do a separate pidro pod and then the two
proxies are communicating with Services /
10. 98. 0
on / 16 right
Ukraine ssa-44 yeah yeah we could you at
some point
we were going to do that actually we're
going to put up we're going to put an SSH I
was going to set up cuz I mean if you want
to set up an actual race cluster I really
think you need to setup SSH access remote
control plane to your notes to your note
host machines because because how we going
to get on there and do you know this is c a
r i c t l or whatever you need to do to do
to do bugget tenda 96/16 right
I got that right 96/16 is what all the
services are on my default i18n 168 / 16 is
the default Network for the pods
yeah you company I work for has its own
class A address fruition 7
IP address yes his face face a
yeah
listen. 96 is just one of them yeah
I know it's only one of them that you have
to like get around it so I'm trying to say
hitting the reason I thought it was because
I it makes sense for us to make the vagrant
machines on the 10. Address
write up anyone that I put on the 168
Network because yeah that's the same as my
internal but it makes more sense to put them
on a $10 for going to simulate an enterprise
Enterprise the chances of you having an
internal address on the 10. Range is going
to be very high if you were here for a large
Enterprise almost every Enterprise I've ever
seen runs on the 10th on our internally so
if you get what I'm trying to get at is if
you want your vagrant yeah right that's what
I was just getting that so so if you want
your if you want your internal if you want
your vagrant set up to feel Enterprises in
after you can bring over the SSH anything
and there's really no distinction between an
actual Enterprise machine then use a tendon
address
and if we do that then we don't have to
split the the you know the / 17 CR you are
on the 192 168 because we can just we can
keep everything he's at fault and so that
would even be more intuitive for people just
beginning me I kind of like that we're
writing it out you know just cause but it's
not needed right because it's his fault
so I think I think I'm going to make that
change right now since we got everything to
work then make sure to save everything cuz
this way works
yeah
he's 24 for all your private notes if you're
doing that then how do you how do you run
Community Center as well I have a question
so is the 10. Address rain inside of
kubernetes
nat it away from everything else it seems
like the answer to that is no
set up 43 very cute controller
starseed Terraria 1042 traffic to 43
interesting
so you actually changed yours right
Porsche it sounds like you did that right
now
is it being out of communities doesn't call
for it but it's best practice right
right so there's there's really
when people draw like a box around their
kubernetes cluster that's just a line on a
piece of paper
the only thing that's really keeps your
kubernetes cluster together if you're not
mad at me like that would be IP assignment
you know and yeah
GPS says 3 cast
yeah the secondary PCS Andres thing
for account well
secondary onesies hundred. Interesting
so since it has so so I think so
I mean we have a few considerations or one
of them is that
virtualbox already assumes at 10. Not an IP
address as a default in fact we found out it
was 1:50 or something what was it
I mean I'm trying to get two and a happy
alternative for testing it for starting out
in for beginners that I could use him
something that
oh wow how's it going out of this building
so it's a Sim saying if we have like
little ones are dead they're dead Jim
they're dead
at work who is the doctor who is the doctor
not
I said 10. Right why isn't it saying here I
guess I might have to go to hatch
so right so this is a default virtualbox IP
address right that's a fucking 24
oh nevermind nevermind that that's just
right here right
I got it backwards if you got it scared me
to death
yes I didn't get ready to take you for a day
out of this ability welcome welcome welcome
all your crazy welcome to the crazy
I know what the fuck are we doing right we
love having people visit
epso a24 wait a second
yeah we definitely have it over and overlap
that was the problem we had an overlap
Note 3 and 4 yeah yeah I think that's what
we'll do and then and then nobody's going to
nobody can touch that
can't touch this
we passed the part that we're cadres and we
made sure that the subnets were not
overlapping also weary you know did
everything we had to do a medium in it and a
joint and it was done
so I don't play around right now it is
unfortunately we're not come we can't say
with 100% of surety that the problem was the
overlapping eyepiece we can't say that
sleepy you no way it could have been that I
did something out of water in it but it did
all the indicators seem to be that was it
because it was never provided and was weird
and stuff so
I'm getting at here is
I think what we need to do just because if I
if I'm going to explain this to somebody
else I'm not going to have to tell him about
the other IP stuff right I want to be able
to just assume the default I want to
memorize it a false and I want to know about
the are you are I mean upon us or to see how
you are but I don't necessarily want to have
to live in that level with that level of
paranoia I think if we do 10:00. The only
problem with this if I had any other devices
on my network which I doubt I do everything
on the 10. Now we're carrying $10 is pretty
in a pretty broad but I I like that I think
I think I want to use this from now on you
are one is obviously the router
usually so we don't want. And and and and
and and
and I'm going to I'm going to go for them
if that works we really should not have to
do this year yourself
and if necessary and I mean
we should be able to do this only
and unbeatable it the only reason we're
doing that is because we wanted to know was
real the join to be able to go into the
right if you had
all right so I'm going to try this get diff
update advertise address yesterday I thought
I just did it today not do it
you know what is dropping this because if we
did the old one
and this is before I just laying here so 10.
0. 0
it's a lot to Ocean
get diff yeah we got the
thank you ready shell is now loaded
yep I think we're good to go so
no
all right and if you think we're dumping
this this might be the end of the day today
I need to bring storage Quest tomorrow at
all day probably early tonight
I don't know I feel like I should still keep
going with this I need to get to the point
where I'm at a storage classes with the end
of fast and we provisioned
that I need to do that I need to figure out
how to do that. So I got to get that done
like right away
nice places to go out faster this morning
but whatever I learned a fuck ton so
vagrant destroy or do we just see if they
could do a Reload I think we can do a Reload
I think we have to do I think we have to do
to destroy right
I don't know can we do a Reload and we'll
have it will pull down anyway message I will
try to restart the service
we know he didn't change anything actually I
don't even do that
I can just you cute I can do a cube ctre set
are you keeping me in reset right
I want to try that I want to try that
can we just do a reset
because of that cuz the IP stuff is not
going to work right
did they get stored in and it's Annette. Do
you know whatever
I'm trying I mean
I just throw it away anyway so don't the
left
set honey bees
Halifax right you're right I forgot about
that I forgot you're absolutely right
all right right all right fun
fragrance destroy reset reload install trim
saw
and at the same as a stray
I know that really is reloaded I don't like
I don't know I don't like this is only like
my fifth day of using Baker so we start Big
Red Machine loads New Vegas figuration
I see that's going to reinitialize anyway.
Rest is Academy reload
oh yeah okay I make sense all right so
Brian control node 102
SSH I cute ATM reset.
If headache
oh if you're expecting that you mean
force would have not had me do that right
I see and then
I see and then the reload is going to do it
without because it was going to throw out
the binaries gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha
gotcha yeah so
yeah we can do then I went right fuck that
Hodad's
nope
healthstop pod connection refused said cuz
he didn't control first
oh I was that was bad so I just throw it
away
I didn't know if I should the notes First
Citizen notes first
thank God it's a virtual machine alright so
vagrant I love sugar do permission to from
machine right
what is that only do the provisioning I
can't remember I can't remember
and there's no man there is no man there is
only Zuul
there's only Zuul
you have a lovely singing voice
yeah this to
I'm getting tired it's now it's time for me
to step away from the keyboard after doing
this last night on my own a little bit I
lost every fucking game in Monsters failure
is like one night I'll go and I'll have like
a kick ass like all night I'll win every
single game and after a full day of
kubernetes I tried to play DotA and failed
five games in a row
I just couldn't do it it's like they know
your game I know your game yeah my tiny one
I hear you have a grants reload thanks for
all the help
and thank you for all the fish we need to
get that one too
I don't know if he will think of that movie
in general
goodnight e goodnight ladies goodnight
lighters
I'm getting silly probably time for me to go
no one likes a silly 50 year old man
put on my prospector face
all right here we go
or I can put on my Navy Seals cap which
keeps my bald head fashionably warm
yeah I just had is so perfect because it's
not too to like heavy and it's not tight
doesn't cut your circulation my Patagonia
caps suck they suck all of their horn
they're actually horrible this thing however
Bliss hey anybody watch anybody seen the
anybody anybody watch the Boba Fett book of
Boba Fett I fucking love it
I love it go team tusken Raiders oh my God I
just watched the episode with all the
the episode with all the tusken Raiders I'm
not going to give it away so cool
makes me hate Anakin even more
I'll just say there is a walrus man
there is a walrus man
wait what that was all reinstall
we should have the results already there
righto I'll look
I'll look and now it's 10. 2 okie dokie
good nights for ladies
I will do our sinks with your pain sink
again
that's your pain sink let's do it
Cube admin ATM Dash
dash if you're a server advertise
address is 10. 0. 0. 2
open eating it stupid fucking emacs mode
there we go that's looks good
SSH into node one Ascension 2
okie dokie now here comes the magic
set W sink pains on are you ready are you
ready for the magic
that's right
how many CPUs do we have I'm sure you want
to know and proc will tell you we have two
seat fuse on control
2 horse whenever we have one here and one
here how much memory do we have on them I'm
sure you want to ask 3-8
yeah I'm going to gig on each she's actually
too big and no swapswap cell turned off
there is no swap and we are now able to join
our stuff I forgot my drink man though I got
to get it into ATM
join god dammit
I forgot to join game and I am sorry but you
can print it out if you need forgot to get a
new one
it's actually token something
comedian token that says join
create create Prince
join there we go
all right now is copy this over here
and then this one right here going to do a
crossover that's okay
and then there's a b at the end
now that should join the join that's on the
control plane should be automatic
so we should be fine
watch both our systems joint at the same
time
actually we canactually we can set up all of
our completion on each 12 kind of
and we can't and I can't because this is
your friend Adam in file for Q-See field I'm
going to turn my thing off
so now what now we do I mean
Q-See tell completion Bash and I need a cube
c t l
tab tab get notes to episodes the hello
x 4 Cube config equals at Sakura Nettie's
admin
and then get knowing there's our notes and
look our notes are ready
that's fascinating this is somebody was
talking about this last time our nose are
not supposed to be ready you know why
they're ready because there's stuff still in
at CNET. Too even though it's fucked up is
lying to us
are not answering it to you whatever it is
it's actually lying this is a lie I'm
telling you it's a lie
it's falsely ready yeah it's not good
somebody was saying that it showed ready and
then they were confused that's because we
still haven't installed the the Pod thing
but it kind of thinks it's there but it's
not so you have to go you have to go do the
Calico install
and that I have here
so let's do this on it anywhere that's got
to keep CDL control access
it does not Envy in Cube system so I don't
even think we need to have you in the right
context I think we have to set the namespace
contacts I think it just works
mostly because I think it's cute sea tale by
the fault was probably look at that
Adidas pants gets pods
I mean that they're still stuck reading the
containers I just wish they all veggie do
you think
so before they weren't in that state they
were in sort of a different state
yeah that's that's It's Curious it's very
curious
36 of those already. A62 knows already but
it's not
I mean that I'm this entire thing just for
discovering that kind of disagreement from
reality is worth it just that one little
thing
so and an hour to do
watch GigaParts can you system
fuck we did it only for communities
alrighty
running running running
I don't know this is taking longer than
usual
I want that we fuck up what did I look up
when it for you to give you a better I
wonder if it says some configuration stuff
in there somewhere
is because a Calico Q controllers aren't the
neither
I want to see what's happening
oh
how do they all have the same IP address
it doesn't make any sense
you know what it we dropped it I dropped the
p i t r i mean apart and server cidr I think
he needs it
Neff doesn't how to select interface cuz we
didn't tell it
so note to self you cannot drop
accent like that we're going to do a reset
again tonight so I'm going after all the
reset this is again repetition repetition
reputation repetition of a Play hack the box
I break my systems
edit Damon said Calico node
you want to fix it you and you're a Fix-It I
first of all I want to make sure that I get
this line right
right must I must I screwed up next time so
it's
server or network network cidr
10. No we're supposed to be 192 why didn't
you pick up the default
someone tell me why I didn't use the default
like I supposed to
I'm kind of pissed in the whole time I was I
was sold
the hopefully that was really going to
simplify that right we renew 192.168
add 0. 0 / 16 which is the default
but it didn't use the default
so the reason they keep putting a series
that they're like a Yoshi and I might
actually need this thing I apparently Calico
needs it so
even though that's the default it's a Calico
kind of miss you alrighty well
that's just on every single one right I
guess Cube
God damn it I have to do all that shit again
Patrol don't need this I don't need this
cigarettes Sea-Doo
I just said again
I didn't mean repetition Maybe repetition is
good
alright so
okay get ice and keep system
forgot and think it worked
oh I'm stupid I'm stupid
8. This is what I want to get memorize to so
config set contacts
no queue system
alright so okay edit
Damon said Calico good thing I know VI
and I didn't stick with and I didn't force
myself to learn emacs and I'm not learning
commission U of M shit
I just have to put that in there and go to
EnV
God damn
so it's the damage that you you study the
Calico damn is it actually I'm impressed
I'm impressed
he's do I got a text or nothing. Equals
we can't do the full $24 cuz we used all of
it
I think you're confusing your your stuff I
don't think we can do that
are we supposed to put the 1927 there when I
say 168 stuff right
that we reserve the 10.0 addresses for all
the hardware or is this the hardware thing
so tell him to use the interface that has
the network
she said her face was has a network meaning
of that
so it'll detected it and then it'll put the
other stuff in there interesting okay
I know I would have known this one IP Auto
detection
the Calico thing huh
I got a detection method
value
as a weird Hero 6 at you soon officials I
was going to say so
it must have been a messed pick the
interface was going to run on but then it
has two is still has to set the 192
addresses or that's that's that's that's a
different thing it's going for something by
default that's totally different right so
all right I hear you I just seems very odd
is that this was a mistake I was not valid
Fountain Valley
you know why because the fucking
as afraid of that I was afraid of that
fucking tabs
oh my God it actually looks for the IP
ranges and then figure out what interface
based on the numbers
shit that's horrible
so are you telling me that is setting the
saying the same thing the Pod network cidr
is not going to fix this is it
is that going to fix it nope so I'm going to
have to do something like this
well I get the first two I try to not think
about
let me have to delete those are they
fuck you fuck you and your non Alias is this
is why I hate aliases
hair braiding well that nose all that nose
running we ever sell the OneNote this
morning
if I did it right if you need to restart
something
that is really fucked up I Calico thing I
need to read all the docks for Calico
this is the control plane
are they supposed to do it on the other one
one second ago
if you didn't take yeah.
IAH developer how are you
and I know I would have thought it would
have changed her wait we have to wait for
the refresh your old do you think I have to
force the delete or the rolling restart on
the pods
I'm kind of thinking I might need to what do
you think
I think you need to really restart the pods
Brazilian
k
here we go again
and Evan
oh it's pretty good it's been educational if
nothing else where to go to
or is it for a log Calico
cni containers
oh shit
Calico node
that was fast
migration Alyssa Calico FM complete I know I
found directory
that's what you might do stuff this little
stuff since
yeah sfm stock
Cube system Calico whatever yeah I'm just
getting to the thing down
Les Calico node Calico node
I don't have to hear
Xenia star status and when I get that one
Hey look can't talk to 1096
700 problems again same time is it for
I want to thank that Calico actually cares
about the pods Services supposed acacian
this isn't a thing to do with it I know it
is like but it's not work related right
interesting
if I can't talk to the services is it
because we put everything else on the 10.
Network and now we have a conflict I think
that's it
we do I think we have a I think we have a
I also I also think it will look this is 10.
0. 96 right
so if those networks are physically
connected isn't isn't setting our 10. No.
No. No. 24/24 is that an overlap
hey I got it going been exhausting
I sent it 96 and we did tell her okay you
got me you got me on that one okay
Highway 24 all right that's fine yeah it's
2424 is just the last week right that's
Tuesday 5 to 5:20.
All right I'll make sense so that's not it I
think it is I think it is the CID our stuff
there's when I throw this away
I got a whole thing with Labs I just decided
to have a repo and if you're right about
that
excited at the marathon. This is a new thing
I'm going to try to recommend
yeah goodnight Brioni
can reset again and remove myself or I can
just destroy and try it all over again
yeah no problem I just wanted to let you
know that
is consolidating these and
I did a thing on important Repose you should
have
yeah I mean the other way to do it I just
don't know how we're going to do a clean
install
at the thing I need to think about what
you're doing this is it is if if we didn't
have the ability to reset it like how would
you fix it if you couldn't do that
right now and you probably be
you can you can reset and then remove the
Seeing Eye stuff and then go if I couldn't
just blow out the machine which you normally
couldn't do so it's good point
I want to say agua for you guys I got the
whole idea of like crazy in Temple for lab
and stuff I think we need to move away from
that just have a sandwich single a visit a
place to dump all your notes everything and
then I think your
I think we need to figure out another way to
write I mean a whole thing of it here
I don't know if you can see here I mean
since August here I just want to show
so we need to do
I think I think when we make a registry were
going to make projects experiments exercises
and tests and bottom line is
we're going to need to refer to a project or
something like that so that's how we can do
that
I think the thing works going to write up is
going to be more like the challenges that we
ended up doing
I think riding the exercise / challenge down
and or the specification for project
I do those are the things those ideas for
things to do and the badge right so badges
projects
and exercises such challenges those are the
things that we should that we should create
repositories of and people can go there and
then go find other people's research on a
based on their unique identifiers sooner so
that's I thought about that a lot this
morning when I woke up right so that's um
let's do this let's dolet's do
I do how you do
brexit and just know we need reset
everything right so
all right and reset
managing directors of our live
then what is taking too long
it doesn't look good this does not look good
I try to see where is the average elevation
in Enterprise appointment
even though you going to pay for it
entrance if you cosplay especially in
machine learning close to where GPS all that
matters
with me even being able to tweak your here
in points machines this deal is a big deal
and I just was a physical machine imagine
mr. Gyros I wonder if we have to know what
if we did
I'm going to remove everything in seeing eye
right I can get this wrong
is an entity was it and then it where is it
it's Nets
far where is it at Dottie
I was seeing I right
202 doo doo doo doo
do do to do to do to to well sir
I'd rather restarting reload Desiree start
right
he currently doing
do what you do do do do do do do I feel
positive that this is going to work
I'd rather go to bed what time is it
hey what my disk drive is making all kinds
of noise
I want to give me a 32 core threadripper
light Minister Valdez
I was apologizing cuz this last released he
did from his laptop and he doesn't normally
work from a laptop
emo
I mean set up an independent Calico for sure
I want to see if you have a Calico and do a
deep dive NFS okay so that three main
batteries sets that kubernetes uses that I
need to really get down and dirty with
is calico for the cni container D or Creo
for the the runtime of your face
and
NFS for the storage glass and so we have to
figure out what the preferred storage
classes for an FS
Anderson is another one we need
an Ingress I really saw it in your S8 I need
a saw it in your ass and then I needed Salt
and NAD middle of me those are the batteries
that people add to kubernetes because
they're not included I really should
understand this to you as well my fucking
hate is to you
but have the minister at so we got to know
it Sam
so are we got
all right so as to save control c u r s u s
I don't want to listen to store Scotch just
manually create feces
so what you going to tell me that there's
another one no that's better or something
advertise do you want do you want to do this
I don't think we need to do that but it
what's wrong with that is
wait what's it going down to Calico stuff
I think we are right
cuz I want to change the IVs in at 1
we had to change IP to Newton at 1
wait a second
I thought we would get all the season two
faults I wanted to use the eyepiece of
yeah but we had a subnet mask that was weird
so
it was a spot that when I pee I was trying
to use the defaults
and so I'm I'm just curious why
wait
that I mean the Calico thing I want to
believe that the thing that we're struggling
right now that I'm struggling with is
is primarily because we didn't set up the
I didn't set the Pod to pod Network cidr
because that that's the that was a part of
it I think
so let's just work another one
x 4 Cube think
sending okay
they're pending or not ready the way they're
supposed to be like that's what we want
right before they were waiting on container
so this is already different
and the notes themselves yes
and they're not ready okay so this is
already better right
so when we haven't had any other changes
whatsoever so far so good
yeah I know getting a nervous so now we need
to run our cute if you apply it Calico on
here
I still don't think we need that we're going
to separate that I don't want to I do not
want to do the wrong thing here
running container creating
Brandon I didn't join it
today I did in front of me
has point on the carrots, taking forever to
download
or not and I can't download it cuz of that
face
yeah I like that maybe iptables gets messed
up no
and I two options we can continue to kind of
work around this and when we can try to
resend you a comedian with the PID with a
beat with a pot server Network
cuz I could still this is still okay right
this is still going to be okay
is it not I wonder if there's like some 10.
Overlap I know we don't know supposed to be
you know very well
I wonder if there's some peace baby tables
files that have like regular kids favorite
like writes this stuff they sell that they
weren't loves to write this shit
so
that looks like it we got closer but not
quite all the way there
is Emily network-related whatever it is it's
not work related yeah
since I'm out
no access
but are you
rise LOL I don't know
as exactly the same thing whoa
my quarters are cool I wish I could do it
it's hard work do him like hard work
do you watch Mikey on which he does at New
York
is a streamer and i r l
it's not because there's an overlap in the
subnets again is it because we have a 10.
Going on and have it turned on 96th and
maybe I got to subnet
wrong
I think I kind of think I did get to
something wrong because it's / 24 should it
be / 16
I think it's supposed to be / 16 yeah
I think we do have it wrong I think I think
it's exactly the same problem we had before
I saw 16 not not in the one that
we have a / 24 somewhere I can't remember
where
are you talking about you're talking about
the
the server the service is right
yeah
I don't and that is rent was your own one
day over that for sure
02 and is 0
yeah
I got my number is wrong with our way to be
/ 1/8 is the one that uses all three outfits
right and I am dyslexic elimin8 it is 8 the
one that uses all 3 of debts the last three
octaves are the 24 that's why I'm using my
285 70 mess so
always the last okay I got it wrong in so 88
is when these is the first aid and that
would make sense because you know
all right so that okay
well then then I'm in the only other thing
that we can try besides complete restall is
to do the Q ATM using the the PID thing
I mean using the letter Y
how can you tell well then why why is it
trying to talk to
Nintendo network
the only thing I can say is at this point
the only difference between the two has been
that argument that's been the only thing
it could be the decision of fault but for
some reason it must trigger something that
doesn't mean differently I don't know what
that that's the only thing that's been
different other than the range other than
the range that we just take check the range
I knew it would be interesting to check it
back on the way okay that and we haven't
done a full clear out of everything right
oh
shit nothing there
because this is not right
there's still a number of variables here so
one of them is that we haven't totally reset
that thanks
that's weird
what you think it changed
interesting yeah I mean if there's many many
possibilities I would not know any of them
I mean I do remember this destruction
staying pretty had waited to write those in
there
it kept saying is you're seeing I need it
let's try can we try this couch right or
reset
again I'm going to reset going to clear out
to see the Chucky
and then we're going to
we'll try the comedian with the with the
possible range
and if that doesn't do it then it's it's
it's back to resetting the whole thing go
back and let me know what works and making
more incremental changes
everything from scratch my same time yeah
yeah let's do that and this case that that's
that's fine right cuz we might be missing
something
yeah I like but I don't know if I went in
this case I think it was a bit I mean if it
works then
we can still help isolate the problems right
it doesn't work that well that's actually
really important right so if it doesn't work
then we absolutely know that is either
changing this this number to get somehow
conflicting or
or we need this in whatever version right
now this is the only two options because we
got it to work that way those are the only
two things have changed and I mean I feel
like we have to kind of go back and isolate
with changed so
so yeah same thing long time but I don't
care
I want to I want to an absolute clean redo
is that one time at work we actually deleted
that vagrant file as well even if it's like
really really clean slate
and I want to buy it could be the timing and
could be the timing of one thing coming
through before something else does I had
that problem with makeup before
in a provisioning is like one thing would
not be finished in since it was not
synchronous in this route
it was now no way to know what thing was it
was going to finish first
I I know that's what I'm saying the real
Otis has the recreate Which Wich
unlike you I'm still really interested in
figuring out how to do this with and anyway
because
you always have that option and pulling the
plug on the machine
you know you have the fucking chase that
shit down I would be a pain in the ass
Professor summer with so little experience
like me I mean right now anyway I mean I
could do it I'm good at finding problems
usually but but this
I kind of want to know what it is
I had the feeling the moral of the story is
just always put pod server IPs and you are
on everything
men nll make your day go better
I don't want that to be true but I just feel
like that's what it is because that's what
they keep screaming about it and then
stalled Ox I really hope we don't have to do
a Calico configuration specifically
wait we left that old cow configuration in
there too
oh no we didn't know it was snowing at
nevermind no I didn't know it was in that
was in the resource we had to do directly
and communities in the coronavirus at
someone away
we did not do that the second time though
maybe that was what was missing
remember that when we added the environment
variables Calico we didn't do that the
second time
remember when we did it like we did live
update on the on the couch with the
Federation
the name is a configuration we added that
and then to try right before this one yeah
could be how do you say
what time is it me and my nine hour streams
not a single fish in sight
we're going to get through this town is
going to be like really fast though I want
to get that down so I can do it in like
really quick quickly
so many moving pieces in this whole thing
though I mean this is this is why I like
traditional admits they see this shit and
they run there was one run screaming and I
fuck that I want nothing to do with it
usually he's at and does business partner
work interesting
you know you could have been just a minute
reset
we'll know soon enough because if that
I mean the one thing is we write about this
is we don't have to do all these steps Again
by hand and I always have to tell myself
that in the old days
resetting a system like this it's also makes
me like shutter at the idea of even that
booting again because you have to change
your images Annette Boudreaux and you could
never change the static image that would be
so bad
so you want to have an ansible thing that
runs after you refuse to do an option
a lot of this stuff is really sold me on
virtualization all over again even if you
take a performance penalty
hey I just cannot imagine the amount of time
lost doing all of this if we didn't have her
Tools location
it would be weeks our days at least
machine booted and ready vagrant shell
what are people doing today on Twitch I
doing something fun
who she talking about Jewel Jewel in Julian
I don't know if I want to go look at that
it's terrifying
yeah oh no a president is saying bad things
in what Universe do you think we live in
I mean I was hoping you would be better but
you're more than good old days and
presidents didn't say shit that was horrible
I just did shit that was horrible and close
doors and close to parts
once upon a time remember that
yeah all right so where do I go
with installation I could be true
comedian and it let me do it without it
API server advertise address
and I see what I see right at 2
right
Sia
do do do do do do do do do to do to do do do
do
do do do do
I feel happy I got time for an hour
how goes it
we shall now ask connect to Note 1
Minister work last time so I don't have any
doubt this can work this time
it was just it's the Calico stuff is not
working
have to be root of course god dammit
to do do do do do
tutu tutu tutu tutu dance on the Christmas
Merry Christmas I wanted it to be longer
I really did longer Christmas sex time
longer Christmas song or Christmas
a boy well that went well
not ready as we would expect
and pending as we also would expect
and now for the Moment of Truth we shall do
the apply with nothing more
nothing more than this humble apply
to get our wonderful Calico which I'm sure
is going to work without a problem
I have faith
see if I can just tell it's already working
can you just see it it's in an estate
it's all Happy Paws initialized here we go
containers are creating up this or that
stuff last time one of them came up
but not the one there
no dice no dice that is so lame
that is so lame
slimme1 came up pretty quick pretty quick
it's okay
from scratch it means Wiki ready accident
strictly speaking it's not from scratch
right because it's because we've used him
yeah let's do this let's go look at the long
again
I'm getting better at this it's a good
practice so I do not have a mon this time at
all
calico containers Calico
yeah I mean it's exactly the same I wish it
was in here I'll wait
potatoes Calico
2 222
what the ellipse
are you come out
and then we kiss you when I reset this this
one
I need to know if you can do this so much
ride anyway yes
and I'm going to cube ATM reset this one
yes and then I'm going to use this version
so happens
yeah we didn't delete it I'm trying it
without it first and then after that we'll
read it until I get the stuff in the stuff
in
Addison ice last night buddy if it doesn't
work out then next
didn't we do this
if it doesn't work I have you really fucking
baffled
the only thing difference between this and
the last one is the IP range that's it
and then I did we just get lucky
so yeah we definitely do
CareCredit okay and we know that these are
fucked up because you didn't clean out we
didn't clean out and see a nice last night.
But but
are less on track and then we'll do it that
way we'll do it the official we've gotten
this over before with that being kind of
hosted just because Brianna said that they
had the same problem so be able to know
about that promise super important
give me some be so great if it worked
running house fast shit that was fast
probably cuz it already has it download it
oh my God
oh my God oh my God
Leo
so the moral of the story is Val shalt
include pots service here you are in 1.2 3
and to be fair to LPG videos not using the
same versions kubernetes as I am
so and you know this is consistent with what
the documentation told us to do to
so the takeaway of this little going to
settle is now shall always put the pier it
is it is weird
eppinette if I fix it so
yeah I'm glad it's working I don't know so
well
and how how much different is this then is
the slash 17 that we had before right you
think I'm an official have the numbers in
them to see how you are in a Mil yeah let's
go check
let's go check that for sure so antsy
Freddy's grab that shower cidr
there you go holyshit
that is weird I'll be seeing you see that
you what that means that means that
something changed
that it's it wasn't writing that before so
even though it was the fault it wasn't
writing it
did you order your slicker nice like Alexa
so them
the really cool thing about this is is it
hey or appendix how you doing
is we actually know specifically
that you have it I'm going to put that in
his this is like so important
I'm going to let it out cuz I don't feel
like riding a big long you know Treatise on
it right now I think we already did
something related to this
and I give you probably doing wrong or
commiseration Resource Commission keeping it
came and yeah yeah
it could be a 123 bug I used to text cuz I'm
lame yeah
answer seidr
tell me five it's going to really want to
know about that yeah that's fucking weird
that's fucking weird is that the actual
default
yeah this isn't this is away 16
going stuff from the galang I think I think
from the golang project
I had three it can be resold on Amazon now
you can bet you about off Amazon
yeah yeah that's right I think that's what
about it
I can't remember honestly I don't remember
my trash in there somewhere
yeah I know so so there we go
yeah it was a horse Worcester but we
definitely got it we definitely got it so I
I don't know why this point
I want to take you cause it I think
no I no way I would never have known if it
if you have it is over I would never have
known to do that
at one another do any of this stuff so
even though the duchess parts or czr us
seems
I have a feeling it's a bug in Calico
I do, go back to the log and see how it
connected don't you like how did it connect
when do note to write with this dude on one
and I kind of want to see how it did connect
yeah we didn't do that extra configuration
thing either maybe they updated Calico from
4 to 3 I don't know if I'm glad right I
would rather add a city yard then didn't
have to add yet another additional
configuration for Calico
is in the docks seeing your art doesn't have
a default really
isn't going to get that right there is no
default
well you have a doctor that refers to that
it's not just on the main page
is there a resource for that
that's true I really want to knock that
resource and get that right so
God dammit is it really
wow count to go read it
right now so I can understand cuz I have to
answer any questions on the test about this
so stuff like that
execute the following phases we know about
this
options API is a bad idea
and you guys are
what is going to be the address
and you and you have added a second
h.h. on interface for the
private Network to get stuff to talk to each
other I kind of feel like we need to do
free to play around with what what if we got
the default network interface to do the
right thing like if we if we were to use
vagrant and to set it up as a as Bridget
instead of Matt
it would put it it would put it on the same
network as the rest of our stuff on her own
internal IP network
but I feel like that's also dangerous
because now it's going to be by chatting
with other stuff on my internal Network here
you can't interesting okay imma try that
oh shit they don't need to be not
a vagrant needs to be. I could have swore I
saw I could have swore I saw switch for that
Napier server addresses in the IP addresses
that the who advertises listen
this will be external and listening on six
sex 443
if I'm never going to face what we use but
this is a huge from my work my finger
anywhere and you have added a second
interface with the phone I just to talk to
each other without adding this your
set up will default to an interface that
isn't connected to anything
it's ready or what get rid of ignorant. Are
the natting
yeah
I mean I understand why they're doing it you
know it's safer to do its way safer to do
that
I would probably do the opposite that didn't
really kill myself cuz I'm definitely not
good to
draw that shit on the Food Network
this actually relates to what I'm going to
teach you the Boost because
and the booths were definitely going to get
you know
we're having a talk about work some machines
are going to say while should you brush your
not right and
unless you have a really really good reason
you should probably use now
and even want to know the difference is a
well one of them is like the computers
inside your computer the other ones like the
computer is next to your computer even
though it's all inside a computer tech
nothing
so
even if I'd say I cannot pass over share
your seems like people like people will
spend like 5 hours trying to trying to be
the hockey box game you know hacking it I
consider this hacking this gives me every
bit of satisfaction as playing at the box
for 9 hours straight
it's the same exact thing it's the same how
can I hack this to do what it's supposed to
do
are going a bit better it doesn't you know
these workarounds interesting because it
doesn't have them right
yeah I I I know I you know I delivered we
did it live you did live
that might have been a reason who knows
Orson how are you
yeah bigger bigger is Fox up in her face is
really bad and we found out
we found out out yeah bigger and doesn't say
a word instead of Mac address at all
and then I know it was using the same IP
address for every interface
every every machine because since were
nodding and then
no beyond that I don't know all I know is
adding Pawn server cidr fix it
how many things but that fix it
it still does rotational it something it's
something that you can see her being his
fault that's why I keep getting I would
really like to know what the modify eth0 to
do the right thing and it made me think of
it as the only interface
I feel like I feel like we're
I feel like we're kind of out of bounds a
little bit by using an additional interface
instead of using the default eth0 interface
but but vagrant needs it
yeah you need to redo 20 cm face that's
what's up because any of the standard
instructions for installation
are any of the standard installation
instructions
you know depend on using the default
interface and when you put it back on and
they're really fixing them
all right it's not a Calico bug usual
problem with that when
it seems the problem
is related to vagrants requirements for eth0
as the
management interface for itself therefore
requiring the creation of e t h 2
with a private Network
regrets other active
this change to the default Air Forces
certain things to be explicitly defined
or it's like you see seals qtm
or and seems to get confused
xnxubd
yeah
yeah well thank you for validating our
solution that we just spent an hour coming
to
I couldn't hear that you had that problem
you had the same fix it is a really good to
hear it I mean it I mean it I mean it I'm
not you know I'm not that there's no sarcasm
at all because we we we we we weren't even
sure that of this results until it happened
and they were like well it doesn't make any
sense because the error messages are saying
that it can't get the 10. 96
and we like what the fuck it's like network
is not working at all in this thing and
and it didn't make any sense cuz he needed a
piece of use default file Network
and I don't think we have it I don't think
there is a default on that works out what
you're saying I really want to read that I
think it I think I want to take a moment to
understand which networks have defaults and
which ones don't and how many networks are
we talkin about here you know what I mean
and because we're actually talking about a
third network away or an extra now we're
going to turn my big horn Big Red's you know
the master control Network on the 10.
Network that's not it so we have yet another
Network to deal with
so you know I'm saying on Summer
oh right now work thank you
MaryI married a s
oh yeah I do it again
yeah I don't want that locked in my brain
yeah
alright so
an unusual problem Calico can raise the play
the look of a reverse camera situation with
Kevin and wrinkly it seems the problem is
way too vigorous requirement for the 80s
your office management or face
Brian creation an additional
ath1
with the private records record this change
the default forces certain things to be
explicit
explicit arguments
certain optional arguments
CV required I guess
down the fall route interface which makes
regular kind of whack yeah that's a great
way of putting it
to put it in the words of Porsche nest
Calico on stew be in the default
route interface
which makes vagrants kind of black
also thanks to
a g g i n for and then hours
how can you debug ETSU
it did that was so weird
configure it yeah
give me a minute
exact address of the official Robert says
it's listening on its default will be
external on the Samsung 43
and test with tell tell Nance
and I said that I liked it because it's on
there installing the phone network in recent
years but this is a huge problem working
with fragrant you just might be tonight and
have added a second case one of the private
networks get stuck each other for CV father
yeah
I could not believe that donut was was on
redhead by default then that was weird
I know
it's a VIP mod why I don't know
I said I want it open this for second want
to read something here
in
again we go so the default network interface
will be used if not
the default is 6430 answer the phone as well
EXO cert directory as a default
3 string
I hear you. So the service is a default
figuring Catching Fire Guard
so
so i s role-playing will automatically I can
send yours everything
Social Services have a stat services or
default address Network 1096 that's good to
know
the appears that bigger has a default IP
network of 10.0.2
Venezuela to that seems to be the default
subnet for vagrant if you don't provide
anything else so far everything we've made
has been intended 02 if you have
there is apparently as you said no default
for the Pod cidr Network
the pond the pond
pod Network cidr
Cardenas did not work until I put it on
there
it would appear Cornelius is it a fault
I figured you'd be for not using convenient
to pick Prince yes
The Raconteurs images
every fear that was that's all
networking crd string Pat to the network
director that contains a files named
this is why I came to find range of IP
addresses for the Pod Network
it said the control plan will automatically
Alta terriers for every node
use alternative range for service Eyed Peas
okay so so this is not does not have enough
salt
which it was a really leaves me wondering
whenever I see I understand why you were
doing that environment change LBG now I
understand completely you were saying that
he was sick was picking it up off the
interface and it did the configuration
changes you were doing for the Calico cat
think we're related to changing the IP the
IP of the interface for Calico to pick up
and you were telling it to pick up the
interface still have to pick up the other
interfaces 1000 Network and by doing so then
it would like resolve its own. And part
number to a Dr stuff
I see why you were doing that now because
you are trying yeah you you are trying to
get it to
to infer the IP range based on what it
detected
for the interface was on because like like
my promotions think that because it went to
the default because it looked at the default
eth0 its other 10.0 tattoo and probably try
to just to do rounding on that
whatever reason we couldn't confirm rules in
the routes or anything and I got that wrong
so
is Alexa Calvin out of curiosity house
working absolutely all right so so that
that's working
and if I feel like this is this is good
enough for now
okay
I got it wrong well let me the first time
I mean I don't really need to know when
calicos doing other than how it works what
works in the day but I I am very curious to
see how to check the no doubt I thought we
did check it out already I only know two one
is working
as long as you can route those addresses
that's that's why we were so confused
I mean at least we were both confused since
I didn't read it that way and it's like
and when in doubt at it just to be sure it's
a safe was going to save you such a big
hassle if it doesn't work
kind of shit now working yeah
yep and they have pretty shit networking I
mean that's pretty sure I meet them open
bugs on the on the Mac problems
and if it if it turns to be much more
substantial than that I want to look for an
alternate that I don't know I don't I don't
I don't know what else is out there making a
whole bunch of Packer things and build your
own network
just making sure I calls the d-box manager
or something I don't know what they'll turn
it is you know
ansible terraform a telephone with the
telephone with it with a virtual watch
driver and then I'm open to that possibility
add peas and can I sell a Coon Rapids
so
Laura log containers
Plus
unless my talking about
Hungry Howie's there's nothing here
shit more Calico
no we want we want on what
I'm Brandon we need Cube system
node and then we need to Calico no log
what's her name
so I don't know if that I don't know if that
helped actually
start checking it every store connection
verified is for Freddy are getting resource
it's like Beautypedia
EZ Auto detected ipv4 address on Ethan
engineering 110. That was not there before
that I don't remember that line being that
way I remember they're seeing something else
there
I know that TV for change will check for
conflicts interesting
yeah it didn't get to this part it was like
I'm going to do a thing and then it failed
so and it's because this using Auto detected
address whatever Calico does to Auto detect
doesn't fly well with vagrants or at least
the way we were using Baker
okay so
no degree for changed check for conflicts
I didn't really do it did it no change
I guess I don't understand this line it's
like it change the IP
so this means the Pod was an IP before and
it changed it and it's like okay we're going
to do I automatically look for other
conflicts
but because of tools I had that rap DVD Mmm
Yeah Yeah I can see that usually being from
and I guess this is I'm just trying to hash
out you know beginner stuff it's been
extremely educational I mean God damn I've
learned so much and it's not the kind of
thing you can do unless you like try this
shit at home like you ATM if you don't even
have the beginning of understanding what
could possibly go wrong if you're just if
you just going off Theory and books and
doing some Vino
so I'm super happy for you even though it's
delayed my my storage stuff I'm going to
really kick ass tomorrow at work to make up
for the research I've been doing but I
consider this is extremely valuable research
so
at the front of no i p d i p I think that's
I would that's why I was confused because it
says it's changed it like there was nothing
before
so does that mean it was just picking up the
IP the default ethernet interface I imagine
that's what it was and that would explain
that would explain why I couldn't route
because it's that's that had lockdown Nat
management interface that varies
so it's been a good reminder of how
networking works and secondary interface is
excetera
so no no as number configured on no resource
Isabel value
give a damn configmap okay that's good
found this in the comedian could pick me up
this number right here came from
the cidr thing
that came from the Pod network cidr setting
that's exactly what it was set to
makes me wonder if
it got stuck on the step before but it
didn't print out these other statement these
other errors because I got so hung up over
there
I'll know it when is it going to be able to
be able to get it working at all wasn't
working so I could have even gotten a config
me up
f yeah
I think it was really weird about this is
after it happened it seems to have hosed up
other areas of networking on the system
we were okay so this is important
after we ran after we ran the Calico apply
we could no longer get logs and shit from
the infant
in fact we had to SSH into the nodeload and
read the logs outside of communities to get
to it
that suggests to me that the Calico apply
fucked up and networking of the cube proxies
well
and at least a return around
I mean because this before that I mean by
this is super important I want to make sure
I can remember this because before we apply
the Calico sea and I we were able to get
information and go back and forth and talk
to logs and everything we all the things you
can only do that or not populated we can do
it we can do just fine but then after Calico
came along
the basic you proxy not working wasn't
working anymore
I that I can't overstate how serious that is
if if that were to happen
yeah
if that were to happen in a production
environment that would be a streamly
critical outage
must be on the phone trap
so what happened is we install Calico Calico
said hey default route I'm a kick you out
and too pricey or whatever was using the
default route and yes it is said no I'm done
we're done here and Calico took it over
which is super bad and you're saying it's a
bigger bug because Victor has the fault this
is extremely unlikely to encounter in a
while because no computers very few
computers in the while they're going to have
different ethernet interface is for a
community's I mean most knows that one is
there a interface and that's it I mean they
might have more of those are not being used
that you teach one with off to these are you
have some saying yeah
LKQ proxy work before Calico setup properly
he told me I don't know what I'm trying to
say is I was like I don't even know what
your proxy I'm too new to know what I'm
telling you is it normal commands like
getting logs on them on the employee worked
I can do before I do the Calico fly I could
do keep CDL logs on the Pod and I could get
information even answer and after I did the
cow why didn't the cube shelf life for the
Calico H-E-B Source I could no longer get
Logs with the same exact amount and the only
way we can get logs is the SSH into the
known outside of communities
I'm just telling you the effect I'm telling
you the end-user affect I'm just saying it's
a big deal because if you if you can't
communicate with your nose because whatever
happened whatever reason doubt this dream is
just tanks my idea and then I know a lot of
us it has already my my exuberance about
about Metal base security token of thanks
you think I'd find differently make sure
they didn't find him
right I don't know what my plans are I'll go
back and read about plainedge and all that
so I'm just telling you the effect the
effect is it the command work before and
then afterward it stopped working and I'm
sure it's Network related and there's
different Communications we have a person we
went we went through that quite a bit we
went through will how How can any
communication happen whatsoever if there's
no see and I and obviously you can and it's
a different network and it says in its use
in Coop Roxy is probably got a different
name
are the bottom part of world is data plan
all right well that makes sense so the
control pain again to make your point out
the fact that installing Calico which is
supposed to be reduced in scope of severity
and risk to the date of plane having it fuck
up control plane Communications with the Pod
with an Ode to me that's a big fucking deal
I mean that's a big fucking deal for a free
Calico to like blow up the control plane
Communications
yeah I did
it did it stop the logs from working are you
saying that getting logs out the off the end
point is through community so you know that
you'll log command is it date of plane
operation is busy shoveling whatever
resources inresource doesn't exist pot yeah
or whatever I don't understand where you are
coming and so yeah everything is good at
work but looking up my video tell you we
were redoing standard things that are that
were fine and as at least intrigued with
regard to the logs command
write that specific command whatever
protocol use I don't care whatever for a
cayuse it did not work and it just see sore
and so we had to SSH into the reason I keep
harping on this is because I have been
really like froby caretti's on metal and
said Arrow antenna tell us about us up and
now I'm like fucking terrified of it
how the hell are you going to debug a
problem if you only have mtls access to the
thing and has to go over the API and then
and then you try to do a Calico installing
something like that until it goes her in her
brain nice
I don't even know if Sarah has its own sea
and I probably does I mean it doesn't make
any sense right
Jim you can't win Wednesday night at work
and you only have one tonight provider for a
cluster right
I get that right yeah
Heroes vs.
The logs function stopped working it's not
overly stressed
and I would be unable to rectify the
situation if I didn't have SSH access
it was Angelica would all have been whatever
that stopped me from communicating through
kubernetes with my endpoint for a specific
command that was the problem and that is a
big deal
Attalla says configure being for you see
when I mean that's that's that's that's that
I did right
okay so does that mean I don't know I
understand I don't understand enough
is Uranus see you then
just a totally is
let me know when you get your lungs as it
keeps each old man from the from the control
plane how is that not
but whatever it would take about one command
the fact that something that supposed to
work stopped working and the only way to get
it to work was to bypass all of Freddy's
that is not good that's not good and it sent
me it might have been a trivial thing I
might have been logged with the fact that
even existed raise his suspicions for me
anyway about other applications that might
promise the world and then have some quirky
thing that keeps pizza for you we we we
talked about this before I was saying if
it's somebody was saying that that they
don't trust the idea of of of non SSH access
to their nodes to the post so I should say
the most machines and and I I feel like
and I got today one and a zero install was
incorrect oh you weren't here for it so your
opinion doesn't matter
he chatted working we appreciate your
confirmation and what actually happened and
so we'll see we'll leave it at that is
completely unrelated to the problem we had
to because you don't know who you were here
I can't even kiss you to allow us to travel
to apps that are going through the essential
as well yeah I was thinking about the issue
that I have and you know having problem with
you or is that a an advertised things didn't
do what I was supposed to do and I don't
give a shit if it was vagrants fault the
fact is the reality is is that
one of the core commands for for diagnosing
your in points stopped working and all the
time not on the case but I can people I work
with a lot of times we say did they what
they would like doing like prematurely SSH
into the endpoints and start doing shit on
there as a cessation try to diagnose sings
Looking Through the catalogs and you know
and running a doctor or and or you know
whatever one is much I don't know what does
the the city i s e d i c t h and they're
doing it a lot and I was like oh yeah you
can do that and Cody has a chain and I think
that's a lot of like extra Administration
and security to have to keep lockdown you
know why can't we have this like black box
or the note and the machine combination and
that leaves me that makes me begging the
question what happens when is he and I is
provided by Sarah Oh and and you can't you
put Calico van everything else do you can
you have your own tonight so I take away
this is really just one thing I need to
understand the scope is he and I and how how
you can possibly have a difference in a
provider if at all
I have one simple question do you only have
one seeing a provider for cluster
is that is that true or not so
enemy X know and I appreciate your
experience yeah and everybody appreciates
mostly force it the number one thing I do
appreciate is that you confirm the findings
that we just had
so you've completely confirm that we were
there we were experiencing the problem that
you've also had so that is invaluable to me
I really appreciate that but yeah it's a
separate communication that communication
stops working you know this is what happened
I did it to see Jalen fly
on anyting anyting and the network stop
working on the known
Winter Garden communities
that that is what happened at you can blame
it on vagrants you can blame it on the
network configuration but the fact that you
can do that
that that is what concerns me is the fact
that you are even capable of fucking up
communication with your end point by simply
applying
you know in this case when I I think it's a
damn it said
and I think that's a big deal it never works
are you saying that logs would not have
worked at all cuz I'm pretty sure we did it
wherever those some of those instead of
psyllium Calico if I have another one that's
watching them to do
so
yes the lungs working that could help
financially did yeah
but that was the other thing too is that one
of the one of the nodes
when we applied the Calico thing one of them
worked one of the pods came online and that
was the one on the control plane that didn't
have to do any routing
datum plane because Calico is not
operational right okay
all right what is very possible it's very
possible that we did not try to log command
before Calico is installed on I could have
swore we did lvg to remember that's
something you were three creating I could
have swore we did
I just know that I can totally be great by
the way I know the exact steps to make a
break again just remove that argument
I want to think that we did the logs against
the then today to playing stuff and it
didn't work
that what you're saying it could very well
be and that would then we would all be in
agreement
this is a ride and yeah that was that was
that was not there I could have swore and
I'm questioning it now I could have swore we
did a logs query
I could have swore me to send the deposit
even exist
that was after we never tried it before
then. Did we I mean that's probably what it
is
that's probably what was his one day he'll
listen to you why don't you listen to me a
little bit huh
he really fond of telling other people to do
so you know yeah
yeah I think that's probably it now this is
nothing you told me is anything that she
knew the one flaw and everything that I said
here is being unsure about whether I ran the
logs against the pot that was remote but I
swear to God we did I swear to God we did
and that would that would break it to
confirm yeah I kind of want to I kind of
want to because
you know what that would be
I mean it makes an expiration date and plan
is appreciated I mean that we figured it was
something different there is anything
communication what you're saying is it logs
the logs communicating from pods have to use
the potty and I had was I don't have any
fucking at work at all and it and it and
that communication is a part of the datum
plane as opposed to standing in my in my
particular case
yeah well if it's possible and I would love
to be wrong and I guess we all definitely
test
what businesses are part of a bigger
question which I have and there's two big
questions one of them is how would I put
Sarah when points in here
number one if I'm managing my own cluster
right at managing my own cost and I want to
add something to tell us in points and
they're all in all things like Mama bus will
take care of all for you then obviously
they're providing their own see and I
if they're providing their own C&I what
about when I try to play I'm going to have
to create some tanks art alterations in or
did not deploy to Dad because it already
hasn't or is it going to answer any of you
and me to do the joint is going to show up
and it's going to try to do it is going to
say I'm sorry I don't need your fucking
seeing eye I got my own
in which case you know how are you managing
to seeing eye. Sit around and tell us their
needs or this new generation of of bare
metal and metal communities in points
and so the only way to talk to it at all is
through a m Tillis
grpc over mpls it has its own API and
you can mix and match
it it has its it has 100% has its own his
has its own API and you cannot SSH to the
thing and there there they're touting it is
and it's it's pretty pretty I don't know if
it's something is going to take off the
reason I'm interested in is I don't want to
have to run systems Administration test and
also Cooper days Administration underlying
hosts Network for all your nose you have two
large
collections of it architecture to support
you have all of the underlying systems whole
systems
and it's what I'm trying to say right now
you have all the underlying health systems
and then you have all of their kubernetes
systems on top of that and there's a number
of efforts including a cluster ctctel which
just went one Pinole in July
that are trying to to bridge this Gap
and I'm super intrigued by it I'm intrigued
by it but I'm also nervous and the people
have presented this to so far they're like
no way you're not taking away message access
to my house and like yeah but if you could
do it in a secure way so that there's
security was the number one concern to
Defcon about clusters and they're getting
hacked because people are breaking other
container engines and breaking out of
communities and they're gaining access to
the systems is happening all over the place
right now so as whether or not they're
always is is the answer I don't know but the
fact that they are attempting to address the
issue by saying even if you break out of
this you get read-only access to the file
system and nothing else that's the attempt
and whether they do it or not I don't know
they don't have you if you support and stuff
like that but I find it really fascinating
because if this works the future could be
the future could be coronavirus on metal and
which means that you're managing your entire
infrastructure to accommodate use instead of
having to basically two sets of
infrastructure that are intermesh you know
at the hip
you know at the hip you're you're you're
supporting your your Baseline host of us
whether or not you realize it or not some
for you and you're supporting all of your
camera Deez Nuts on top of that and so you
see you see it was torture people starting
to ask a question it would it be cool if we
could just manage all of the thing from one
interface and it might be fine in the sky
before definitely thinking about this I mean
is that cost $52 absolutely based on this is
it's based on this mean you know you only
have one thing to update right now like
right now the problem is is that we had this
time it's like people have to ask us to
cordon off note so that they can do system
upgrades I can upgrade the version of red
hat or something right so I have to take
down or kubernetes does and they got me can
you know you know shuffle all the the
container work off to something else and
then those things have to be cordoned off
and then naked they get their system
upgrades and we bring back up to software
I'm on there you know I'm saying and it
sometime
the opposite problem sometimes we need to
use an extra NVIDIA drivers me like that for
something any job than a machine-learning
job and so we have to tell a structure
people hey can you add this bit of of of
Hardware this bit of driver which doesn't
fall within the purview to create his people
so now they're putting drivers on his stuff
and we also have to take him down and we
have to coordinate that the coordination
between the infrastructure Engineering Group
and the communities Administration group is
is where the pain point is
what's that ya is Equestria man in the
customary system
yeah the guy is is pretty good it's got big
problems for just casually looking at it the
other day I went to bed I don't want to get
into it right now but but let's start with
the fact that you have to have a booty
bootstrap cluster yet they install Mini
Cooper for him use the thing doesn't work
unless you already have a cluster to do the
management see if they have an extra closer
you have to have a cluster and just to do
the management of the other Hardware cluster
because it's all the written for kubernetes
itself which is kind of cool it's like
eating your own dog for kind of thing but
it's multiple layers of complexity that that
I don't know I am not sold but yeah that's
it is what it is so you know this is a
really cool thing to do but you know what
another option would be thanks for that
I'm fine I would be any different either
right
so so yeah so I think that those are things
that that would eventually somebody
experiment and one likes it so much so they
talk to me and they got a premature to put
my name on there I'm not and I should have
put me on there I'm not in that I'm not an
expert on this shit all I happen to talk to
them like one day and then they threw me in
here and I'm like okay fine and then they
put me in here even though I wish they would
take me out but whatever it seems to me like
they're doing the right things though
they're doing what I want so I don't I don't
want
I don't want to fuck around with my
infrastructure and my crew bonetti's I want
both I want my peanut butter and my
chocolate together I'd I don't want to fuck
around it I I want to see you today and it
might be you know Pie in the Sky a dream and
I think you'll all agree on that mean if
your if your behind cluster cluster CTL then
you can probably there's a lot of there's a
lot of thoughts on the the idea of managing
Hardware through kubernetes and that's all I
just want to see where that goes there's a
couple of different takes on it as one you
know completely ephemeral read-only access
to know only through the API know what does
Ajax this is that one and was that I was
just find that measurement cluster is
necessary
and the only reason a management class it
would be necessary as if you would grab the
keishin as a couple days application. Which
I would have done I would have done that but
that's what they decided to do there's a
certain time when you can put Grey's aside
and you can say you know what we don't have
to make everything a kubernetes application
we can make it a standalone single
executable that's that's bloated and has
everything in the world in it and I would
rather they have a good day would have dress
that the reason that you have to do it is
because there's so many different types of
hardware and shit in apis everything you
have to talk to you and you can't put
everything into a
put everything into a single executable
because there's so many layers and seems and
all the same reasons that could bring it is
just a bunch of apis at the end of the day
that's what they end up doing yeah how do
you manage and clusters exactly an end that
well. You know that's what coronavirus is
designed to do is designed as you a lots of
going to manage lots of different things
through lots of abstraction a lots of ppis
and you know at some point yeah sure I feel
like I feel like people reached too quickly
for that though I think that they should
stop the bad think about it you know they
did it right I don't know that they would
have made that they necessarily had to make
a kubernetes application to manage a turban
in his application that's running on
communities on Hardware that's managed as
hosting communities
it's just a certain level of complexity
that's there is people think it's necessary
and call me naive for saying so I don't
think it's necessary every time and I hope
you will agree with me and I just told me
her and say there are people that agree that
this doesn't happen to know that one exists
and if that weren't true so anyway I just I
wish that they had known that was there when
we start of some Alternatives that's my
first procedure coasters you feel and I
think it's been thinking about it I also
think it's extremely fascinating what
they're doing over here with this little
black box kind of thing over his dinner as
well
was model happy to Cheryl I think it's
important I'm not really interested but if
you wanted to talk about it you know to me
it feels like a solution that's coming from
an over engineered background and it and I
don't like that I don't I don't like over
engineered Solutions I barely like you're
ready and there's a ton of shit about the
raise that I think it's just way over the
top of the necessary and and I think so
going to get you a black check mark today in
the world but you know it's I try to call it
like I see it. Is it going Aaron welcome
so yep mystical I mean forcing all we need
to do is we need to have we need to have you
I know if you'd be willing to talk on on
Discord we should have you and Tony 5 we can
get 20 for the talk go through that because
I think that what that's not immediately
relevant to anything that we're doing right
now to get a job or anything but in the next
five years this is going to be a big deal
because it's going to save companies tons of
money giving management was garbage yeah it
absolutely is it still is I know I
completely agree and if you're talking about
just general config management
nobody is as fix that nobody is fix it yeah
it's still it's still a problem and it's not
just that there's like other kick management
out that it sucks to I don't know I don't
know I don't I don't know that
Community Solutions I'll have to say I don't
know I don't know I haven't followed it that
that closely I
I don't know I think one of the solutions is
to remove options personally and to have
opinions and communities is like really
hates having opinions as soon as coronavirus
has an opinion is like oh fuck no see and I
also fuck knows you know let's doctor fucked
is so now we're going to do you know we're
going to have a delay or no traction cuz we
can't have an opinion here
is it Mexico's if you're interested to come
in
actually white pages are they going to
search the web page I know what you're
talking about when I click view page source
action code like if you were to enter this
command line absolutely from the web page
actually are who is the server but yes
was that I'm going to talk about Nick so
something out yeah that mean he'll do it
says this does remove options yeah it does I
mean
it's like a big the car to the emerald and
dynamic Yeah by different companies wanted
me to see and I yeah
cap has become the standard is very few do
not agree so you know I I would really love
some of you Heavy Hitters to talk about that
and just sit back and eating popcorn and
because I am just a newbie here right I am
just a newbie what video this video
video this video no nothing we talk about
here will ever be on YouTube unless it's on
Saturday
going to catch the ball over here in time
and come stop by you have 60 days to watch
the vod's if you want to come back and watch
him
this is not this is not an organized thing
by the way and it had all cash as well this
is not a sin than organizing I will
eventually summarize you know all the
mistakes I've made in a way that hopefully
will be helpful for beginners there's nobody
answering I know I think if I would agree
with you on that as well I think you would
agree for sure if those are all good things
I I don't want to spend too much energy on
the communities on metal of conversation but
I think that is the future personally
yeah ain't loyal calicos not making a dime
off of it mindshare yeah
I need to be really interesting I don't know
if I would probably have more information
and I don't I don't know at all I don't have
any any bead on the game that's going on in
the car. Space I know what I need to know to
do my job and then this is Neo that I try to
identify the leaders using landscape or
whatever but so I know what to learn a I
know what does I know it is Gabby can owes
canoes on middle Sodus are oh I think that I
think that that space is shaping up in an
interesting way and that's all I have to say
about that I would love to see metal burned
in kubernetes at some point
I mean what about from our communities
I know it's like you think it's crazy but
the k3s stuff people are starting to think
that way so
you know when you can get it anyway it's a
really fun exciting thing to think about it
has no relevance to your job today it's mine
but but the idea of being able to
be able to totally encapsulate away
everything you know about the hardware and
then and then just managed just the one the
one in point as opposed to to you have to
manage to in points if you don't use this
and that's why it kept me is For The
Straight Guy
so it's great I'm really glad that you have
been has been in that for so long has been
really fun to hear what you have to say
about that when I get into it
running has coronavirus which they acquire
to be there in less. For the company's
platform yes they did and included at the
time I remember Rancho s was a kind of
involved to let you in and a fork
so I guess we had so much fun it cheaper on
computer to the master and second chorus is
Dad after they got ahold of a programmer and
I was like holy shit and they said yes and I
wasn't going to let you know it's not as
well with the Linux kernel but all the stuff
around the edges is all is all is all go and
I was like why did they do that and Russ
orsi or something like that I don't know
they didn't go
yeah they got rid of everybody ain't got rid
of it yeah
a very much thanks Jennifer but that's why I
don't like right at there's a lot of reasons
I don't like her that but you can't deny
that red has to go to the go to distro for
Enterprise even if openshift isn't that
definitely is
so that's why I'm focusing on in the
beginning by the way there's any beginners
out there still listening we're going to
we're going to do the MRI with a p t 12 so
you can get used to the APT package manager
and then when we get to the in for surgery
stuff going to be doing we're going to be
doing would be red hat because that's my
hands down the Enterprise leader for that
stuff and then if somebody wants to go
forward and get right at certified whatever
I I think I I I I I I don't have a handle on
it I hope that's true but having gone
through the pain points of just trying to
set up Ubuntu servers vs. Enterprise servers
that I just did just in my short little
thing here and it was much easier to set up
the redhead stuff
and that's all I have to say
do I get from Red Hat yeah yeah I know
redhead look redhead is a really good at
making you think you have to have it
but aren't you want them or do you want you
do you want to just do that is famous for
making desktop Linux
what do you put on there Debian what were
you going to go what you going to do besides
redhead Susan
Susan is good then we're very aware supports
whatever you want
WhatsApp
I don't know I'm kind of interested in Alma
is going to control that shit forever
like yeah it's expensive for sure it is
sindicato absolutely 450 weihnachtsmann
Drake
I don't know we went with a pretty good
debate about that discussion the other day
about what the best but it was the best
Enterprise Linux distro and their strong
opinions on that all around
what I want to know is can you get it can
you put Elmo s can you put can you put Alma
8 in your Enterprise in production and not
and get away with not paying somebody for
rent at support
you have to let me know that you got that
enterprises love the support contract that's
what they love and the banks might not like
it but some of mine up don't like paying the
money but they pay Microsoft for crazy
or clinics you know what you'd be surprised
yeah
I know there's no there's no winner ass
always everybody's different
but I think the The Lion's Share of the
district Market if we can measure it this is
really we talked about this before just in
general on this channel about people's
warped ideas about distro is based on
YouTube and twitch and rented versus the
reality was actually deploy to the number of
this was it have been deployed if you can
watch the store too for an hour and year and
he'll never ever tell you a breakdown of the
distributions as as as as it could be
counted within the Enterprise because it had
the fucking numbers nobody does
and so it's it's downright irresponsible to
say oh arches the best sister for this in
this in this or or dipping is better because
of X and Y and meanwhile millions of systems
millions and millions of systems of rain the
most important software and applications in
our world are running on these dishes that
nobody sees because they're behind a
secretive Walled Garden and nobody has any
idea
and if you want to get anything close to an
idea you got to subscribe for $50,000 to
Gardner Medical Group who goes through and
interviews all these companies and pays a
high price dollar to get some indication of
what those companies are doing what's the
time they lie about it and they come out and
tell you they charge anyway it's a total
rocket as a total wreck if you want to know
the truth if you want to know the truth of
what distros are being picked by the most
people
at the sitio level in a huge Enterprise or a
multinational corporation you cannot find
that information you can't get it
he needs to Colonel Kira nerys
well I agree with that except for I can I
can say oh I don't know three different
outer just last month that happened because
people think that way
it's no you have to think about this is the
problem this why you think I want it I want
to see them merch
I want to see the merger because the outages
we've had every single outage has been
related to kubernetes combining in a bad way
with an operating system and Legacy iptables
shit that is fucked up our Network and is
nothing to do with me this is nothing to do
with me I'm just telling you the reality the
reality is that the underlying host OS
matters and a particularly if you've done
anything special with with networking or in
a monitoring and stuff like that
yeah I would like I would love for the
colonel Kira nerys to be the way to go the
problem is it's never going to happen that
way
and if I don't I wish you would I would do
that so that's why I think
that's what is why I think Cyril's is on the
right track this something important as soon
as as soon as we can buy Hardware that's
already been provision for kubernetes you
just flash the firmware whenever you get the
latest and you're worried about the security
and it's all it is is accurate is no to the
end and it's completely and totally locked
down and nobody talks to it except for the
vendors and you know and that's going to
Viola gplv3 and all kinds of shit I want
that if I was buying if I was buying a big
lots of big Iron I would want that because
it would be cheaper to maintain it would be
so much easier to configure and if there's a
problem you know you have one one point of
contact to deal with when if there's a
problem
so the problem is doing that is like it's
it's making tons and tons of Highly
opinionated decisions about what's going to
be on a thing right now one of our biggest
challenge is keeping up with the video
fucking drivers we are a huge fucking
machine learning cluster huge and our
biggest challenge one of the biggest
challenge is keeping up with NVIDIA drivers
now you can do that for kubernetes I'm sure
professional essay cluster and cluster API
you know
and it's a pain in the ass it's a pain in
the ass getting your driver here in
yeah mix have to be a speaker
but if you can shoot a few guys that would
be up I think that's where it's going but
that's not where Legacy Hardware is
and nobody has a BF a BF ebpf for anything
close to it deployed in production right now
bacon image I think that's what you should
do just make an image into it the problem is
you sous-vide bacon images and you have a
you know they do make an image by the way
they they have one in the oven Sybil like
tweak it after that now they have Chef trips
I forgot we're still in Chef our
infrastructure citizenship
which is another reason it's not so bad that
learning Ruby there's so many people still
using that shit
let me know what the value is Oh you mean
you're going to have it here it is
it's in my. House as am I. Might imagine
she's in there
inkifi eat
so yeah I would die for you to drop
what's that yeah
are they going to say Paul is image-based
yeah well I think that's that's where it's
going I think it is going towards images do
do you know if they got any of video
supporting here
a proportionate have you done any no teacher
discovery
he probably I don't know if you have or not
and I know it's it's only barely out of beta
it's pretty cool it's pretty cool you
probably have but if you haven't I'm just
curious
knowing Peter discovering a Jeep your future
discovery which is a beta it lets it let you
create a finiti rules for an increase sexual
tables that are based on CPU and something
up
Kevin doesn't need a discovery every
applications due
navigation developers wanted to cuz they
want to make sure they're running out of
each 100 Review 100 whatever the fuck they
want to be able to make sure that themselves
and they don't need it
I know all right well it's a different
question then we'll save it for later
and dr. Kirby images of pain is the drivers
in it for the Knicks visit or yes they have
they have they have their own Uber Hub by
towards stuff which is our stuff is all the
stuff is completely incompatible with the
Jupiter images I've been I've been dying for
them to get that because as well I kind of
went to bed now this is interesting
I've got a detection method senior IB 600
text message
this is one of our kind of surprised if you
register to terminal valid IP addresses to
choose from I'm going to need that
that was that was a good today to leave in
the dust
I'm sure I have all the savedvagrant destroy
so I don't blow my computer away
yes-siree-bob
commit skates
do do do pod Network cidr
there we go status
I can push with fish
And that's going to get a tag
golden I'm going to keep moving the golden
tag around anybody who actually
wants to
and I forgot I combined it with me
everything I mixed all my labs together now
so any of my foibles and and failures are in
The Labyrinth home so if you want to run a
vagrant from scratch
and get a working caretti's cluster by
with an f s support you can run this and we
haven't got CRCT I'll look and take her to
bed and then you just run in it here and you
run your joint in your dad for California
done I'll probably actually add those to the
steps and tomorrow I'm going to be adding a
storage interface Source plus I don't have
the storage place right now
so what kind of an fs-50 amount so I can
race components ATM what you did
and yeah control plane curious
okay then I could say if I hadn't seen the
filet
boy Calico see you and I
so they had ever hearing it pods warning
this step requires some careful
some care when working with vagrants
which has horrible networking and takes over
the defaults eth0 interface
all right and show me the worker nodes
why didn't you do this initialize kubernetes
it says control plane
plane with comedian
join the worker noses next Alpha Calico cni
Curtis tours class manifests and I will be
done with this so I can actually go back to
the text what I want to test so I can be
working on this
and I don't know if I'm going to do it
tonight or not what time is it
what time is it I probably stepped down God
damn it already
shut all right well I got to go to bed
we need to do stars class before I go does
anybody here have any links About Storage
classes that you would suggest
oh and lots of different things
it's so yeah what would y'all
think about that do what your buddies
reschensee and we talked about if you're not
even any filters you should you should be
good to go
is there anybody's this is Marquis it's over
here is
I I don't I don't how do you spell transfer
everything
yeah you should be using filters in that van
bench it at all
at 7 history mode
here is something you're supposed to rain in
Festus, Romans yes I heard that too it's not
a defense though when I'm trying to find his
son in a storage cost for my room and I
don't have that it so that's why I'm going
to start tomorrow I don't know what I'm
going to start but I'm going to start really
early I'm really need to get that done I've
got a ton of shit to get done for work and
the stuff is is not holding me back but
everything we've done has been essential has
been really really essential but I need to
start
providing Somebody by a Praying a monitor
and some stuff there's nothing like a virgin
you don't need one for a simple fast mount
what I'm trying to say is is there a is
there a default provision for storage by the
NFL storage glasses built in a kubernetes
Wikipedia I guess that's the question or is
that a batteries not included as well
oh thank you for that link just won't
preciate it pottery she ate it
but it down here with the rest
oopsie that's my mistake
thank you I'm trying to decide what I need
to go read before we go do our thing
tomorrow I want to do some reading before I
jump in
and I think an offense is pretty much
and then a false class you need
understanding in Natok Safa and other stuff
time for bed for me I don't know if I'm
going to actually sleep from defecating on
wide who should we be buddy to read
I mean I just go look real quick
and see who we got here 0nyx up it's talking
about football today to science
oh Danny's building cool shit
2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2 2
I want to build robots like her Fusion
building robots
I'm a shih tzu SolidWorks
I think the stuff is supposed to so cool
alright I'm a Raider
all right for me
by everybody Timo
oh I see a cake you I'm just about to rain
and taking off nice talking to you I am very